make sure you try to keep my attention
I didn't bring my dog today I was told
that was bad
Christina are we good to go
yes you were all set do you happen to
have a microphone next to you I just
wanted to see if it was on
yes I have this one here
here is on
it is on okay maybe move it closer to
your mouth if you could
is that better oh that's amazing perfect
thank you so much
and Christina it I'm looking we have two
uh representative Tom Dolan's I think
representative piamonte needs to be
renamed I'm happy to do that awesome and
can we make him a co-host too please
absolutely thank you
I was wondering
going in and no side effects other than
just being a little bit tired
the next day so that's good and well
during the second shot
no uh you know my arm was a little sore
but that's what
exhibition same thing
or the
non-management members of the committee
it's pick on the chairman and
co-chairman's hair day yes okay
Christina
this is Christina this is representative
terlevins yes hi could you um correct
the spelling of my name I've tried to
correct it a couple times and it keeps
popping back okay last it's e-n not a n
absolutely thank you so much you're
welcome if we're going to make sure that
piamante is you know correctly
identified you should all be correctly
identified absolutely I gotta follow his
lead absolutely everybody is piling on I
want you to know I was the one that told
them to spell your name oh Piemonte
thank you so much it gave me extra
attention
foreign
so chairman you're all set whenever you
want to start thank you
all right okay
okay before I get started I want to
bring up an issue that
yeah the ranking member and I have been
wrestling over
the last few meetings and neither one of
us had it exactly correct but it was a
it's a good teachable point and it's
about
how you how you make a motion on a on a
favorable
um
idea that needs an amendment about how
they went first or second or whatever so
here's
here's the uh the script of how you do
that
so you would raise your hand and then
say Mr chair I'd like to move
OTP
on House Bill
1000 and offer Amendment zero two nine h
and then uh what happens is then we go
to the amendment to make a vote and then
uh depending on how that go turns out
then we uh either make a new motion or
we go back to the OTP motion
so that's how that's how that's done and
we'll I'm sure we'll have an opportunity
to practice that sometime today
[Music]
yeah
thank you
Sharon's uh
script for to start the meeting uh
please pay attention to this especially
those that you're in the public as chair
of the municipal and County government
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67 and
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body is authorized
to meet electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
an executive session may follow
please note there is no physical
location from members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously
this meeting however in accordance with
the emergency order I am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listened and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available to in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice of this meeting implies with
house rules and RSA 91a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS leg.state.nh.us
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
Christina Daya is the staff assisting us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll calls vote so let's start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there's anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to
NOLA and of course that's for those
people participating via Zoom platform
Mr clerk please take the role
here
if MLB
here in the LLB
insurance
here and there will be
right
Home Alone
here in the LOB
um
you're at home alone
present in the yellow B
representative
present at home
my husband's in the house but not in the
room with me
good morning Mr clerk I'm here in Dover
New Hampshire alone and the cat is
napping
good morning I am at my home in Exeter
and my husband is somewhere in the house
and I'm sorry Mr clerk but your your
sound is breaking up could you hold your
microphone closer to you please
we have a microphone
you're probably using the one that's in
front of uh
good morning I am here in Northampton in
my home alone in my office
Davis
good morning Mr chair I am present I am
home and I am alone
[Music]
Namaste I'm in my home in Nashua alone
in my family room
representative fan
I am in my house alone in Peterborough
New Hampshire my husband is in the house
but not in the room he
home here thank you representative
yes I am here I can hear the proceedings
um I am in uh my home in Nashua my
husband is in the house
um but not in this room
and representative Gallagher
I'm here in my apartment in
um Concord and um
if you at all please rise and join me in
the pledge
um
thank you
[Music]
okay today is uh is our last
uh session for this first the first half
before we get to uh crossover
so uh congratulations to the committee
this is a municipal and County
government committee so congratulations
to the committee for the hard work we've
uh when we're finished we will have
processed over 40 uh bills that have
come to the committee
and
and we'll uh
what we are scheduled to have a fairly
long day today so I would I would uh ask
that you not be shy about asking for
breaks if you feel like you need them
just to get up move around and stretch
or take a uh a bio break or whatever
don't don't wait for me uh to give you
breaks please just put your hand up and
uh we'll certainly take some breaks to
try to break up the day I anticipate
we're going to go deep into the
afternoon so
please bear with us and those of you
that are testifying some of these bills
will be short some will be quite lengthy
so uh I I ask you to keep your remarks
on point
and succinct
and that will be appreciated by all uh
people listening and to those who are
waiting to testify behind you
today we're going to start uh
and reopen the hearing uh that we
recessed last week on House Bill 588 and
as a reminder that's the bill about tiny
houses that we had had begun last week
and so we're going to start and I'm
going to turn it over turn the floor
over to representative maggiori if uh as
one of the co-sponsors of the bill if
there's additional testimony that needs
to be heard and also for the committee
to ask questions so representative
managiore the floor is yours thank you
Mr chair and thank you members of
Municipal and County government last
week I appreciate the conversation that
we had on House Bill 88 which is
relative for the building codes for tiny
houses I want to start off this meeting
by saying that an email that I sent out
late last week
uh regarding an amendment which would
have been number two zero two one zero
six three zero H
um I am not going to be offering that
Amendment uh so please disregard again
zero six three h as in Harry I'm not
offering that Amendment there is one
Amendment uh to this bill uh the
amendment that was offered the last time
which is two zero two one zero five one
zero H and that Amendment removed
the wheels uh or all references to tiny
homes on wheels from the bill
since our discussion last week uh there
have been no additional changes to this
bill uh as as it was proposed so uh I I
I I welcome any questions or comments
from committee members uh from there so
thank you then be happy to to offer an
additional summary of the bill if anyone
needs it
today anybody like representative to do
a summary yes representative
this is going to do the summary first
however if there's a request
uh I have a question
uh
before we get to that representative
status did you have a comment
I I do Mr chair but it's not relative to
588 so I will lower my hand and raise it
again at the appropriate time okay thank
you uh representative trip from right
ahead
uh thank you Mr Derek uh thank you Mr uh
representative thank you uh there was
some question about uh uh the attachment
of uh appendix 2 I don't see anything on
that yet
is is that forthcoming
the thank you representative Tripp for
the question
um appendix Q is the Crux of our entire
issue here and because appendix Q for
those who may not know is the uh it sets
forth all the regulations for tiny homes
including uh the the primary issue maybe
not the primary the Salient issue which
establishes the size of a tiny home
which is less than 400 square feet we
feel that uh since this was already
adopted in the uh the IRC the
international residential code those are
the codes that all building officials
will have to go by when these tiny homes
uh need to be need to be uh inspected
and and therefore including it in the
bill seem to upon further discussion uh
be redundant it already exists uh and
that was the issue at hand that's why we
considered I should say that's why I can
considered the amendment but I have
learned that it is not necessary now to
include that Amendment
and I hope that answers your question
uh
where would that be available
appendix Q yes
uh thank you for the follow-up appendix
Q is in the is in the IRC and I
apologize I don't have I don't have the
reference number to it but I can get it
for you
I can get it and I can send it to the
entire committee
thank you sure
thank you uh any other questions
representative majority or anything
about the
the bill 588.
yes representative Gallagher yeah sorry
I
um just forgot
um could you just remind us real quick
what the IRC stands for international
thank you representative Gallagher for
the question the international
residential code which is The Code by
which the building inspectors reference
for all of the codes uh when they're
doing their inspections on any home any
residential I think commercial
properties also no not commercial I'm
looking at the pros in the room so that
well IRC residential shame on me I
should listen to what I'm saying so
that's what that is and if again I can
send out the specific reference uh two
tiny homes in the IRC plus a plus a link
to that uh for your information if you
would like
uh representative status do you have a
question we're just waiting here
um not about this bill Mr chair I want
to stay on this bill just uh do we uh in
the year thank you a lot of questions
representative maxiori or anyone else
who may have spoken to this bill earlier
last week
okay seeing none we will be executing
this bill this afternoon uh or if we
have some time this morning to do it uh
so stay tuned if you're curious about
how the executive section will go so I'm
going to close the hearing
um
House Bill 588 thank you very much
the next bill we're going to talk to we
have a hearing on is there is Bill
thank you
this is a
this is a bill about budget committees
and
let's see
representative power from uh from the
committee is actually a sponsor of the
bill
so I'll turn over her to introduce the
bill to the committee representative
Powell in Florida
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
my Telly fellow committee members I
appreciate the opportunity to to
introduce to you house bill 484 relative
to budget committee recommendations on
warrant articles for the record I am
representative Diane power I represent
the towns of Brookline and Mason in
Hillsborough County District 26. this
bill comes from a constituent request
in 2020 the town of Brookline formed a
study committee to examine the adoption
of an official budget committee the
chair of that committee brought to my
attention the following findings first
budget committees and some
municipalities are publishing
recommendations on warrant articles that
do not include Appropriations or
expenditures
furthermore the study committee was
informed by the New Hampshire Municipal
Association that publishing such
recommendations is not consistent with
New Hampshire statute the New Hampshire
Municipal Association has published
guidance stating that New Hampshire law
does not authorize the inclusion of
recommendations by a budget committee on
non-money articles
with that allow me to introduce the bill
this bill clarifies RSA 32 and that a
budget committee or an advisory budget
committee shall only provide printed
recommendations next to a warrant
article that includes an appropriation
or an expenditure
this bill before you is needed due to
the fact that when a budget committee
publishes a committee recommendation
pertaining to matters that are
non-monetary they do so outside of their
statutory authorities defined by RSA 32
colon 16.
pursuant to RSA 32 the responsibilities
of a budget committee or an advisory
budget committee is strictly fiduciary
whereas matters of policy and governance
rests solely with the governing body
according to the Hampshire statute it is
of significant importance to maintain
separation of both responsibilities and
authorities between the governing body
and the budget committee otherwise the
roles of each skip word and the
effectiveness as well as the authority
of each is eroded
in conclusion this bill clarifies the
duties and authorities of a budget
committee as it pertains to
recommendations published on warrant
articles and delineates the separation
of authorities between the governing
body and the budget committee
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee members for your time and
attention
chairman I am happy to answer any
questions at this time if you will out
are there any questions from the
committee of Representative 40 do you
have a question
yes I just had a question we don't have
a budget Committee in my town so I don't
know how they work but if a warrant
article uh representative didn't have a
dollar amount with it an expense or
Revenue with it but asks
who's voting in something that at a
future date will indeed cost money or
have revenues brought in
can the budget committee comment on that
under the provisions of this bill
thank you representative Porter could
you clarify your inquiry by providing an
example no I just was wondering if there
was a warrant that said we would like to
establish a uh commission to a committee
to look into building a youth center in
town
um and that was on the was the warrant
article and it would if it passed it
would it make money have to be spent so
that's the question that I have because
again I don't know we don't have a
budget committee it never comes up but
places that do would the budget
committee be able to say then the budget
committee does not recommend this
because the expense would be more than
we we anticipate or might be more than
we anticipate thank you representative
Porter for your clarification so
according to RSA 32
um section 16 the duties and authority
of the budget committee is clearly is
out clearly outlined and there are four
um main functions of the budget
committee and the first is to prepare
the budget the second is to confer with
the governing body the third is to
conduct budget hearing and
um the fourth is to forward both budget
and recommendations upon special warrant
articles to the governing body
and that is articles that propose an
appropriation so RS in statute special
warrant article is defined and that's
any article in the warrant for for a
annual or a special meeting that
proposes an appropriation
so that would include a budget article
as well as a warrant article that has a
monetary
um number two
thank you representative ViSalus
yes representative uh for taking my
question I think I know the answer to
this but I'd like to clarify it in our
town we have a number of Ward articles
this year that will be expending money
but they're not from current taxation
they're from taken from the uh the rainy
day fund if you will so there's no tax
consequences would the budget committee
make a recommendation in those cases
so you're referring to the case in which
thank you representatives lasalles for
your question so you're referring to a
Warren article in which there is an
expenditure
is that my understanding correct yes so
I I would say that under this bill that
the answer would be yes because an
expenditure is fiduciary there is a
dollar amount and furthermore an
expenditure
assumes that there was an appropriation
at one point in time
okay thank you and let me this is the
chair I I would uh I want to ask a
question uh
as a follow-up to uh
representative Porter's earlier question
if
um
I know in Londonderry we have by by
custom not by Statute we have a
a rule that that already
includes this practice where if there's
no money being spent uh that the budget
committee is silent on the on the
warrant as as is the Town Council
however
there's nothing that prohibits members
of the budget committee or members of
the Town Council to speak individually
as members of the public either for or
against a particular Warren article they
just don't speak
as a member of the body on behalf of the
body that they serve
so I I believe that would still be uh
allowed
representative power is that correct
um thank you for the um the follow-up
chairman Dolan that is correct this bill
here pertains only to
what is published in the warrant
so therefore
discussion conversations that is not
addressed in this bill it's only what is
published printed in the warrant
okay uh representative Mentor you had
your hand up earlier did you did you
still want to speak or is that uh
well I I do but I will I'll yield to
representative Gallagher and
representative tree Levin because I
think we're dancing around the answer to
my question I just have to see that it's
been answered so thank you
representative Gallagher you're next
uh there is
um one email we got raising freedom of
speech concerns with this particular
bill could you address those concerns
please
yes thank you representative Gallagher
for your inquiry
um freedom of speech
um is
is not
does not come into play in this bill
as I had stated earlier it pertains only
to what is printed in the article
discussion debate conversation is not
the um intent of this bill
and representative treeleven thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
power for taking my question you've used
the word fiduciary and I believe it was
also in the statute that you um read to
us could you I use that word in my
practice
but I'm not sure it's being used in the
same way that I understand it so could
you just give me a quick definition of
fiduciary in this case thank you thank
you representative true Levin when I
used that term I'm referring referring
to money monetary
um items
thank you
and representative do we have uh James
Le favor on the on the line
we do Mr chair and he should be all set
to speak and so the favorite you you are
please introduce yourself where you're
from and whether you oppose or support
this bill
yes
Mr Lafave are you with us
okay while he's getting uh his uh
communication squared away let's try
Brian Raider uh Mr Raider could you
identify yourself where you're from and
whether you oppose or support the bill
Mr chair Mr Raider is here too but for
some reason
wow
not 100 sure why we are not getting
Mr Raider or Mr Lafave
all right well let's go to uh let's go
to uh nhma Cordell Johnson
and we seem to be having I'm going to
ask if Mr chair with your permission uh
if Christina our
assistant is on the line to help because
I see all three members here
that you have called and the fourth two
we have four members uh all here but for
some reason I can't get them
chatting with us Christina are you on
the line to be able to help out
all right I'm gonna do this uh
pursuant to my uh opening script I'm
going to recess the uh the meeting for
five minutes and see if we can iron out
some of our technical uh
issues and we'll reconvene it at 10
minutes past nine o'clock
so ask
a follow-up from uh representative
Christina if you can hear me we're
having some technical difficulties that
need some help
yes
I've never heard the term War though
so well the thing is we have a bill
coming out there it says that uh
is
yeah
well but it's it would be done
so she it would if it's not on the
official Midway yeah how would it
if exploded off unless
right
I've just never heard that
obviously there's two types of values
because
Mr Raider can you hear me this is
representative Jim majory yes I can hear
you very good the problem may be fixed
I'll ask you just to hold on and
apologize for the inconvenience we'll uh
we'll be back in just a couple of
minutes great thank you thank you
vote on
it yeah
the warrant contains the Articles if you
have traditional autonomy then that
those warrant articles are acted upon at
the time
or like a slip of paper yes no ballot
and then additionally certain some
special
um
there are special items in statutes
example the adoption or to descendants
to you that
to rescind it it has to be on the
official
because that's the provision of
that question must be placed on the
official ballot to extent that's not
anything that can be voted upon however
law
to do that they took it off the official
balance so now to the thought that you
do it on the warrant at the time so does
the sb2 channel yeah after it's adopted
does it have a warrant is it beneficial
well you have a deliberative session yes
there's a warrant but then the official
okay
so dick was using the term worn out so
it's not such thing
Yeah official ballot
has those foreign
[Music]
all right ready to get started again
we are ready Mr chair and again I
apologize for the uh problem to view the
members and the public but we seem to
have fixed it
okay we're back in session on uh House
Bill 484
uh this is on budget committee
recommendations with their where there
are Warren articles that have no money
associated with them
um
but we live who has uh who has any
questions for
representative power
James little faith yeah oh I'm sorry uh
James Lafave are you with us
and he is with us and I have asked him
to unmute and should be all set to go Mr
Lafave uh welcome to the municipal and
County committee uh please State your uh
where you're from and uh what's your
position on the bill thank you very much
uh chairman my name is James Lehrer I'm
the current chairman of the callway
municipal budget Committee in North
Carolina in Conway New Hampshire and I
am testifying in opposition to the bill
I sent down a two-page written uh
summary of my uh discussion yesterday I
hope you all have received that
okay please proceed
thank you uh chairman
a few years ago the town of Conway
transferred ownership from a Town Road
to a business entity
Conway Municipal budget Committee of
that year I was a chairman held up this
legal transfer would impact on future
budgets even if it was solely a matter
of increase or decrease in the town's
road maintenance cost
on that basis a committee voted to have
the Conway Municipal budget committee
position on this Warnock a recorder for
the information of the voters the town's
legislative body
the attorney representing the business
disputed the Conway budget committee's
actions and African currency
I'm sorry about the phone going off in
the background folks excuse me for a
minute please okay
as I was saying
um the attorney representing the
business disputed the cnbc's action
after concurrence by the town of
Conway's Town attorney the record of the
Conway Municipal budget committee vote
was removed from the war knockout
following this event one voter at least
approached The Honorable Frank McCarthy
a former member of your committee to
address this situation with a revision
to RSA 32 colon 5 VA
representative McCarthy working with the
assistance of legislative services at
the time and the municipal budget uh
Municipal Association representative
excuse me drafted a bill HB 1392 which
following a minor Amendment from the
state senate with the support of the
municipal Association at the time was
adopted this bill's legislative intent
according to conversation I had held
with former representative McCarthy was
unable to be here today as he's out of
town was to allow budget committees to
vote on and have those votes placed on
all warnacles regardless of the monetary
impact HB 1392 was passed on June 12
2018 and went into effect on August 11
2018.
former representative McCarthy and I
both believe that the 2018 revision 2
RSA 32-5 Colt VA provides musician
function committees with the authority
record their votes and have those votes
placed on any Warren article proposed by
the governing body and then I quote a
portion of the bill a bill can a budget
committee adopted under RSA 32 colon 14
May on its own initiative required that
the tallies of its votes be printed next
to the effective article
as you have already discussed I have
read the contents of HB 484 and it is in
my opinion designed to ensure the mdc's
recommendation can be a fixed to the
effective War knuckle only when the
warnockle submitted by the governing
body or by petition includes an
appropriation or expenditure
apparently the town of Conway has a
proposed Warnock article number 22 for
the voters the legislative body
consideration on April 13 2021.
this Warren uncle has been defined as
non-monetary by the town's governing
body
this article calls for establishment of
a short-term rental Expendable trust
fund utilizing fifty thousand dollars of
taxpayer Monies
for our purposes of the short-term
rental coverage if HB 484 were in effect
today
this Warnock would be placed on the
ballot without a written without a
recording of fixed NBC vote simply due
to its designation is not on monetary by
the governing body as I understand the
law
it should be noted that the common
Municipal budget committee has supported
this warnaco by a 1200 vote on February
10 2021 during our public hearing and
that tally is listed on the ballot today
subject to possible stripping later due
to timing concerns
wow a cut to the fact of Chase I request
that this proposed change to RSA 3215
colon five you do an inappropriate to
legislate and any all of that
appropriate version be used to
effectively defeat this bill and provide
all NBC's The undoubted ability to vote
on all warnockets to be considered by
voters the local legislative body at a
time meaning be that under sb2 or the
judicial town meeting in closing I wish
to thank you for your time and your your
courtesy and listening to my somewhat
disjointed unfortunately due to the
nature of our presentation today thank
you very much for your time
representative and the committee thank
you for your testimony are there
questions from the committee
for our speaker
see now move on to the next speaker
Brian Rader uh please uh State your
location and uh and your position on the
bill
all right
um I'm Brian Rader I'm at my home in
Brookline and I am opposed to the bill
um good morning I'm Brian I'm the
chairman of the Brookline finance
committee and a member of the Hollis
Brookline Cooperative School District
budget committee I am testifying in
opposition to this bill because there
are many warrant articles that have
significant fiscal impact that do not
include an appropriation or a specific
expense for example in Brookline this
year we have a warrant article to move
grades seven and eight from the co-op to
the town to the town School District
this would require the town to build a
new school and to hire more step
teaching staff the cost of this are
enormous but the article itself does not
have an appropriation or a specific
expense
there are several warrant articles that
change the way that funds are
established and affect the transparency
such as an article to allow the schools
to retain two percent of the unassigned
fund balance or an article to change
where the cable access funds are
deposited we have articles that make
changes to property tax exemptions for
the elderly and disabled we also have a
warrant article to change the town's
advisory finance committee to an
official budget committee
the voters expect the finance and budget
committees to take positions on Warren
articles that have a fiscal impact or
significantly change the way that funds
are handled or that significantly impact
our particular committees in particular
for sb2 school districts like ours many
voters go to the polls without taking
the time to find out what is on the
warrant the recommendations printed will
be the only source of recommendations
for some voters
in the end these are only
recommendations and each voter decides
for themselves how much weight to apply
to the recommendations we do not need
conquer to micromanage our how our towns
are run and we should not restrict the
voter's ability to get recommendations
from their own town committees thank you
very much Mr chair and the committee
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee members
seeing that will move to our next
uh testimony from Cordell Johnson from
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
foreign
thank you Mr chairman again Cordell
Johnston for the New Hampshire Municipal
Association and uh when we looked at
this bill we thought that this uh really
just uh restarted existing law
um and
tended to agree that there is no that
that budget committees should not be
submitting recommendations on items that
have no uh no monetary impact I guess
listening to the and so I was inclined
to say that
um we think the bill may not be
necessary but it may on the other hand
it may not
hurt to clarify you know if the budget
committee is submitting recommendations
on for example proposed zoning
amendments or anything
nothing to do with with monetary issues
it may be helpful to clarify that they
can't do that listening to the uh prior
two speakers
um I guess I I do see now that it
um the bill says
um you can only submit a recommendation
if the article includes an appropriation
or expenditure
and there may be articles that don't
include an Express expenditure but are
still going to cost money
so I so to be honest I'm not sure where
that leaves me
um I guess I think it requires some
consideration
um and if the committee is is taking
final action on all bills today
um perhaps this is something that could
be retained for further study because I
do think it is
um it's an issue that warrants some
consideration
Johnson any questions from for the nhma
no questions next speaker will be
pronunciation as a g hand
or Kian
coming with the pronunciation I had to
unmute yes it's uh Tom Guillen yeah uh
Tom would you please state where you're
from and what is what your level of
support is for this bill certainly thank
you my name is Tom Gehan I am from
Hollis New Hampshire and chair of the
Hollis budget committee uh I am before
you this morning to voice my opposition
to this bill
uh some of the reasons have already been
touched on by other speakers I'll try to
be brief representative Porter asked for
some examples of uh non-appropriating
articles that would be relevant for a
recommendation from the budget committee
Mr Raider touched on a couple I would
add a few uh in addition to the elderly
property tax exemption there's the
veterans property tax credit which in
our town can run to an expenditure uh of
approximately a hundred thousand dollars
uh just a few years ago we had an
article before us
that proposed changing the uh land use
change tax from the general fund in the
town to the conservation committee that
did not appropriate dollars but it
reduced uh our Revenue by hundreds of
thousands of dollars uh Mr Raider also
touched on the Cooperative school
district of which he is a member of the
budget committee there every five years
uh in Hollis Brookline we see discussion
about the apportionment of net costs
again that is not an article that
appropriates money but the result in
subsequent years affects appropriations
of literally millions of dollars
um
RSA 32 in terms of its setting its
purpose for the budget committees is to
assist the public assist voters and
prudent use of public funds I think it's
vital that budget committees are uh
remain able to make recommendations on
articles that do not expressly
appropriate funds but nonetheless have
tremendous Financial impacts on our
towns the other point I would make in
closing is
um
our budget committee and I think budget
committees in general bring a lot of
experience uh to town Affairs on my
committee we have a member I have a
member who is retiring this year after
50 years of service to our town as a
selectman school board member budget
Committee Member and Myriad other roles
um these are the type of folks that
serve on budget committees our voters
and neighbors ask us our opinions on
these and want us to take positions and
in closing I think it's a good thing to
hear from our elected officials I don't
know why we want why we would I don't
know why we would want to suppress their
recommendations
that's it for me thank you very much I
appreciate the opportunity to speak
before you today thank you for your
testimony are there any questions for
those who testify that was our I believe
the last person that indicated on the
sign-in sheet they wanted to testify for
the public for me he joined us joining
us a contemporaneously
are there any members uh representative
Matthew Dory that uh
indicated they want to speak I'll come
back to representative in just a second
I do see thank you Mr chair I do see uh
two hands up one from one new hand Eric
power and then Brian Rader's hand is up
whoop he was saying took his hand down
so I see two new hands Eric power and
Chris Hyde in that order
okay we'll start with Mr power
hello can you hear me this is Eric power
yes you sound fine go right ahead thank
you uh Mr chair and committee members
thank you for letting me speak in
support of HB 484
at the Brookline 2020 town meeting
voters approved a warn article to direct
our select board to form a study
committee
to determine the feasibility and
suitability of adopting official budget
committee for our town and school
district for RSA 3214 I was appointed to
the study committee and became the
committee chair
during our work that started in May of
2020 did we did a lot of study on budget
committees we learned a great deal about
the roles and responsibilities of an
official Bud com
consulted with peer towns having
official beer official Bud come across
the state
and we also consulted with the New
Hampshire Municipal Association New
Hampshire School Board Association and
New Hampshire Department of Revenue
we essentially became subject matter
experts on budget committees by looking
at them across the state and learning
about them
and this year our our warrant actually
includes a uh Warren article to look at
adopting a bud come in our town and
that's scheduled from March 27th and I
think in written testimony I provided to
a website if you're interested to learn
more about what the study committee
findings were on the budget committee
so in this effort we consistently heard
that one of the roles of a of a bud calm
is to include recommendations in the
warrant only on Town and School District
articles that have an appropriation or
an expenditure
known as monetary articles
and if you look at the nhma guidance on
their website under Municipal budget law
under their frequently asked questions
it says the question is whose
recommendations should appear on the
Warren articles and budget items the
answer is recommendations should appear
if at all only on appropriation articles
the law does not authorize the inclusion
of recommendations on non-monetary
articles
we also contacted their staff attorney
and got a prompt response confirming
this point
the responsibilities of the official
blood Com or fiduciary including
preparing and recommending operating
budgets making recommendations on money
monetary warrant articles and
periodically reviewing expenditures an
advisory budkom recommends on operating
budgets in monetary articles
non-monetary articles include those
involving policy and governance which
are under the purview of the governing
body generally a select board or a
school board these matters are outside
the authorities of a budcom as
prescribed in RSA 32.
in 30 RSA 3216 it describes this this
Authority and it points to the fact that
recommendations by a budget committee
should only be made on special warrant
articles in RSA 32-3 so the special
warrant articles are worn articles that
have an appropriation so you can see
what the law is saying right now
examples of non-monetary Articles
include requiring estimated tax impacts
on Warren articles adoption or
rescinding of official balloting like
sb2 establishment of study committees
with no appropriation or expenditure and
amendments to Cooperative School
District articles of agreement with no
appropriation or expenditure
interestingly our Hollis Brookline
Cooperative official budget committee
has included their recommendations on
all of these types of monetary articles
non-monetary articles over the past
decade despite the warn articles being
clearly outside their fiduciary
authorities and responsibilities having
served as a board member on the Hollis
Brookline Cooperative school board from
2014 to 2017. I was disappointed that
the co-op budget committee continually
insisted to include the recommendation
in Warren articles that were outside
their purview as you know the
non-monetary warrant articles
currently the language of rs30 RSA 32
does not explicitly prohibit a bud comp
from making recommendations
on non-monetary warrant articles in the
warrant unless you read all of the
pieces of it despite clear guidance from
New Hampshire Municipal Association and
common practice used by most budcroms
across New Hampshire to stay in their
fiduciary Lane
House Bill 484 provides the need of
clarification to RS RSA 32 so that a
budcom only provides recommendations on
monetary worn articles in the warrant
consistent with their fiduciary
responsibilities and authorities this
bill's proposed language makes it clear
that Warren articles involving
governance and policy receive
recommendations from the governing body
and not from a budget committee thank
you for your consideration and I request
that committee members vote ought to
pass on House Bill 484.
thank you Mr Powers there's a I do see
some questions from the committee I'll
start with uh representative 11.
let's go I'm still on here I'm sorry
um it's okay I'm sorry I don't have a
question at this time I'll lower my hand
I have a comment for the committee for
later thank you
representative uh majori
Mr chair but I think representative
Porter was before me okay representative
my hand always comes up first just
because I'm a co-host it's my fault
sorry
um thank you Mr chair thank you
representative Maggiore and thank you Mr
power for considering my question I'm a
little confused now by all this the RSA
that you list uh talked about that uh
said what
um
budget committees can
comment on on the warrant article
does that RSA prohibit them from
commenting
in the current law is there specific
language that prohibits the budget
committee from commenting on items that
do not have uh expense or expenditure or
Revenue such attached the question for
Mr power
yes representative Porter good question
the the language is not explicit enough
it's in the gray area in my opinion
that's the purpose of this bill is to
clarify that if you have different teams
by different attorneys looking at it and
that's why it needs to be clear
that that's the case because that's the
practice that most budget committees
have been following but there are cases
where it hasn't been followed in the
state and that's what the purpose of
this bill is is to clarify
where the budget committee should be
making recommendations and where they
shouldn't
um that's that's my opinion of it
okay next we'll go to representative
Maggiore and then representative Tripp
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
power for taking my question
um uh I have a I have an sb2 town here
in Northampton I served on the budget
committee uh so I have a little bit of
experience and I will say that our our
budget committee does not put its
recommendations
um on the official ballot
um
that just the way that it is but my my
question is maybe a follow-up or
piggybacking a representative Porter and
several others if if the budget
committee is going to invest the time to
discuss these issues and mine does my
budget committee spends an awful lot of
time discussing these issues asking
questions what is the harm with
providing if it's in statute at least
the possibility for them to include
uh their vote on this by saying because
right now as as we read it it says only
when the warrant article which which
only is shall which means you can you
can you don't have the flexibility to
say uh that they may so I'm just curious
why the objection to adding that if
they're going to invest the time and I
apologize for being so long-winded who
are you directing that question from Mr
power uh Mr power yes thank you Mr chair
yes this is a a challenging question so
there is going to be a line between what
the budget committee should be weighing
in on and what they shouldn't
and that that the uh the point of this
bill is to
you know establish what's policy and
what's governance versus what is an
expenditure and what is a an
appropriation and it's clear the the
primary role as in law is the
appropriation and the appropriate is
proposing the budget and then and then
Weighing on on Appropriations that's
really the function of a budget
committee
there are other articles that made down
the road almost every worn article that
you can imagine will could at some point
in the future have a potential tax
impact but until it gets to a point
where it's quantifiable
and it gets down to a number it doesn't
make sense to have a budget committee
weighing in on governance like if you're
changing your curriculum or your um you
know you're changing you know In
Articles of agreement you're you're
making your school board larger or
smaller those types of things aren't
really appropriate for the budget
committee because those are really
policy and governance and if you have a
budget committee weighing in on those
you almost have
two governing boards
um and so this is trying to respect that
the governing board has certain certain
uh governance and policy issues that
they're supposed to weigh in on in the
budget committee has their uh Lane that
they need to stay in fiduciary and
that's the reason for this bill is to
kind of delineate where our budget
committee is appropriately commenting
and where they
um should not be commenting
thank you uh we have a question from
representative Tripp
thank you Mr chair uh thank you Mr
Potter for taking my question
um
it seems that uh
this is an SP2 issue or well it could be
an essential but uh
I'll use SP2 as an example
aren't uh this is the first session that
you delivered
uh
things like increasing the size of
school board or possible uh
things that will happen in the future
that might cost money to be discussed
by the uh the citizens of the uh
governing United States rather than uh
people having to rely on uh
recommendations of the budget committee
yes that is um representative Tripp yes
thank you for the question on that yes I
mean in an S we have sb2 in Brookline
for our school district but we have
traditional meetings for our town and
for our Co-op School District so we have
we experience all of the different
variants
and yes at an sb2 you definitely have
the discussion during the deliberative
session you have a discussion during
your uh your budget hearing
so there's a lot of opportunity to learn
about the uh about the Warren articles
all of the warn articles and so you know
the budget committee is can can provide
their opinion there's no freedom of
speech problem here because they can
definitely provide their individual
opinions and that's often asked at a
deliberative session or a traditional
meeting but what gets printed in the
warrant is important to follow the law
and the law is a little bit ambiguous
right now and that's the purpose of of
clarifying it to ensure that you know
everyone knows what should be going in
and what shouldn't be going in and so
voters can and do get educated at
deliberative sessions and at traditional
meetings before they vote
thank you representative Davis do you
have a question
uh yes thank you Mr chair and thank you
this is a question for Mr power
um
there seems to be a tremendous amount of
difference between something that's
inappropriate to be discussed or
appropriate to be discussed and
something that is prohibited by law from
being discussed and I don't see how that
is not a freedom of speech issue once
you legislate that someone may not
discuss something
you're infringing upon that person's
freedom of speech and expression
can you can you explain to me how you
are not doing that with this legislation
yes representative stavis yes the this
um this bill does not prohibit any
discussion this this bill simply just
makes the efficiency it prescribes the
format for the official warrant that the
warrant will only contain
recommendations for the governing body
when it's a policy and governance issue
the Warren article does not contain a
expenditure or does not contain an
appropriation then the budget committee
would not put a recommendation on the
printed warrant that does not prohibit
anybody from speaking about it at the
meeting at the sb2 deliberative session
at the additional town meeting that's
all still possible and it's encouraged
to the level that it makes sense
but it just it just keeps that it
ensures that the budget committee isn't
printing a recommendation on articles
that don't involve an appropriation and
expenditure on the official warrant
thank you representative Gilman
Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
power for taking my question
uh my question is uh are are you
concerned about uh because an sb2 town
has both a town ballot and a school
ballot uh if there's a warrant article
for the town for something large like a
12 million dollar renovation to the rec
park and rec park and then uh
um on the school ballot uh article for
repairing the roof on the middle school
that's also for 12 million dollars are
you con is the concern here that both
both will be considered for the tax rate
of the town and one will be competing
with the other and rejected because of
that competition
representative Gilman the to clarify on
this the both of those Warren articles
are Appropriations they're proposing 12
million dollars so the budget committee
if there was one would be able to weigh
in on both of those and they would
provide their recommendations because
they're involving an expenditure or an
appropriation that's what this law this
bill is is stating so it's really when
there's not an appropriation and there's
not an expenditure it's not the it's not
the role of the budget committee to
weigh in and so for those two examples
there the budget committee would weigh
in because they're they are spending
money
representative Mentor my my
Recollections we have one more
additional member of the public that we
should speak
very good recollection Mr chair Mr Chris
Hyde and I see no other hands up and if
you're ready I can uh ask Mr Hyde to
unmute yes Mr Hyde if you uh could
please uh uh State your location and
your position on the bill sure um my
name can you hear I presume you can hear
me now
um my name is Chris Hyde I am a resident
of Hollis I am a current member of the
Hollis budget committee uh prior to Mr
Guillen I was uh chair of the house
budget committee as well have sort of
done on that board for a number of years
um I speak in uh opposition to this bill
um we have heard from literally uh uh
hundreds of of our constituents in in
our town about the desire and need to
have input on a variety of different uh
things that come before the voters with
Rich do not associate in the article as
presented a monetary number uh uh to
appropriate or expend in that particular
year some of them are from petition
warrant articles that frankly are
probably malformed uh but others for
instance
um
things like articles of agreement which
have been raised uh here before have
been uh and continue to come up
occasionally uh that will indeed uh
necessitate a change in
Revenue uh expenditures and Taxation for
instance changing uh the composition for
instance of a uh a a class structure at
a Co-op level will wind up changing the
need to provide funding to do that it
may not be included in the instance of
that but it can be well anticipated that
there'll be an impact coming forward and
these types of things land use change
tax uh changes a variety of others that
have come before the voters they seek to
have a group that has a deep analysis
and vetting done and make a recommend
foundation and the reasoning associated
with this which is why they you know the
towns typically have established their
town as a RSA 32 town is to get that
kind of insight
presented to the public and then they
can take an alternate view which is a
good example we we made a recommendation
on a land use change tax in in Prior
year uh that would uh change and and
diminish the tax uh uh the revenues into
the town be applied to another uh
purpose
um and uh the town decided after hearing
it and welcomed and and was appreciative
of the input from the budget committee
but wound up going in a different uh
Direction and that's fine but they
wanted to hear and know after the
vetting that was taking place by the
budget committee with time and deep
analysis an ability to ask the questions
throughout the course of formation of a
budget that they had this vetting
process and so I speak against this
article because all it's really asking
to do is to take away a an ability uh to
weigh in on appropriate articles that
will have a impact Maybe not immediately
maybe not
properly conceived but don't raise a
dollar amount in the article but will
definitely have an impact going forward
so I'm I'm opposed to this uh and uh I
hope you will
um uh defeat this um and send it back
for study thank you well thank you for
your testimony we had a question for you
from representative Manchester foodie
sure
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Hyde for
taking my question so from your
testimony I uh correct me if I'm wrong
this will fundamentally change how your
town budget school committee budget
committee uh kind of changes or will be
limited your constituents voice will be
restricted am I correct yeah the uh
my view certainly is that with the
adoption of 44 as shown would definitely
change uh the input the desire from the
the public uh and and how the um the
budget committee uh acts uh in the
wishes or uh inputs from from our
constituents yes
and representative to 11 you had an
issue I think representative Tripp had
his hand up before me
representative thank you Mr chair uh
thank you for taking my question uh I
keep hearing the uh
the first freedom of speech
uh
during the discussion and that uh
removing the budget committee's ability
to comment on the uh the ballot
uh will be a freedom and speech issue uh
in my mind
the uh they're being to to comment or
provide a recommendation uh
is uh it's a freedom of speech issue but
it's uh it's more of a free event speech
issue in that uh there's no uh there's
no ability for the public to rebut that
recommendation
uh because they have no ability to make
a recommendation on the ballot I I still
contend that uh
these things that are are being placed
on a ballot or something that should be
done in either the delivery session or
during the town meeting uh what's your
opinion on this
had a question
is that for me yes Mr Hyde so I I didn't
raise a freedom of speech issue in in my
comments uh but in terms of uh you know
the deliverer to either we are not an
sb2 town in the in our town or Hollis
school districts we are in SB uh or or
at the uh Co-op uh so um I I don't have
experiences in sb2 town but so all the
Articles get raised at
um town meeting uh and there is ample
opportunity for members of the public uh
to ask and it generally is uh asked of
uh the the budget committees uh in
certain uh issues you know why did you
make this recommendation uh and give us
you know the the top couple of points of
of analysis this is the type of thing
that is asked for and expected uh by our
voters to give deeper analysis take the
time to review and form some
uh and recommendations to them they're
free then to uh make a different call
based upon what they've they've heard
and occasionally do uh which is all well
and good uh but it gives the opportunity
to make sure that it has received a
deeper uh background and that people
know what the future holds maybe not in
this particular year but if you change
the composition for instance of a
structure of a school district in uh in
different class sizes and know that
something is coming that will change uh
the need to raise taxes uh in one entity
or another or build a building to
accommodate or whatever that may be
then those are useful inputs that we
have heard time and time again from
constituents that they want analysis
done and inputs from the budget
committee
representative Philip did you have a
follow-up
uh I haven't asked a question yet but
yes I'd love to ask uh Mr Hyde a
question
Mr Hyde thanks first of all for your
testimony
um this has been on my mind throughout
this hearing and you've seemed to have
spoken about it I want to clarify
are we talking about unintended
consequences I.E a bill that talks about
adding a different grade to a school or
changing the way the perks and
Recreation Department runs their winter
or summer program
but doesn't have any money involved in
it
if we put this bill in place if there's
no Financial or fiscal
note then the budget committee can't
comment on it and that strikes me as
foreign
looking can I have your opinion please
precisely uh representative and yeah I
think you hit the nail on the head there
are a wide variety of different uh bills
both comes from from the the governing
body but also from petition warrants uh
that come that uh seek to do something
that will have a an impact and you can
know you know you knowly uh could
understand that there is going to be a
need to raise revenues uh somehow alter
those revenues from one place to the
other uh and give that input but there
is not an Associated uh dollar amount
placed in the uh the article and uh for
those things uh the voters have asked
kind of repeatedly to to have that kind
of insight from there we've been polled
at you know when we haven't made those
recommendations sometimes we get pulled
at the uh uh the the time however when
we're behind the the eight ball and
haven't really considered them before
then doing a polling at the uh the point
of of the annual meeting is not a very
efficient structure to give the really
good detailed analysis and consideration
uh and and provide that input to the
voters and so for those reasons uh you
know we we are opposed to this and it's
the unintended consequences of what this
this bill seems to to uh propose thank
you Mr Hyde
um and I have one last uh
a question
before we close the hearing uh for you
Mr Hyde
example in Londonderry where the town
that I represent
we have a Warren article this year
that's it's going to say something like
should the town manager
issue uh a letter
to the Speaker of the House in Concord
to make sure that any redistricting be
done in a fair and balanced man
that would be certainly a Warren article
that uh
that this particular legislation would
be targeting that there's really no
point for the budget committee to take
an official position on a warrant like
that like that's the truth yes I 100
agree there's if if it doesn't
ultimately result in anticipatively uh
result in a a expenditure and
appropriation needed a need to alter the
taxation of the residents there is no
reason to do that and and certainly a a
redistricting or otherwise for for
representation and voting or many others
uh to come before would have no reason
for the budget committee to weigh in
thank you and with that I'm close the
hearing
on House Bill 484.
okay next we're going to entertain House
Bill 411
which is to establish a study Commission
on Equalization rate for calculation of
property tax relations
representative merner was the from
co-host County was the uh was the
sponsor is uh do we have representative
representative Maggiore
Mr chair I do not see representative
merner
I will look in a few ways but I do not
see representative merner unless
representative comment has come in as a
panelist somehow so no I do not see
representative merner you have any
others that are indicating that they
they wish to speak on this bill
uh we uh yes I do see I do see the
members who are listed here but I I well
you've already opened the hearing so yes
I do see uh shirelle Lucas and George
Sans Souci both in our list
let's start with uh
Ms Lucas uh please state where you're
from and uh your position on the bill Mr
chair someone needs to introduce the
bill before we can start hearing it uh
good point uh uh Miss Lucas do you feel
uh comfortable introducing the bill or
Mr San Souci would you feel more
comfortable Mr chair it has to be a
representative or a senate a
representative to introduce the bill Mr
chair I'd be happy to introduce the bill
if you'd like
all right go right ahead
uh Representatives uh thank you for the
opportunity to introduce House Bill 411
I am representative Jim majori
representing the town of Northampton
Rockingham District 22. House Bill 411
is an act establishing a commission to
study the equals Equalization rate used
for the calculation of a property tax
abatement by the New Hampshire Board of
tax and land appeals to the superior
court and all cities towns and counties
thank you
and uh in the absence of
representative murder uh I'll ask
Ms Lucas to offer the first testimony
yes hi good morning are you able to hear
me
yes go right ahead you sound fine
great thank you
um in lieu of uh if I could defer the
first testimony to be
um
provided by Mr George San Souci I myself
have signed on just in lieu of any
technical difficulty as a standby so
I'll differ all testimony to Mr George
Sans Souci okay Mr San Souci would you
like to offer testimony please please
identify where you're from and your
position on the bill
yes can you hear me yes go right ahead
thank you very much thank you Mr
chairman and thank you wrap
majority for introducing the bill for Mr
murder who's over at ways and needs
my name is George San Souci I am from
Lancaster New Hampshire and I have
worked with Troy merner the technical
elements of this bill and uh wish to
very briefly I didn't Supply a letter to
his behalf on the technical elements of
the bill
very very briefly the requests of the
bill is to create a study commission to
look at the unintended consequence or
differential between how the abatement
of an abatement is paid based on the
equalization rate that's used to set the
value of a property and the equalization
rate that is used to calculate the
actual abatement in the event of an
appeal
this particular issue is easy to explain
in one sentence what needs to be
accomplished but it's actually becomes
very difficult in the technicalities of
how it operates and there are a number
of different solutions uh to to fixing
this problem it's a bilateral it's a
it's a bipartisan unintended consequence
of how we do Equalization in New
Hampshire
uh the general consensus amongst the
various assessors that I've talked to
and with Brett myner
he best handled in a study commission to
bring a consensus as to how to uh how to
correct this problem
uh my letter does point out that it's
surfaced in in Spades so to speak at the
last uh big Public Service trial 95
communities where uh several hundred
million dollars worth of unintended
value shift occurred in that trial
resulting in approximately six million
dollars worth of abatements
that related to the equalization issue
and not the value
a property that was under appeal the
appeal portion
and that has raised the uh
visibility of this matter substantially
I represent approximately 70 communities
and talking to you today as their
special purpose Assessor it is not just
related to utility properties it is it
is something that is magnified for any
large property whether it is a flash
shopping center the new construction at
Tuscany build Tuscan Village in Salem uh
for a major industrial property
Etc
we do believe that we understand that uh
you you
do not want to create any bills that
require committee activities
at this time because of covet so we are
asking in behalf of repurna to retain
this bill
uh going forward for later on this year
and next year this is an issue that's
been around for a period of time
and
what we have demonstrated through House
Bill 700 that it consensus and some of
these tough
Equalization and assessment issues can
be reached so we would respectfully ask
if the committee would consider
retaining this bill until later on this
year
uh with that I'm available to answer any
questions
and if I cannot I can certainly get
information to anybody evaluation time
so sure I'll Lucas thank you very much
consideration and I'm open for questions
Mr chairman
thank you representative Porter you had
a comment
now he's an old uh indication sorry
I don't know why my hand is up I'm sorry
any questions
for Mr Sans Souci from the committee
seeing none
um
uh do we have additional commentary from
anybody that's online or any member of
the public
we we do not miss the chair that I can
see
okay uh okay
representative we'll read it thank you
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question I'd like to make a motion
uh following your uh clarification
earlier this morning about the order of
uh presentation of amendments I would
like to move reconsideration of hb512
and consideration of the amendment to HB
512 which is just give me a second here
which is 0563h
okay uh that
that uh
motion appears to be in order but uh I
would request that we finish this
particular hearing before we accept that
motion is that acceptable to me
to the Committee Member
um how would you like me to go forward
when the hearing closes do you want me
to raise my hand again yes please
any other questions on Bill 411
seeing none
the hearing on 411 is closed
by the way the sign-in sheet had five
inch support and two opposed
and on the previous bill of 484 we had
four in support and 16 opposed
for those of you who would like to keep
track of them
hey next uh we had them we have a
ascending motion from representative
Davis could you uh
State your emotion please thank you Mr
chair happy too I would like to move
reconsideration of HB 512 and speak to
the amendment that that was offered to
that legislation which is amendment
0563h
h
a
Vern Dolan
um I do believe that that motion needs
to be done during an executive session
if it's already been heard
yes
um
what I'm considering is uh what whether
I should accept that motion and go into
executive session or wait do we go into
executive session
some other bill
[Music]
from the uh
let me take a recess for five minutes
before I accept your motion or decline
your motion uh just to get some
clarification on process
thank you very much Mr chair I
appreciate it we will endure it until uh
ten past tense
Jesus
I'm sorry that's a recess
really happy
thank you
questions
and then
I don't think
no they wanna they wanna
well they have to go through
reconsideration books yeah represent uh
Mr chair there was an amendment that uh
Representatives Davis listed
oh five six three h of the last four
digits
05638 thank you and we had that um when
we exempt that bill last week
[Music]
and Christina has emailed it to us as
well
great
thank you representative Porter
you're welcome
okay we're back
so we're going to resume our session
we're in the in the midst of uh public
hearings and we've had a request by a
member a Committee Member to go into
executive session to reconsider a bill
from the other day I'm inclined not to
accept that motion
because we're not in executive session
now and that we should wait until we do
an executive session I went to seek some
guidance I went I was unable to find any
so I'm going to I am going to rule uh in
favor of going into executive session
now
just out of deference to uh our
Committee Member who wants to make a
motion
I will get further guidance and uh offer
that to the committee later but as of
right now we're going to move from our
hearings into executive sessions in
order to hear this motion uh for
reconsideration so representative stavis
go ahead and make a membership
chair I really appreciate this
opportunity
to offer this motion
um I moved to reconsider HB 512 and
speak to the amendment that was offered
which is amendment 0563h
and happy to speak about the amendment
if you would like uh in a minute the
first uh motion on the table is a motion
to reconsider is there a second on that
motion
a second Mr chair
okay so we have a motion to reconsider
for representative status and a second
by representative Porter
so is there any uh discussion on the
motion
[Music]
um I just
representative 11.
CU representative Porter your video is
off
there you are thank you I'm sorry Mr
chair to interrupt you
uh
representative McDonald
yeah thank you Mr chairman
I appreciate the representative motion I
just don't think
to deal with it right now with the 10
past tense and we still haven't done a
thing and I think we should have
consideration for the uh
time
in the video schedule to speak with us
and I think we should focus on getting
these
hearings back the motion to be
considered this afternoon
thank you
yeah yeah so thank you representative
McDonald I tend to agree however uh like
I said I I went to seek some additional
guidance and I was unable to find a
reasonable source for that guidance uh
right away but uh I I am I am uh I'm
calling balls and Strikes right now and
so I don't have any definitive guidance
why I I can't take this uh motion of why
the motion would be out of order other
than to your point that we are a little
behind in our schedule for our hearing
so uh is there any other comments
seeing that we have a motion to
reconsider 512
made by representative Davis and
seconded by representative Porter since
there are no other
uh questions or uh indications
for discussion I asked the clerk to call
the role on the recommend recommendation
to reconsider the motion to reconsider
ation
uh representative
uh yes
report folks know
representative chip no
representative Wallace no
probative representative of Silas I'm
sorry no
representative McBride no
representative Melvin no
representative
no
no representative power no
representative Porter yes
representative
yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative Davis yes
representative yes
representative van
yes
representative
representative Gallagher
yes
representative uh chairman uh yes
foreign
motion passes eleven to nine so we are
in a process of reconsidering House Bill
representative status do you have a
motion
thank you Mr chair I have a motion to
um introduce the amendment to HBO
which is amendment 0563h
let me let me interject here I think
what you're you're you want to make a
motion to is that you'd like to move OTP
on 512 yes and offer an amendment thank
you for the correction I deeply
appreciate it yes Mr chair I'd like to
move OTP on HB 512 and
um
give me some guidance here and
consideration of the amendment 0563h
a second that motion
thank you would you like to speak to
your member
yes thank you Mr chair wood uh this
amendment was made to the bill in
response to concerns that were heard
during the hearing and also in advance
of the hearing about
um unsafe or inadequate housing spaces
that may be found to house uh Indigent
persons in the state
uh so we um acknowledge those concerns
and we put this amendment in here to
condition the uh release of emergency
funding uh pursuant to our RSA
165 which which mandates that towns and
cities provide emergency assistance to
people who are unable to maintain
themselves it does not specify that
these people should be housed in any
particular way it simply gives Authority
it demands Authority from the towns and
cities to provide emergency housing
assistance or when people are unable to
do that for themselves therefore there
is no concern about building inspections
failing or not being performed and in
fact this bill HP 512 is designed to
keep people in existing housing rather
than to put them in sched to your
questionable housing as a condition of
their emergency thank you
does anybody have any questions on the
amendment
foreign
Mr chair I see one hand I see two hands
up from representative Porter and
representative manjibouti in that order
representative thank you Mr chair
um and I want to support what
representative Davis
um said the testimony that we heard from
the lawyer from the legal assistance
um was the one who recommended this
language to us for the amendment to make
sure it was clear that this bill was
only saying to the towns and cities that
this emergency funding is going when
people are trying to stay in the house
they have
so I you know I we all had the concern
about putting people into poor housing
and we all we asked those questions and
this was the language that came from the
legal assistance lawyer so I'm urging my
my colleagues to support this amendment
and to support the amended bill because
representative the next
thank you Mr chair sorry I had a glitch
here
um thank you representative
Stannis
I fully support this this will impact my
community in terms of not whether we're
going to fire
find housing or not this crisis exists
and this will only enable and help
our communities and to provide the much
needed
assistance in a crisis and I strongly
urge my colleagues to support support it
as it is very enabling and helpful thank
you
and next we have representative
Gallagher
um so
just a question for representative Davis
just to clarify the only words that the
amendment ads are pursuant to RSA 165
correct
that's correct
okay thank you
and next we have representative Davis
yes I just wanted to add thank you Mr
chair I just wanted to add that this
bill does not create any new emergency
housing assistance funds it's simply
prohibits towns and cities from
conditioning current emergency housing
funds on the completion of a building
inspection which many people in
emergency housing situations are not in
the position do not have the authority
or the resources to carry out
thank you representative
thank you Mr chair
um
my comment is
I've been thinking
I've been thinking a lot about
representative
Ayers commentary when we first heard
this bill and he um described what his
town does when someone is in an
emergency housing situation and he he
was pretty appalled that other towns
just didn't do this automatically and I
I feel like
this is a vehicle
that will allow other towns to do
automatically what they're supposed to
be doing and we'll provide all of our um
all members of our community a level of
safety that even though it's in an RSA
is not is not being
um
followed by all our towns so and again
representative air your commentary about
how your town handled it and you were
you were incredulous like what do you
mean they don't help them what do you
mean they don't go to the welfare office
what do you mean they don't get help and
my child may always do and I want every
time to be able to say that thank you
representative Tripp uh thank you Mr
chairman uh
I'm looking at the RSA 165 and uh if you
go to rsh 165 colon one the local
responsibility uh section that
says the guidelines shall include but
not be limited to the process for
application for general assistance Etc
et cetera et cetera
will so this amendment really the the uh
local town from uh from following their
uh their guidelines for uh granting
local assistance
I think that's for representative Davis
yes
thank you Mr chair and thank you very
much representative Tripp that's an
excellent question
um no this bill will not uh stand in the
way of any town or city uh
preventing emergency assistance from
being distributed based on their current
requirements under state law
okay uh so follow you have a follow-up
go ahead so if they're basic guidelines
say that there's an inspection does that
mean that they can't do the inspection
representative I'm sorry is that a
question for me yes
thank you representative Tripp for
another good question no it does not
mean what I'm trying not to do a double
negative here
um
it does not stand in the way of any town
or cities enforcement of its current
obligations under RSA 165.
thank you
representative Davis if you have another
comment or uh you're just answering
thank you because I see no additional
comments or questions
so we have a motion on the floor
to uh op
OTP
uh 512 kind of reconsideration here as
amended do we have a second
then representative reporter yeah
Mr chair I think we we have to vote on
the amendment first yes yes okay
so the question now is on the amendment
in support of House Bill 512 uh just for
record purposes
Let's uh make sure we have the right
amendment number that's zero five six
three h is that correct
okay good so uh I'd ask the
the clerk to call a role on the
amendment
okay zero five six three h
uh yes
but folks yes
representative chip yes
representative Wallace yes
representative Salas yes
representative McBride
yes
representative Melvin no
representative yes
uh representative power yes
representative reporter yes
representative tree eleven yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
yes representative Davis yes
representative yes
representative van
yes
representative
and representative Gallagher yes
18 to 1. and I'm sorry Mr chairman yes
thank you
I don't think we could have a 1911
I'm sorry
okay we had a phantom Committee Member
for just a second and they have left so
the amendment passes 18 to one uh just a
point of uh
uskeeping here the uh I just got word
that the
there's a heating problem in the lob I
can't turn the heat off that's why it's
getting a little warm in here so we've
been advised that they're working on it
but we're free to open the windows and
get as much fresher as we'd like
all right so we have uh before us
uh House Bill 512 under reconsideration
with a motion to pass
okay to proceed as amended is there any
further discussion from the committee
before we take a vote
I just need a
first and second yeah
Representatives Davis now needs to move
out to pass as amended
Mr chair may I do so yes go right ahead
thank you Mr chair
Mr chair I move uh ought to pass as
amended HB 512. thank you is there a
second I'll second that okay uh
any discussion before we go to a vote
seeing uh ask the clerk to call the
rules
no
workbooks no
representative Tripp no
representative government
I'm sorry purpose of walls no
Representative no
representative McBride no
representative girlfriend no
representative here well
Representative no
representative Porter yes
yes
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
representative Davis yes
[Music]
representative
yes
representative please yes
representative Gallagher
yes
and Shannon no
uh
reconsider I have 12 and
otpa defendant 9 fails so my
understanding is we are now back to the
original
Bill 512 honor amended
is there a motion
is there a different motion that is in
your mind
so I'll make a representative
yes Mr chairman I'll move that uh
House Bill 512
move it be very inexpediate electricity
okay is there a second on 512. second
representative Tripp seconds
let's sell us
and trip
is there discussion before we go to vote
seeing none I asked the
collect the caller roll
okay uh IPL on 512 uh representative yes
but folks yes
representative Tripp yes
representative Waltz yes
representative lasalles yes
representative McBride yes
representative
yes
representative yes
representative power yes
representative
no
representative Gilman now
the majority
no
representative Davis no
Representative no
representative van
no
representative plea no
representative Gallagher no Kevin Dolan
yes
uh Ito passes
okay thank you
all right that closes the executive
session for our reconsideration of house
bill 512. we're going to go back into
the hearing mode
yes is there going to be less than
anyone
uh I I think because the disposition did
not change I don't think that we need to
do a second uh majority Report with the
initial report
our next bill to discuss uh or to have a
hearing on is going to be House Bill 392
which is relative to the membership of
local land history
and
we have uh representative samsich is a
prime sponsor is uh representative
president
uh one moment Mr chair I apologize
getting organized um
yes representative samsich is here and I
have requested or I've invited him to
participate there he is
thank you uh representative please uh
let us know where you're from and uh
although we know you but the public does
it so if you could identify where you're
from and your testimony on the bill
thank you Mr chair uh for the record I'm
representative Peter samsich from
District 27 in Portsmouth
and I thank you chairman uh chair Dolan
and committee members for giving me its
opportunity to uh provide you testimony
on H in support of HB 392.
um this testimony I've also uh sent to
you in five by email
um
this bill is relative simple and what it
proposes it proposes to change the land
I use board membership requirements
um the bill makes changes to the
requirements for serving on a local land
use board by requiring that all voting
members including ex-officio members
shall be residents of the respective
municipality
as the in the way of background in 2020
a planning board decision in Portsmouth
was appealed to the Superior Court when
a local planning board made a decision
with the votes of two ex-officio members
who were not residents of Portsmouth
the appeal made the assumption that all
the board members were required to be
residents of Portsmouth however as
currently written the RSA
um does not explicitly mention
ex-officio members
this bill makes clear that while except
the co members conserve on a municipal
boards and provide important insights to
be eligible to vote as a member of that
board the member must be a resident of
that municipality
uh the resident from Portsmouth who
brought this issue to the Superior Court
Mr Brock Brighton has also submitted
testimony and we wishes to testify today
as well
um the bill makes a change to uh RSA 673
colon 1 paragraph one so that it now
reads any local legislative body May
establish a planning board but it also
changes RSA 673 colon 2 paragraph six so
that it would read voting members of any
local land use board established
pursuant to paragraphs one through four
one through five including ex-officio
members shall be residents of the
municipality in which they serve
so um I would I am would be glad to uh
answer any questions uh on the other
hand uh um Mr Brighton who's testifying
after me uh wants to express his
personal experience with this so if
you'd like to ask me questions that's
fine uh otherwise uh Mr Brighton can
answer some as well thank you are there
any questions for representative somsage
yes representative power
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative songs that you are taking
my questions so
to be clear in the current statute
RFA 671
in the bill prints out on line three
members members do not include the
ex-officio members
just just by default or definition of
remember of a plan Accord is that
correct
my understanding is and and the superior
court I think underscored this is that
uh it is not specifically mentioned that
ex-officio members cannot be members of
that board so they assume they can be
such members yes
thank you
but they are not explicitly mentioned
okay are there any other questions
representative piamonte yes thank you
chair and thank you representative
Summers for taking my questions
can you explain the need for this uh
the ex-officio
um
people that are placed on the boards
generally don't have on especially on
planet books do not have a vote
well well uh in contradiction to what
you just said uh the Superior Court
basically said they are allowed to vote
if they're members of that board since
ex-officio members are not singled out
specifically if they are a members of
that board at least in Portsmouth uh
they are allowed to vote Yes
yes go ahead
um so
it would be up to I know that you say
the state the Supreme Court ruled it
would be up to the uh planning board
whether to allow it or not is it
enabling
well I'm not sure exactly I think the
superior Court's decision was to say
that the RSA does not specifically
exclude them so if they're not excluded
from being members and voting
um they are allowed to vote and serve no
matter how they are appointed
thank you any other questions uh
representative Tripp I think you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
uh I believe that uh members of the
board can be either elected or appointed
uh
does that mean that uh ex-official
members
who are well I guess they're they're
appointed like I yeah I've been drawn my
question
uh yeah thank you uh revs and trip I
think you're actually right yeah
okay uh let's uh let's go to uh is it is
okay
Cordell Johnson on the line he's uh he's
neutral on this bill from the nhma
yes good morning Mr chairman and uh
committee members
um and yeah I think I signed up neutral
and I also submitted a letter
explaining uh our concerns
um I think that
I really think the bill is unnecessary
because existing uh already requires
that all local land use board members be
resident of the municipality and in my
letter I cited the specific section with
respect to each land use board
um
I guess I think it's pretty clear that
when the statute refers to land use
board members it includes ex-officio
members
um but if you want to clarify that I I
guess that's not a problem
um
my real concern uh with the with the
bill is that
one of the people who come come within
the definition of a local
board is a building inspector and most
people don't usually think of the
building inspector as a land local land
use board but that is a definition in
the statute I don't think it's anyone's
intent that the building inspector be
required to be a resident of the
municipality uh because that person
usually is an employee
and sometimes works for more than one
municipality so that wouldn't even be
possible
so I have suggested in my letter that if
you are going to pass this bill you at
least make it clear that The Residency
requirement does not apply to
um
to building inspectors
I would also take out the word voting
and just have it apply to all members
and if you want to include
uh specifically include ex-officio
members I would do that
um because my concern about referring to
voting members is then someone is going
to say well I'm an alternate and I don't
usually vote so I don't have to be a
resident
um so I think you want the broadest
possible language in there to make it
clear that all members
are required to be residents of the
municipality I'll stop there and be
happy to answer questions
I I just one other thing I should add
ex-officio members are expected to vote
um
on any matter that comes before the
board
thank you any questions for the nhma
seeing none do we have Mr Brighton on
the line
yes I am here yes please go ahead please
please State your location and your
position on the bill
uh Mark Brighton I live in Portsmouth
and I support house bill 392.
uh
I've seen a lot of changes in Portsmouth
in my 68 years
and as part of those changes in July of
the Portsmouth Housing Authority
the PHA came before our planning board
with a proposal of 64 unit Workforce
housing project at 140 Court Street in
Portsmouth
which is right next door to the feaster
apartments which is for uh to get
elderly and disabled
many concerns were raised by community
members density
changing neighborhood character
the the PHA came looking for various uh
variances and a conditional use permit
a colleague and I went to the meeting we
were only at that point concerned about
uh the way they were using the
definition of Workforce housing
we expressed our opinion and the
planning board gave the PHA what they
wanted in spite of our opinion
day my friend and I were talking and we
realized that the ex-official member of
the Deputy city manager
lived in Kittery
and that just didn't make sense didn't
seem right
and it wasn't until later that we
learned that uh another ex-officio
member the assistant city manager was a
resident of uh stratum
we expressed Our concern to the city
legal department and they replied
when a board member is appointed ex
officio it is not the individual who
serves in that position rather it is the
position that has been appointed to the
planning boy
while people have uh residences
positions do not
we move to take the city to court we
knew that uh it would be prohibitively
expensive to hire an attorney so we
decided to do it pro se
we did find a friend as a sympathetic
lawyer who wrote briefs and uh motions
pro bono
we were joined by 16 residents of the
feast requirements
and uh
I I have to tell you there is nothing
quite like having a superior court judge
pepper you with questions it is kind of
like walking on hot coals please
the Sperry Court found for the city on
all of our issues
now the one relevant to this committee
uh the judge agreed that people have
residences positions to know
Mia Layman the legal reasoning seemed
extraordinary extraordinarily obtuse
uh legislative intent seems pretty darn
clear to me
uh
RSA 672 uh 0.8 States in part to serve
on a planning board a person must be a
resident of the municipality
we filed with the Supreme Court
mainly on the residency issue
I was fully prepared to stand before the
five justices and plead the uh plead the
case
that's how important this is to me
the pandemic ensued
and because of the pandemic
the court uh based its ruling on
just the briefs alone no oral arguments
were heard
they affirmed the Superior Court ruling
stating in part however we conclude that
even if the non-resident members were
ineligible to be ex-officio Boyd members
their votes were harmless in other words
it passed by enough of a majority to
that their votes can matter
in other words the Supreme Court
sidestepped the issue which only now
leads the legislative remedy
that's why I would like to see House
Bill 392 become law
people making decisions affecting the
character of a municipality need to be
residents they need to have skin in the
game
thank you
are there any questions uh
representative Tripp thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my uh uh question
representative Samson
uh
I find your the logic that the judge
used to be quite interesting
people have resonances but positions do
not
well
following that logic
How would
this bill correctly ex-official
problem since it's still a position and
they still
still uh
have a resonance
um
the representative critique effort to
mention his question uh you you raise a
really excellent point and as you could
hear from Mr Brighton
um the just the quartz kind of sidestep
that issue but you know hypothetically
if if a position is an appointment then
somebody living in Florida could serve
on on a planning board in Portsmouth and
be a boating member even though they are
kind of disconnected from their
neighborhood uh and I I agree with uh Mr
cordelli's suggestion that if you do
um consider this this bill uh to be
worthy of passing definitely building
inspectors should be Exempted from this
rule because that that's a different
entity altogether however in order for
us to clarify whether ex-official
members uh are voting members really uh
the only way to do that would be to
specifically say that while they can
serve on these boards and make give
advice to the board uh if they're not
residents of that municipality they
should not be voting because
uh
they might have less less knowledge and
less information than someone who lives
in town so um that is kind of our
feeling about this
thank you any further questions from the
committee any questions from the public
uh representative
manager do you see anyone from the
public I do not see any hands up from
the public I do see one hand up from
representative tree Levin representative
11 please ask me a question thank you Mr
chair uh this is for Mr Brighton
Mr Brighton thank you for coming to us
and testifying today I'm wondering you
mentioned having skin in the game and my
thought is doesn't a person who is an
employee of the municipality city or
town have skin in the game simply by the
fact that they are employed by that city
or town
uh representative 11 I would have to say
no they don't have skin in the game and
I can give you an example
uh if you're from out of town and let's
say that you have to drive in every day
and and parking is an issue and let's
say something comes before the uh
planning board then your view might be
entirely different because you might
need to find parking as an employee
whereas if I'm a resident I might have
an entirely different perspective on it
because you know I can park and probably
walk into town uh or you know in other
words there are instances many instances
in which uh an ex-official non-resident
might not have skin in the game
follow up Mr chair yes please go ahead
thank you Mr Brighton I appreciate your
point of view yet
I would think that someone who is
employed by a municipality
has some understanding of that
municipality its workings and has some
loyalties and concerns
in regards to the municip I'm sorry I
can't talk this morning municipality
itself
over and above their own personal
points of view
one would hope so but we're talking
about human beings and uh it's we have
uh people in town who are
the planning board department head lives
in Newburyport
uh you know her perspective of what is
good for Portsmouth might not line up
with a residence just by virtue of being
human
it can be that simple
uh I thank you for your response
Mr Brighton thank you representative
power thank you Mr chair I'm not sure
who this question should be directed
towards my question is
um does this bill create two types of
ex-officio members that is a non-coding
ex-officio member as well as a voting
ex-officio member based on residency
um
the chairman can I take that question
yeah who is that speaking representative
yeah go right ahead uh thank you
representative power for that question
which is very astute
um
I think it doesn't necessarily do that
because if if in fact you pass this bill
and in the municipality knows that Oni
ex-officio members who live in town can
be voting members they will most likely
appoint people as of ex-officio members
to that board who live in town which
would be a good thing we think
so
um to check my understanding what the
bill has written will do
is that it will specify that
ex official members
shall be presidents
of the municipality and therefore they
will be eligible to vote on
uh represent power I would I would add
to that
um that the it does not preclude a
municipality from appointing someone as
an effects of physio member who has a
lot of experience and background in
these issues who may be live in a
different town however they can give the
advice to the members of the board they
just don't have voting rights at that
point
issue
are there any other further questions
on uh on this bill
before we close to here
seeing none I'm gonna close the hearing
on House Bill 392.
next bill we're going to take up in our
hearing process well let me ask this
does anybody need a bio break or would
you like a recess for five minutes or do
you want to keep moving forward
okay so you know uh
no looks of distress in anybody's face
I'm going to move forward on House Bill
374 and I'm going to ask representative
power to introduce
the bill
this is a bill that uh
the bill that is relative to the
official ballot referendum form of town
meetings which is more commonly known as
this one too
go ahead representative power
thank you Mr chairman and thank you to
my fellow committee members I appreciate
the opportunity to introduce to you
house bill 374 relative to the adoption
of sb2
for the record I am representative Diane
power I represent the towns of Brookline
and Mason in Hillsborough County
District 26. first I would like to
provide some background
again this bill comes from a a request
by a number of constituents
in 2019 the method to adopt sb2 was
changed by removing the question from
the official ballot and instead placing
the question on the warrant to be voted
upon at the annual meeting
sponsors of the previous House Bill
asserted that voters should not be
allowed to vote on sb2 at the Town polls
because they might be uninformed voters
with that allow me to introduce the bill
this bill restores the original method
of adopting sb2 by placing the question
on the official ballots and it allows
all-day voting at Town polls on Town
election day
or by absentee ballot this bill before
you is needed to address a number of
issues resulting from the recent
statutory changes first
the traditional meeting is not the only
time and place to hear about SP2
this bill recognizes the ample
opportunities for one to be informed on
sb2
which are already prescribed by law
initially when the question to adopt sb2
was brought forward the governing body
discusses it at a regular meeting at
which public input is included once on
the warrants there is a hearing on the
sb2 question as required by law moreover
in multi-town districts a hearing must
be held in each town on separate days
so the system already has
two opportunities to become informed on
and debate sb2
furthermore by putting the question to
adopt sb2 on the official ballot voters
have more time to consider the pros and
cons of SP2 than they would otherwise
have at the traditional town meeting
second and most importantly
this bill eliminates the control of a
minority present at an annual meeting to
decide whether or not to adopt the sv2
system
by placing the question to adopt sv2
back onto the official ballot and
allowing for an all-day vote voter
participation is increased this also
protects against disenfranchising voters
like the elderly disabled deployed
military business Travelers shift
workers and families with child care
needs who cannot attend the traditional
meeting to vote on sb2
also the complexities of covid-19 moving
forward only adds to the participation
challenge
undoubtedly when more people are able to
vote on the question to adopt sb2 the
vote better represents the will of the
people and third this bill undoes the
inequitable standards to adopt and to
rescind sb2
by placing the question to adopt back
onto the official ballot the method to
adopt sb2 is the same as the method to
resent
in conclusion
this bill
reverses the recent changes made to
adopt sb2 reverting back to the original
language
it acknowledges the many opportunities
already available for voters to become
informed on SP2 and it enables greater
voter participation on the question to
adopt sb2 thus better representing the
will of the people
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
committee members for your time and
attention Mr chairman I am happy to
answer any questions at this time if you
allow uh thank you representative
representative Porter you had a question
oh yes thank you Mr chair I rep think
and thank you representative Powell for
taking my question on this
um you had a list of
um people who were unable to attend Town
meetings
um quite a lengthy list and I agree with
you
um but when if sb2 is adopted by a
community won't those same people be
hindered from getting to the business uh
portion of the sb2 and therefore not be
able to make their
which is known to the community prior to
the vote
thank you for your question
representative Porter the focus of this
bill is not
um with regard to the merits
of the sb2 system it simply focuses on
the method to
um adopt SP2 whether that take place on
the official ballot
to be voted upon at the Town polls which
um in order to participate in that way
that takes obviously less time than it
would for someone to
need to attend a traditional meeting in
order to
vote on that question
can I have a follow-up Mr chair yes
please go ahead thank you representative
um in the traditional town meeting form
of government all decisions are made at
the town meeting the only thing that's
on the ballot are offices and occasional
zoning ordinances
but all the rest of the decisions made
at the meeting
all the rest of the decisions are made
at the meeting by
making it possible to decide on this
very important issue
not at the meeting if someone's already
in a town meeting mode of government
you're giving them you're changing how
they make their decisions by putting
this decision on an official ballot
does that inconsistency ring true to you
thank you for the follow-up
representative Porter um I'm not sure
that I understand the question but I
will point out that this bill simply
reverts
um the method to adopt back to the
original language that was in the
statute when this bill was originally
passed
um to implement and outline the sb2
system
representative majority
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um putting this on the ballot and the
way to do that certainly does take uh
some understanding I'm curious if you
know are there communities that have
expressed a a dire problem the way the
law exists now or I mean have expressed
a an extreme uh uh well I'll go back to
the word an extreme problem with the way
the law exists
yes thank you representative Maggiore
that's a that's a very good question so
as I had stated
um my background this bill comes from a
request by a number of constituents so
yes to your point there there has been a
repeat and experience problem with
regard to the question to adopt sb2
being on the warrant to be acted upon at
the town meeting and that issue is that
this question
never even gets to be debated because
what is happening in in my constituents
experience is that the question to adopt
is being tabled by people
um who are choosing to table it
um and this has happened in the middle
of a a an individual presenting
the question to adopt right in the
middle of his presentation somebody will
jump up and make a motion
um to table it a vote is taken and there
isn't even a discussion so that would be
an issue
so by reverting
to the original language
um that would be a solution to that um
to that problem
thank you
okay uh next we have uh
a some testimony from her yes
from a former member of the committee I
was kind of a
celebrity of sorts in the House of
Representatives uh former representative
Blanchard
welcome back
thank you sir
I assume you can hear me yes you sound
fine right ahead
uh Good Day committee members my name is
Jim Belanger of Hollis New Hampshire and
I'm representing myself
I'm a former New Hampshire State Rep
serving on the municipal and County
government committee for nine years
it's been a while since I sat with some
of you on this committee
I must bring to your attention that this
committee has dealt with this very issue
as late as the year 2019 in House Bill
at that time we recognized that voting
to adopt sb2 in a regular deliberative
town meeting should be done according to
the town meeting process as required of
all other warrant articles that is to be
deliberated and voted on by the same
voters who deliberated it
the method that was currently in the
rsas was flawed in that it departed from
the traditional town meeting format and
used a format that is in place after the
sb2 process is adopted
since that has not yet been adopted
why were the voters mandated to vote on
a process which is only in place after
sb2 format is in place and the article
gets a deliberative session followed by
a second session where ballot voting
takes place on the article by voters
that were not at the deliberative
session to hear the arguments
this bill House Bill 374 reverses the
effect of House Bill 415 of 2019
sponsored by members of this very
committee
former chair Carson former chair
Belanger former clerk Porter
representative Maggiore it is my opinion
my personal opinion that promote
proponents of sb2 are attempting to
introduce SP2 procedures and processes
into a non-sb2 town meeting
let's adopt the sb2 form of governance
before forcing its processes on the
community that has not chosen to use
that format
do we mandate sb2 communities to vote on
articles especially to withdraw from sb2
using the traditional town meeting
format and voting on it at the sb2
delivery session of course not
in closing I would remind the committee
that in 2019 House Bill 415 passed this
committee on a vote of 18 to 1. pass the
house even after being withdrawn from
the consent calendar
passed the Senate on a Voice vote and
was signed by the governor in August
2019.
thank you are there any questions for
former representative Belanger
seeing none thank you for your testimony
uh the next uh
testimony will come from
uh Miss Laura Bueno
have a good summer everybody
[Music]
thanks Jim
is Ms Bueno with us
maybe am I saying her name thank you
can you hear me yes you sound fine
please state where you're from and uh
what your feelings are about the bill
okay my name is Laura Bono I'm the Town
Administrator for the town of Hillsboro
and I am opposed to this bill
much as represent past representative
Belanger stated I testified a couple
years ago on House Bill 415 and at that
time the legislature understood the area
within the RSA which required adopting
the official ballot referendum form of
meeting to be placed on the official
ballot versus at town meeting
um when a community is asked to vote on
changing their legislative process from
town meeting to Senate bill to it's a
significant change which warrants this
to discussion
um unfortunately the
public hearings that representative
power mentioned are not well attended
similar to The deliberative Sessions in
Senate Bill 2 communities are not well
attended so the information is not
getting out
whether the request is being brought
forward by a petitioner which has been
my experience in my career or by the
board of Selectmen the voters should
hear the reasoning as to the request as
well as have the ability to ask
questions and seek further information
this shouldn't be treated any
differently than any other major changes
such as imposing a tax cap or even the
establishment of a budget committee for
example both of which are done as a
warrant article a town meeting
I'm going to repeat a little bit of what
representative Belanger stated because
at the time the Warren article is
presented you are a town meeting form of
government so that is where it should be
voted on and discussed
I'm not sure
you know it's only been that change has
only been in place since 2019 so I don't
know where the established history of it
not working comes from it didn't seem to
work prior to changing it or correcting
it to how it should be
um but leaving it as is and requiring it
to be brought to town meeting
will enable the people who vote on it to
have the questions answered have a good
understanding and cast their
confidential though because it's
required to have a paper ballot and
they'll be doing that in confidence if
they don't understand the question on
the ballot they're going to either vote
no or not vote at all so that doesn't
accomplish anything
more than
showing that people are not going to
vote on something if they don't
understand it
so I thank you for allowing me to
testify and
um for your time and consideration thank
you for your testimony other questions
seeing that I'm going to move on to nhma
Cordell Johnson
thank you Mr chairman uh again Cordell
Johnston representing the New Hampshire
Municipal Association and we are opposed
to this bill
um as as former representative former
chairman Belanger said
um the Old Law that was 19 the Old Law
never really made sense uh because it
had the legislative body making a
decision in a manner that that it
doesn't do
um the understand the town meeting is a
legislative body as the New Hampshire
legislature the House of Representatives
as a representative is a legislative
body uh as such they assemble the debate
and discuss matters and then they vote
on them they don't just come into the
local news and vote on them by
um uh by uh secret ballot
and in order to make an informed
decision they need to have that
discussion and understand what they're
what they're voting on
as I think it was Laura Bono said uh yes
there is a hearing uh under the Old Law
yes there was a hearing before the
matter went to the official ballot but
almost nobody goes to that hearing in my
town we've considered
um adopting sb2 six or seven times
um I've gone to most of those hearings
and uh there have never been more than
10 people at the hearings so people
don't don't learn about it they don't
understand it and I can say the first
time that the issue was on the ballot uh
in my town and this was before I changed
careers and became a municipal lawyer
and so I didn't I I didn't have any idea
what this was about I went into the
voting booth I consider myself a pretty
well-informed voter but there was that
question and I thought I have no idea
what this means so I voted no
um and uh as Laura Bono said that's what
people are going to do they're they're
not a vote base based just sort of on a
guess
if you're talking about changing the
form of your town meeting you should not
be doing that yet based on a guess about
what it means you could have a serious
discussion and debate
and uh and vote based on uh based on
that discussion and debate just as the
House of Representatives does
um I'll end there and if anyone has any
questions I would be very happy to try
to answer them thank you
are there any questions for the ahma
seeing that night I do have one question
Mr chair we'll be right ahead thank you
I appreciate that and thank you Cordell
for taking my question
um HB 415 I don't expect you to remember
it by number but it's the bill we're
discussing from 2019 which was the last
change to this which I think cleared it
up
um
did the sponsors work with nhma to to
craft that language that was ultimately
signed into law
I remember yes they did I'm a little
insulted that you thought I wouldn't
remember the phone number
all right I'll take my lumps on that one
but yes we did we did work with uh the
uh sponsors from both parties just to be
clear uh on that legislation
thank you
any other questions for representative
from uh Attorney Johnson
being done uh I believe we have a member
of the public that would like to speak
in our position Bill Gail Cromwell
is she on the line
yes I am here can you hear me yes it
sounds
uh yes
um my name is Gail Cromwell
my town of Temple has had 15 years worth
of experience with sb2 on the official
ballot it has rarely come close to
actually being adopted but the sponsor
does not accept failure he keeps going
year after year
however what I would like to say is
probably more important which is that
sb2 is one of the most important
decisions that a town can make and I
would have to tell you that 162 towns
still have traditional town meeting only
70 towns have adopted sb2 and they tend
to be the larger towns
in a the question I think that is really
important is what is the best place to
actually discuss whether a town is going
to adopt sb2 or not I was a selectman
for six years I ran a number of those
hearings that were required I will tell
you no one goes to those hearings
the most common place where sb2 is
debated and discussed is on Facebook now
I don't know how experienced you all are
with Facebook
but it is not a source for accurate
information
in our case it became very abusive to
people
three points it became downright ugly
there was no way for anyone to make a
statement that we should not or should
adopt sv2 in any rational way
so the conclusion that I have been very
glad to be happy with was the adoption
in 2019 of the present situation
we're still required to have a hearing
one of the early proponents of this
legislation said that you would only go
to town meeting that's not true the
current legislation says you still have
to have a hearing and we have scheduled
a hearing for this year before town
meeting then at town meeting we hope
that we can actually discuss the merits
of sb2 or the demerits of it in a
rational way I think that is what we all
hope for is to be able to have some sort
of rational discussion so that people
actually understand what they are doing
because when in the previous situation
people did not know what they were doing
so I appreciate your time in taking up
this and I do hope that you will vote
against this Bill thank you very much
I'd be glad to answer any questions
thank you Ms Cromwell are there any
questions from Ms Cromwell
seeing that other uh
representative man jewelry or could you
tell from your screen if there are other
members of the public that wish to
testify
I do see Mr chair yes I do see one hand
up from Eric power
Mr power uh please uh go ahead and offer
you a testimony
well Mr chairman this is uh Eric power
resident of Brookline and I'm speaking
in support of house bill 374.
uh as a little bit of background uh
Brookline adopted the SP2 system in 2016
for our school district
and we're a town of 5300 and we've been
very happy with it
um so
that's the reason I'm speaking in favor
of this here one reason
um until the 2019 change the question of
adopting SP sb2 ballot was placed on the
official ballot to be voted on during
town and school election day with the
change the adoption question now is
placed on the town or School District
warrant for Action during the
traditional meeting
this change makes it virtually
impossible for a town or School District
to adopt sb2 and let me explain why to
illustrate this point I will use the
example of our Hollis Brooklyn
Cooperative School District which
includes the towns of Hollis and
Brookline
when the sb2 question is proposed as it
is this year again there are many
mandatory hearings that must be
conducted in fact RSA 4014 requires two
sb2 adoption hearings to be widely
announced with a hearing in each town
and on different days
in addition the school board deliberates
and takes a position on sb2 adoption at
the required budget hearing
in addition all these meetings are live
streamed and recorded and the minutes
are available too I'll give you the
experience from this year when we went
to zoom we had over 100 people attending
both nights of the hearing that involved
discussions on sb2 so I would say that's
not a small number
so there there are a lot many
opportunities for students to get
informed and debate sb2
with the 2019 change the sb2 adoption
question is supposed to be deliberated
yet again at the Traditional School
District meeting
or town meeting before before a
potential vote I use the word supposed
to and potential because voters cannot
be certain that the sb2 adoption
question will even be debated upon or
voted upon
in the past as a petitioner I have
coordinated Advance with the school
district moderator to present
information on citizen petition worn
articles including such topics as tax
cap or requiring tax impact notation on
Warren articles at the meeting after the
warrant was properly moved and seconded
I have begun my presentation to the
meeting only to be interrupted by an
aggressive voter with a point of order
with a motion to table the article the
moderator then calls a card vote to
table by simple majority vote and the
article is table with no further
discussion debate and no vote
unfortunately this pattern has happened
many times over the years
the Hollis Brookline Cooperative school
district meetings have always been long
and sometimes have had multiple sessions
over the dates over many dates and I
have I sent you a written testimony but
we've had sessions that have been one
two three and even five sessions long we
had a session in 2018 that lasted 14
hours of meetings
so you can see it's not a short meeting
generally
practically speaking only a small number
of citizens are willing and able to
endure these long multi-night meetings
and these voters are overwhelmingly
against adopting sb2 because they prefer
to maintain the control of the
traditional meeting
it's not reasonable to expect many
voters in favor of sb2 to attend the
traditional meeting in hopes of
potentially discussing and getting an
opportunity to vote on sb2
the sponsor of the 2019 changed said
that the question of adopting SP2 is so
important that it needs to require
voters to be educated again at the
traditional meeting debated and then
voted upon then and there
this is Fault this is a faulty argument
for several reasons there are already
multiple occasions and opportunities to
learn and debate the pros and cons of
SP2 with long and often multi-night
meetings voters have no idea when the
SP2 question will potentially be brought
to the floor
lastly there is certainly no guarantee
that a debate or even a vote on adopting
sb2 will occur at a traditional meeting
in fact the situation recently happened
last year Hollow citizens placed the sb2
adoption question on their 2020 Town
warrant via petition
during their traditional town meeting
the sb2 adoption question was tabled it
was tabled without a vote or even a
debate
did this 2019 change improve the process
clearly no debate and no vote on sb2
adoption is not an improvement
ironically Hollis is the hometown of the
primary sponsor of the 2019 change which
moved the adoption question to the often
official ballot
thus the effect of the current law is to
prevent the adoption of sb2 returning
the sb2 adoption question to the
official ballot is reasonable and
logical it guarantees that the question
will get a vote there are ample
opportunities to learn about SP2 and get
informed
more importantly HP 374 enables all
voters to weigh on in this weigh in on
this important question at The Ballot
Box on Town election day or by absentee
ballot when more voters participate the
outcome better reflects the will of the
community I urge committee members to
vote Auto pass on House Bill 374. thank
you very much
thank you heather questions uh yes uh
representative lasalles
yes I think there's there's one thing we
can all agree on we have experience with
sb2
uh that the participation of the
community in the deliberative session is
generally very light
and
it's been my experience that it's very
easy for a a group of people who have a
particular interest in one of the
questions that's going to come up to
pack the meeting and then cause the
outcome of the beating to be what their
particular feeling is and there are
there is a lot of people who are opposed
to the whole idea of sb2
by allowing
the people as a whole to vote
on the official ballot of sb2 seems like
a very uh much more democratic way of
solving that SP2 question and in fact to
me it's the whole purpose of that it was
brought up earlier about access to the
official ballot and being able to
participate by people who are
handicapped and uh
uh and it's been my experience and I
guess I'm I'm uh directing this at
representative power
isn't it your experience that that
handicapped people are more
able to participate in an sb2 question
on the official ballot then going to a
deliberative session
thank you for the question
representative lasalles
um yes it is my opinion that
um
people who
um have difficulty getting to a
traditional meeting and
tending very long traditional meetings
um it is much more accessible for them
to participate in the the the town
um as a member of the legislative body
um to be able to uh
cast their votes on the official ballot
on Town election day
okay any other questions from the
committee
and uh there are three Mr chair from
representative Porter myself and
representative Gilman I'm not sure who
was first but let's start with uh
representative
well thank you Mr chair
question is for Mr powler
um
you spoke about this the uh in a
deliberative session or a traditional
town meeting that somebody with an
article can pack the meeting with the
people that support whatever they're
doing
uh that's a campaign
um
Administration kind of thing so what
makes that different from having a town
having an sb2 town I mean
can't somebody pack uh the voting booths
just the same as packing a town meeting
the question yes I think the the uh what
happens at a sb2 deliberative session
what's happening at attritional
traditional town meeting
um who goes to the meeting and who
participates is vitally important the
deliberative session is deciding the
form and what's on the warrant in the
traditional meeting is debating both the
warrant and taking action
so I think it's important who goes so
people that think that the liberative
session isn't important I think uh don't
understand it completely
but the the the point is is that through
deliberative sessions generally are
conducted in a few hours
not multiple days multiple nights
and it's much easier to participate
in that way
also the sb2 question
is trying to enfranchise many voters who
cannot make these meetings
and they cannot go to the meeting to say
they don't want to go to the meeting
that's the problem here so you
enfranchise the the voters to be able to
adopt sb2 many of which who can never
make a traditional meeting
so I think by enfranchising everybody to
decide in providing all the app
opportunities that are out there to
learn about sb2 it's uh I think that it
is a fair system to be able to put it on
the official ballot and by the way the
official ballots also used for zoning
questions and we don't require people to
go to zoning board meetings to vote on
that as well people vote on it based on
how they educate themselves just like
they would on sb2 thank you
representative Porter
thank you Mr chair and this question is
for Mr power I'm so in my town we have
traditional town meeting in my school
district is sb2 so I have experience
with both deliberative sessions and town
meetings
my experience has been that people
attend town meeting at a higher number
and participate more than they do at
deliberative sessions
just like with you and with us as
Representatives it's our responsibility
before we vote on a bill to listen to
testimony
ask questions and Ponder and make what
we consider the best decision for the
State of New Hampshire in a similar way
people need to do that
for their towns
getting people to the meetings is an
issue in both
systems as you have explained it's it's
so my question is isn't it the
responsibility of the people in the
community to attend
town meeting if this is going to be on
the ballot or deliberative sessions
prior to putting the questions on the
ballot is not is that responsibility on
the people to do that
or is it up to us to find a way that
they can avoid doing it and still have
their vote
well I uh thank you for the question so
there's the the question of adopting sb2
is a challenging one because
you know there's many people that can
simply not make a traditional meeting
and I and you've heard some of the
people that cannot do that
um but they would very much want to
participate in this in the uh in the
Democracy we have the sb2 system
provides that so I don't want to get too
much into the details of the pros and
cons of sb2 but you know you have SP2
you have two opportunities to
participate the deliberative session in
the balloting session and undoubtedly
the balloting session always has the
largest number of participants because
people are voting on Election Day or by
absentee ballot and that's been our
experience
like uh Hillsborough and Brookline we do
have the SP2 system for our school and
we have the traditional town meeting for
our town
and so we have that we have that
experience and I'd say if you look at
our numbers and I've looked to talk to
our town clerk our deliberative sessions
that we've had for our school have had
the same or even a little higher than
our traditional meetings for our school
so we have not seen that uh drop off
we've had very much the same amount of
interest in our school district
deliberative sessions as we did in our
traditional
uh meetings but I think it getting back
to your question the
um it is the responsibility of of
everyone to to participate but like I
say people cannot always go to the town
meeting
whether or School District meeting to
vote to adopt sb2 and unfortunately
there's no guarantee you even have a
vote or when the vote occurs and that
that has already happened in Hollis in
our neighboring town of talking to my
friends in Hollis they have told me that
they were very frustrated by the they
waited at the meeting to vote and then
they didn't even get to vote on it
because it was tabled it wasn't even
debated so that doesn't that doesn't
seem to be an improvement and I and I
think that that's probably where we're
heading this year for our Co-op meeting
where we're we've debated sb2
four times already this year and now
we're going to debate it again at the
meeting so I think it makes a lot of
sense to put it on the official ballot
so that you do get you have the debate
but you also have a vote and I think
that that's important that people that
you just like in the House of
Representatives everything gets a vote
thank you
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
power for taking my question which you
um I think you answered a little bit
with your last statement but since this
bill since 415 went into effect there's
been one local Town election I believe
which was in 2020.
um not I'm not discounting any any
issues that may be happening in Hollis
or Brookline do you have any evidence
though of other communities where during
the time where 415 has been an effect
that there have been any issues or any
standing complaints
the um the the 2020 meeting for the
co-op did get a vote on sb2 and that's
the only reason it happened for sure was
because we did we have a traditional
meeting but we had the drive-through
voting
there but it was it would be likely not
voted upon in my opinion we'll see what
happens this year
um I do have uh one one person I spoke
to that's in Bow that they wish that
they would have they're trying their
have SP2 on the ballot this year and
they want to uh they wished it was on
the uh official ballot it's on their
their warrant this year
um but there's like I said it's only
been in effect for this is the second
year of it and last year was a little
interesting in terms of all the town
meetings so it was kind of hard to judge
but
um I think right now you're never going
to see another town adopt sb2 until it
gets be gets put back on the official
ballot for all the reasons I stated in
terms of the town meeting attendance
thank you
thank you uh I don't see any additional
questions uh do we have
any additional comments or testimony
from the public
it's like we do not I do not see any Mr
chair all right I'm going to close the
here uh before I close the hearing I
just want to report on the sign-in sheet
we had 24 people sign in one in support
23 to pose and zero neutral
and uh so with that I'm going to close
the hearing on House Bill 374.
uh as a point of uh Administration as
you look at the clock right now it's a
little past 11 30. we're going to take a
break for a half hour at 12 30 for lunch
I anticipate that we'll probably still
be in the hearing mode at that point so
we'll recess whatever hearing we're in
and then go to lunch at that point
the next bill before us it's House Bill
and this is relative to permissible
residential units in a residential Zone
on the sign-in sheet we had 66 in
support 11 opposed and one neutral
and uh representative van as a as a a
sponsor would you like to introduce the
bill
yes Mr chairman I would like to
introduce the bill
ready to go
okay uh House Bill 341 is a bill that
seeks to address a problem that we are
seeing all across the state of New
Hampshire uh we are in a housing crisis
I don't think anyone denies that
according to the latest numbers from the
New Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
we're about 20 000 housing units short
um and the problem is that
one of the problems that we're facing is
that our existing housing stock doesn't
match very well with who needs to live
in it right now about 75 of all
households are either single people
couples or two unrelated people living
together right now in New Hampshire a
lot of our housing stock is big houses
that do not work very well for the
people who would like to live in New
Hampshire and quite frankly often don't
work very well for the people who own
them
so what I've tried to do with this bill
is enable the construction or
Rehabilitation of
um
housing for more units
so why am I doing this right now 78 of
Manchester is zoned single family
residential 75 78 of its residential
area is Zone single family those
neighborhoods are not all single family
they contain
pre-existing small multi-family units
this bill would allow us to do that
everywhere
and you know one of the questions of
course is why do we need to do this at
the state level
um preemptive zoning is uh
not always a good idea often it's not a
good idea at all but in this case I
think that making a Statewide decision
is really important there's no incentive
for any individual jurisdiction to vote
for more density even tiny historically
appropriate density of four units we
need to do this as a state because
otherwise it's not going to happen we
have seen that
one of the questions that
um people ask is well why for the reason
that we recommend that I recommend for
is because
four units can be financed very simply
with a simple homeowner loan by the the
VA the FHA Freddie Mac and Fannie Mae
will all write a simple homeowner's role
for up to four units so four units is
house-sized it's easy to finance it can
be built by two women in a van or three
guys in a pickup truck it's not a big
developer project it keeps money in town
by allowing us to repurpose buildings we
already have and repurpose and continue
to use the infrastructure that we've
already built the water the sewer the
existing roads you've heard me testify
on other bills that it costs about
404.65 a foot
to maintain a road in New Hampshire salt
sand plow ditching mode that's not
Paving we need to use the roads we
already have instead of taking on from
developers New Roads
um so what does this bill actually do
this bill legalizes missing middle
housing by and missing middle is housing
that's bigger than a single family
smaller than a big apartment building
all of those things in between up to
four units
making up to four units permissible by
right on any residentially zoned lot
with Municipal Water and Sewer most of
our favorite neighborhoods look like
this already we need to be able to
create more of them instead of of
preventing their creation
this bill helps people who are looking
for housing it helps people who are
living in big houses that they'd like to
convert into a multi-family it helps
municipalities because it allows us to
use our infrastructure efficiently and
it helps small Builders locally with
projects that they can do themselves
this bill does not change any of the
rules established by any jurisdiction
about lot coverage parking requirements
necessity to conform to the
international building code I understand
that the Fire Marshals were concerned
that we were saying that a single that a
fourplex is the same as a single family
house no we're not this is a land use
code it doesn't have anything to do with
the international building code you
still have to conform to all the rules
involved in the IBC including for us
four units inside of a single building
that building has to be sprinkled
uh this bill doesn't change lot coverage
doesn't change front setbacks doesn't
change anything it just says you can put
up to four units in here if you can make
all of those things work
um
the it's not the end of single family
housing you can still build a single
family house in any of these
neighborhoods same as you can now
um the economic impact is amazing
because this is a way of adding almost
invisible density historically
appropriate density to our existing
neighborhoods and that's where people
want to live we haven't built any more
of the neighborhoods that people really
want I mean people talk all the time
about oh my God Portsmouth is so
expensive Portsmouth is expensive
because it's very hard to build anything
there and speaking of Portsmouth in
particular and this is true for most
places in New Hampshire
um I have a good friend who lives on
Richard Street in Portsmouth and he did
his master's work in landscape
architecture by looking at the his own
neighborhood about a four block area and
he discovered more than a hundred places
where another unit could be added
invisibly
if you could have more units on a single
lot so it's a really crucial bill for us
for so many reasons IT addresses the
mismatch between our housing stock and
where and who wants to live here IT
addresses the issues of Municipal
expenditures IT addresses the issues of
having enough housing for the business
people who want to live here
so that's the story on 341 I'm happy to
take questions
thank you representative van for your
testimony and just to acknowledge that
we're somewhat behind in our
our hearing process and we have at least
people who wish to testify on this
particular bill so I'm going to ask
those that are queued up to testify to
try to hold your comments to
approximately two minutes so that we can
we can move through and hear everybody's
point of view and also those on the
committee to be brief and succinct in
the types of questions you're asking so
next I have a question from
representative Gallagher
all right so you said
um
you said that this bill won't end
single-family housing
um
as someone who thinks that single family
single-family zoning should actually be
ended what would you say to someone who
thinks that this bill doesn't go far
enough
single family but you can still build a
single family house in any of these
neighborhoods
it's just not the only thing you can
build
okay thank you
and representative Andrew booty is next
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative van for taking my
question I I'm thinking about the
concept of Aging in place so if I have a
single family home and my kids have left
I want an age in place wouldn't this
help with keeping staying in the same
Community but building that Community
around me that
would help Aging in place and keep the
vibrancy
yes absolutely because it allows you to
make your house smaller and at the same
time provide housing for someone else
okay uh next we have representative
treeleven
thank you Mr chair and thanks
representative van for taking my
question here in the city of Dover we
have what my friend lovingly calls the
old house neighborhood and a lot of
those buildings in the 80s were changed
into Condominiums they were huge
mansions and they were sliced up to four
Condominiums and then another one in the
carriage house but in your research for
this bill or anything else have you
noticed that that's not happening these
days or because it's difficult to get a
condominium to be in place
uh it's not actually the condominium
issue the issue is that lots of
neighborhoods are uh zoned so that it's
only single family so you could have
single family and you might be able to
have an accessory dwelling unit but you
can't have any more than that for
example in my town uh there are two
Primary Residential zones there's the
general residence Zone which allows
multi-family anything over two and
there's the family District which only
allows one or two I happen to live in
the general residence District so I was
actually able to convert my house if I
had lived in the family District same
house just down the street a little bit
I wouldn't have been able to
may I have a follow-up Mr chair yes
please go ahead
I asked about Condominiums specifically
is oftentimes people get into that
situation and the condominium laws in
the state of New Hampshire
predicate you know how they put that
condominium in place and you pay a
monthly fee for maintenance and
insurance and all of that yet I'm
thinking farther along if there are
there I know there are more buildings
that if one person owned that building
and made it into a four unit
they could have following on
representative mangaputis they could
have income from that building and
absolutely get themselves started along
that pathway of Financial and also help
someone else because they they would
have tenants versus owners and we know
that our rental market is just horrid
right
um
for an organization called the
incremental development Alliance and one
of the things that we urge people to do
is to buy a multi-family as a way of
reinvesting in their neighborhood
creating Financial wealth for themselves
and providing housing so yes that is an
important part of this thank you
representative representative Gilman
next
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um in your uh presentation you discuss
uh the historical aspect of growth in a
town have you found it uh I think this
is more question for the general public
to hear your answer
have you found that most towns begin uh
centered around whatever their main
uh industry is and then they as they I
don't know grew more wealthy they bought
more land and then grew outside of the
city center or town center and now what
you're asking this bill is let's fill in
those empty spots to make it dense again
that's right a lot that's a really great
question because in fact a lot of
jurisdictions nationally and in New
Hampshire are less dense now than they
were a hundred years ago because of the
loss of buildings or because we didn't
fill in in the way that we had
historically so yes that's exactly what
this is it says let's use what we've
already got and fill it in and in a
historically appropriate way because
these are not big buildings these are
house-sized buildings
thank you
and next we have uh representative
sorry forgot to unmute thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative van
for taking my question can you say
something about about what you think the
uh impact of this bill should it pass
might have on uh older kind of
downtrodden downtown areas uh that that
are in fact
um
searching for the right term
these are the places that that attract
over development in in a kind of
unhealthy way would this bill
um free free up those areas in a way to
provide more such multi-family housing
in other areas as well kind of even out
the the supply and demand yes I think
that's exactly what it does it allows
right now we have neighborhoods that are
frozen
um and what this bill does is unfreeze
those neighborhoods and say there's no
reason why this neighborhood
uh has to stay exactly the same as it is
because historically that's not how we
build towns we build towns by having a
Crossroads and we put some buildings
there and then we put some more
buildings there and then we make a few
bigger buildings and then we kind of
oonch out the growth pattern that we've
followed for the last 75 years driven
largely by federal housing policy and
also Federal Transportation policy has
been very very different from the way we
historically grew towns this bill is an
effort to return us to a more organic
way of growing our towns
thank you
thanks we have representative Matt Fiore
I wave off Mr chair thank you okay
thanks and next we have representative
Tripp
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Finn for taking my
question
um
the uh there's a section in the bill
that I don't quite understand it says
the lot and yard standards setbacks
parking requirements are not coverage
Shelby nor more restricted than those
required for a single family dwelling
that is a oh sorry
go ahead is that your question
well that that's an error it should say
shall not be more restrictive than for a
single family house I thought that had
gotten corrected I apologize we'll have
to correct that
um the point of that is that the lot in
yard standards lot coverage parking
requirements all of that
does not go away if you want to put more
than one unit there but it also is not
more restrictive than it would be for
more than one unit I hope that helps
so so the uh
so the amount of non-permeal non-fermi
of uh surface uh stays the same
yes so if for example if in your single
family Zone it says there's a 40 lot
coverage maximum it would remain a 40
lock coverage maximum if you put four
units there
I I still I have a follow-up yes another
follow-up hi uh on line six of the uh
the bill it says uh well actually five
and six
uh
the residential zoning District served
by water or sewer or which candy net
connected to water or sewer all right
tire
does that mean that uh if
that the uh
the the multiple uh dwelling flask can
still be uh well and septic
no
it's connected to municipal
water and septic
the reason that language is in there let
me explain why it's there sometimes when
a town expands Water and Sewer they
Skips a lot because for whatever reason
the person who lived there declined to
be involved if that lot were to be
redeveloped for more than one single
family house it would have to be
connected to town Water and Sewer it
can't remain on septic and well
but I don't believe that's what it says
it says or can be connected it doesn't
say shall be connected it says it must
be or can be connected if you think that
we need an amendment we can certainly
look into that but that's the purpose of
this is that you can't do it unless you
are connected to town Water and Sewer so
if that's unclear I'm happy to offer an
amendment when we get to that point I
will make a note
thank you
thank you representative air you have a
question
yes thank you for taking my question Mr
chairman uh what I'm concerned about is
again we're sticking our fingers into
the zoning board
uh number two I know what you're trying
to do and I think it's a good idea but
when these when these one family
neighborhoods are designed
you want to put four units on a lot and
hook up the town water and sewer and
that's great as long as it was a four
bedroom house there
because that's how they calculate the
size of those pipes that are running in
the road to handle that water and sewer
so you might run into a problem
where a whole neighborhood wants to
change to four units
they're going to have to dig up the
street replace water and sewer
which would be a big cost
right and that would be up to up to town
to
do now if a developer wants to build a
development and hook it up to town Water
and Sewer the developer has to go to the
town and make sure that there's capacity
and can be denied if there is not
capacity and that would be true for this
as well it doesn't change that okay
thank you for your question
waving off again
no I I no I'll ask it I keep putting my
hand on it up uh up and down thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
van for taking my question by any means
with reference to uh being hooked up to
water or sewer can you help me with that
and and the reason I ask that question
is Northampton may be very unique in
this that we have an incorporated
Village
um set by Statute a hundred years ago
more than that which has sewer running
through it but the town cannot the town
isn't hooked up to it it's only used for
facilities at the beach I've had people
in that Community say what does by any
means mean with regard to sewer so maybe
it's not maybe it's not relative to us
or maybe we're just so unique but but I
had to ask the question okay so I would
answer that if people can't attach to
that then they can't do this so if your
system is set up only for the beach then
it's only for the beach and the town
would have to make a different decision
um to allow this to happen in your town
thank you
the next uh could we bring up
uh Mr Parisi uh from the New Hampshire
State Fire Marshal's Office who'd like
to speak in opposition to the bill
can Mr chair and I've asked him to
unmute and there he is he should be good
to go
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
to the committee for allowing my
testimony I have submitted a written
document for testimony and I I won't
read the whole thing uh I appreciate uh
representative van uh stating that this
does not have anything to do with
building or fire codes and that a
building that was converted a
single-family dwelling that was
converted into more than uh you know two
dwelling units uh would still have to
um comply with the the Fire and Building
Code I just have some concern that it
may not be interpreted that way and if
there was a way to add a line or an
amendment to this bill that would make
that clear we would certainly have no
issue with the bill whatsoever we want
to do what we can to help
um with the housing shortage in the in
the state so thank you for allowing
testimony be happy to answer any
questions any questions from Mr Parisi
seeing none next
I'd like to invite
Miss Christy West a member of the public
speaking support of the bill
foreign
there now can I can you hear me yes you
sound fine we're right ahead hi good so
I am I live in Mount Vernon I have a
cape a tiny Cape that was built in 1785.
I am renovating it completely I'm I am
your demographic exactly what
representative van said I am 68 years
old I will need some rental income to
and supplement my Social Security even
though I plan on working until I'm 80.
um but I am con I am renovating my house
right now so the whole first floor is
handicap accessible and then there's a
small uh uh two bedroom one bath with a
kitchenette upstairs that a small
caretaker or a small family could live
in and it would be a unit house by
itself there's also an L Edition on my
Cape that I intend to tear down I was
hoping to make it into an income uh
producing unit but I I didn't think I'd
ever be able to get past the zoning uh
Committee of my town what representative
van said early was uh there's no
incentive for the town to increase
density I can't agree with that more I
know my zoning board I know my town I I
they allow the the what do you guys uh
the Adu only because there's that state
law that says that you know you can have
a mother-in-law apartment legally now
but they never would have agreed to that
so I want to do two things I want to
provide some handicap housing eventually
when my house is given over to whomever
and I want to supplement my income so I
can what did you call it uh Aging in
place and
um that is my forever home my forever
dream I won't fill up a nursing home
and I just wanted to give you a little
picture of you know what the public how
much how valuable this would be to an
aging population that's in New Hampshire
and I'm happy to answer any questions
but thank you Mr chairman for letting me
speak well thank you for your outlook
and uh the descriptions uh
representative magic booty of a question
from this West yeah thank you thank you
for uh that was my term of Aging in
place and I think that as the New
Hampshire demographic is changing me
including uh would that not help to keep
our people in our state like you yes
were you finished sorry
uh absolutely in fact I think I mean I
maybe speak you guys would know better
than I do when I was originally
converting my house thinking it would be
handicap accessible for my 94 year old
mother
um I found that there was a way for her
to stay in my home and could have a
caretaker living there and instead of a
nursing home because we don't have
enough spots then I would be able to get
some assistance financially to pay for
that that was where this started 10 15
years ago and absolutely I couldn't
afford and there's not any spots for
nursing home and I'm going to be her age
at some point God willing and yes I will
be unless I have a catastrophic medical
problem then I will be able to
completely stay there and not cause
anybody any trouble take up any other
resources my one little road
I mean I live in a small house what you
were talking about septic and town and
things my house there used to be seven
people that lived in it for 10 years
there's only been one me and it's
perfectly capable of having a garage
apartment you know who could give me
income a caretaker three four people my
everything is built up the one thing I'm
disappointed about is I do have a well
and septic and we don't have Town water
anywhere close to me so I'm giving you
my story and I hope someday there will
be a bill that includes we who have
septics that are adequate I just had
mine refreshed and revived and you know
it's absolutely been tested and big
enough so anyway sorry to take up so
much time
next questions from representative
Wallace
my question for the festival thank you
uh next question is from Representatives
Davis
Mr chair uh this is a question for
representative
is it um also the case that the more
people who are aging in place the more
taxpayers New Hampshire has
absolutely
and they're more likely to stay here if
they can walk to the store when their
kids take their keys away
thank you
representative
uh thank you Mr chair I don't have a
question I just want to let you know
that my New England Schoolboy is home
for lunch
[Music]
next uh
we have a member from
from the public from Peterborough
Melissa French at the she on the line
representative Med short
thank you
it's Mr chair and should be good to go
uh give you a testimony and let us know
how you whether you support or oppose
this bill
thank you Mr chair in the committee
I support HB 341 I have also emailed my
testimony
my name is Melissa French I live in
Peterborough and I am a former board
member from Monadnock area transitional
shelter
I was on the board for the local shelter
and then I need to call in for help
I love the town I live in Peterborough
it's a great place to live we're renting
half of a big old house it's old and
creaky and beautiful
I love being able to walk into town to
go to the library or peek in the shop
windows
my son is a dishwasher at the diner and
walks into work
I'm in the local writers group my girls
still Girl Scout cookies I built a
community for myself and my family in
this little town
last month all this was in Jeopardy we
got an eviction notice the owner wants
to renovate so he can sell I let
everyone know we were looking for a new
place hoping Word of Mouth would help
people were sending me links for two
bedroom rentals for twenty two hundred
dollars a month
the median sales price for single-family
homes has risen nearly 23 percent since
January 2020 to 350 thousand dollars
a third of our income is fourteen
hundred dollars a month
we're currently priced out of our
community
we are competing with people with more
income and Better Credit listings are
rented before we can call them on the
same day that they go up
it looked Grim that my family of five
would be living in our car by the end of
April but my network pulled through for
me and someone local let me know about a
place that might be opening up we got a
lease for a house in Dublin we were
lucky
it is far more likely that my family and
others in situations similar to us could
be facing facing down housing and
security
we've lived in the car before when we
were foreclosed on in 2007. we
celebrated my child's birthday with a
cupcake and a candle from the grocery
store in our car seat because that's
where we lived
keeping your family safe and secure is
so much harder without a home I dread
being homeless but know with our state's
current housing situation it is likely
to happen again
I urge you to vote in favor of HB 341
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to speak I'm happy to answer any
questions
thank you Miss French for your
compelling testimony are there any
questions in this French will we go on
to our next speaker
seeing that I'm going to ask
uh
match Grays from the nhma New Hampshire
Municipal Association who poses the bill
to uh
please speak on it thank you chairman
Dolan this is nature Grace the New
Hampshire Municipal Association we do
oppose the bill there are really three
three things of concern I want to bring
up today
first is we would consider this a state
mandate
that would eliminate local control over
a particular area of zoning and we we do
oppose that I'm aware that many members
of this committee are aware of our
position on that so I won't go into
great detail
secondly representative air brought up a
a great concern which were the Practical
concerns that we have
whether we're talking about water and
sewer use uh you know areas for parking
or Road use one of the concerns that
communities have is
if suddenly a large number of
single-family homes in a particular area
are converted into four
basically Apartments what would that do
for their infrastructure
so for water and sewer as was mentioned
often they calculate their size of their
pipes for you know how many people are
anticipated and that's usually per
bedroom
so if you convert it and it's you know
you can't prevent a family from moving
in so you could have
something that goes from a four bedroom
to all of a sudden having you know uh
four couples in there so now you have
eight people instead of four
multiply that you're having
greater demands on Water and Sewer usage
which is going to require costly
upgrades similarly uh you know if we're
not requiring upgraded for parking you
might have instead of two cars you're
gonna have four or eight
you know at a certain point there's not
going to be street parking for this
number of cars where are we going to put
them all
um same thing with Road use you know
roads are designed for a specific usage
if we're talking about downtown it might
not be that that big of an issue because
you're probably designing them for heavy
usage all the time but if it's more
outside uh in the country you're looking
at something like the geometric design
standards which might say you know you
have a different type of Paving
and the third concern we have is some of
the ambiguity in the language here
importantly it was noted uh I think by
representative majority about the phrase
which can be connected to Water and
Sewer
there's no limitation on that
um so we'd be concerned that some
developer would come in propose a plan
he would meet all the Planning and
Zoning requirements
and they want to build essentially a
series of
a four unit uh buildings
and say well this can be connected to
Water and Sewer therefore there's an
obligation of human body to connect it
even though the meanest product might
not have that in their plans even though
that might require some sort of upgrades
along the way
and so we're concerned about how that
might end up costing communities as well
okay we have a question from uh
representative man chapudi
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr Greaves
for taking my question you brought up a
question about a single family home
going from four or two people to eight
in my case when I'm talking about the
Aging in place if I was a household of
uh two plus four kids six and then we
turn it around and we are just the two
of us or you know God forbid I've become
a single person and that would still the
house was built for six or seven people
so instead of having to move and
transition won't this give us
opportunity to age in place I
and it in that suburbs yes you know
instead of having to move my community
where I live won't this give us an
opportunity to live a healthy life
I think you bring up a great Point
representative
um you know for Aging in place my
understanding is in most cases what
happens is you know someone lives in a
home raises their family they then you
know all their children leave home and
uh you know they want to bring in
someone as basically a caretaker for
them
um and the household as they get older
so that wouldn't necessarily increase
demand
um but there are other possibilities
um you know someone uh as I believe was
mentioned
uh you know someone might have just an
average house like mine with two or
three bedrooms decide hey you know I can
gut the inside I can fit make this into
four units for small units you cannot
limit the number of people who live in a
unit if you're if you're renting to them
um certainly you can you can charge the
different costs but you can't limit it
so you know someone comes in we've heard
about how people are priced out
presumably even small units are going to
see high costs
um they're going to be in demand so if
you're converting my house to you know
four units who's to say someone might
not come in with their family of five
and and move in in one of those units
now we're talking about already five
people in one of those units we have
three more again you have this
multiplier effect so it it really
depends on what the use is and
unfortunately that's not something we
can control
representative to 11.
thank you Mr chair and thank you Nick
for being here today and taking my
question in regards to municipalities
paying for hookups of of uh new
buildings that are in their single
family
zones that have been changed to a Zone
to allow the four units my understanding
is the municipality owns the piping
at the street and if you're a property
owner wants to hook up the property
owner pays for that entire hookup so
it's not from my point of view I'm
thinking it's not an increased cost to
the municipality am I incorrect
foreign
I think you're mostly correct so
typically the way these projects works
is they'll be a new line run so I know
of one project for instance that uh a
uh uh basically a residential facility
for older people their septic system had
failed
they had to get hooked up to the
municipal water and sewer system
as part of that the municipality ran a
line down which is called Main Street
um and then the municipality offered for
uh anyone along Main Street to have that
hookup and therefore they had the cost
like you just described for anyone along
that street but they they had a a total
cost of you know a couple million
dollars and then they divided that up
based on how many people said yeah they
wanted the hookup
and there was this standard hookup fee
uh but there's also the possibility of
you know you adding a line on and then
the treatment plan itself not being able
to handle that influx of
of whatever it is that's coming down the
sewer pipeline and therefore you're
needing you needing to either uh build a
larger plant or or redesign your plant
so it can accommodate the new inflow
from the sewer similarly if you're
pumping water
um as I'm sure this committee knows from
dealing with bills involving the town of
Merrimack we're looking at possibly new
wells new well systems if it's an area
that needs treatment of that water
those additional costs as well in order
to pump uh the volume that's necessary
to keep the pressure in those lines to
make sure that contamination doesn't
happen and everyone has Safe Water
uh follow up Mr chair yes please go
ahead you know while I appreciate
everything you said and where you're
coming from
I have to I have to inquire that
never mind I'm good thanks
okay
um take care next the next speaker
uh is uh
Miss Friedman from
from Bridgewater
I I can I I would ask you to try to hold
your comments or your testimony for two
minutes
yes uh can you hear me
yes let's go right ahead yeah um uh Mr
chair I'll I'll keep it brief Mr chair
committee members uh my name is Aubry
Friedman I live in Bridgewater uh
private citizen just representing myself
I totally support this bill
um as the reasons already mentioned the
the housing is but even before the
pandemic this has been going on for a
long time this has been building up for
a long time and also let's not forget
the jobs too uh we need young people
here in New Hampshire to you know fill
the jobs and frankly they with families
and children and they they can't find
housing so you know the whole point of
this is to open up uh there's
restrictions that have been uh limiting
the uh building of housing now my main
point here is
um okay I live in Bridgewater I'm a bit
little bit of a NIMBY myself in that you
know we we want to keep the small
character and all that that's usually
the argument people use we don't want it
to turn into like big cities and stuff
with a bunch of apartments and so forth
so I understand that uh but frankly most
a lot of properties already have
covenants limiting what you can do
anyway so there's already going to be a
self-limiting mechanism in place
all over the state and it's not like all
these
multi-family units are going to pop up
all at once yeah there'd be a few more
here and there I don't think it'll
change the character of the towns you
look at Alexandria and Grafton which is
in the area where I live in they have no
zoning and they just look like regular
rural New Hampshire towns like
everywhere else mostly
spread out and not a bunch of
multi-housing so it really wouldn't
change the character but it would create
a lot more housing if you could have in
a par uh you know multi-family here and
there and it would definitely help the
situation and my last point is just
um this bill is kind of a upholding
property rights which is the big thing
for me let people do what they want on
their own property property rights are
very important but your neighbors should
not have a say in what you do on your
property and so um it only extends to
the limit of your property and it's it's
these planning boards and the zoning
boards and the busybody neighbors that
are causing the problems they object and
the then you can't do anything to your
housing to as all the benefits that have
been mentioned so I would like to see uh
property rights have held and create all
the benefits that as we've said the uh
just create more housing and where
people young people can come to the
state and actually have a place to live
and and that's it I I totally support
the bill thanks thank you our next
speaker is a lobbyist from the state
work and play a New Hampshire
organization Bill Stewart who would like
to speak in support of the bill and
you've asked for two minutes you got it
thank you Mr chairman I appreciate it um
I will keep it to two minutes
um Mr chairman members of the committee
again my name is Will Stewart I'm the
executive director of State work plate
and we are a Statewide non-profit whose
mission is to attract and retain more
young people here in the grant state so
I'll you know I'll Echo
the previous speaker's comments about
the need to have more young people here
in the state and you know for this
reason we're in support of HB 341 which
seeks to address the number one reason
that young people might leave the state
and that's not being able to afford to
live here
attracting and retaining more young
people is critical to the future of our
state New Hampshire as you may know is
the second oldest state in the country
with one of the lowest unemployment
rates and on top of this we're the
number one exporter of high school
graduates seeking a four-year degree
with 62 percent of these young people
leaving the state every year some of
them come back but many of them don't
so in short New Hampshire needs all the
people we can get in general and all the
young people we can get in particular
our businesses need workers and
customers as the previous speaker noted
our towns need volunteer board members
our non-profits churches and Civic clubs
all need volunteers to accomplish their
vital missions without which our
communities just can't function
about three years ago statework played
commissioned a survey to collect data on
why young people stay in and might leave
New Hampshire and the number one reason
we found is that the young people might
leave is that they just can't afford to
live here our housing both on the rental
and the homeownership side is just too
expensive and we heard this again and
again uh over and over last fall and
winter as we talked to young people in
nine locations across the state as part
of our policy and pint series
housing in New Hampshire is expensive
for just about everyone as we've heard
you know from those who were approaching
and or post-retirements uh to uh to
younger people as well but it's it's
especially expensive for younger people
who being early in their careers
generally make less money than their
more experienced counterparts uh young
people also face the additional burden
of student loan debt indeed New
Hampshire has one of the highest average
student don't let Stu
debt loans uh in the country and when
you're paying hundreds of dollars a
month in student loan payments you know
it makes it that much harder to afford
housing that's already expensive
you know there aren't any silver bullets
when it comes to making housing more
affordable in New Hampshire but here at
stay work play we see HP 341 as one of
several specific actions that the
legislature can take to help address the
state's housing crisis so with that I
will conclude and uh thank you for your
consideration
thank you Mr Stewart
representative Davis you have a question
yes thank you Mr chair and I'm not I'm
genuinely not sure who to whom to
address this question possibly to
representative van
but also also possibly to uh Mr Gray's
of nhma
and uh just speaking from the
perspective of Lebanon New Hampshire
where there are 13
000 people
as a member of the planning board we are
being inundated
with
um mega corporate National development
companies coming in wanting to put up
two three four hundred unit apartment
buildings uh in our city which will
radically increase the population in a
matter of months
uh and we're struggling to figure out
how to supply the infrastructure to deal
with with these things and and I'm
wondering
if
this bill and the development that it
might facilitate
could have a mitigating effect on these
um on these developments which which I
believe are not beneficial to our city
and to in generally to cities in New
Hampshire
who'd like to tackle that question
I think representative van
representative van give it a shot
unmute
thank you thank you so much for that
question yes part of the reason that I
think HB 341 is really important is
because it allows smaller development
development that is of a historically
appropriate size for our towns
and it allows local people to be the
developers and you know they hire local
plumbers and they buy their their
sheetrock at the local Lumberyard
um doing this smaller
has many advantages for towns because it
does in fact keep money in the town it
uh doesn't concentrate the development
in one giant development and it allows
neighborhoods to change gradually over
time
thank you
thank you uh next we have we have two
folks who want to testify uh both of
Ramada state
one from Virginia and one from Portland
Oregon uh
so I'm going to ask before I'm going to
let you speak I'm going to ask you to to
control your testimony to one minute and
I'll first go to Salem Firth from
Arlington Virginia
am I pronouncing your name correctly
Salim but can you hear me yes go ahead
Celine wonderful thank you for having me
um much of the testimony I gave this
committee earlier on HP 132 applies to
this bill as well which would achieve a
similar object facilitating a modest
increase in residential density allowing
more homes per lot would promote
affordability conserve Town resources
have less impact on Forest and farmland
and promote property rights we now have
experience with reforms that allow two
to four unit buildings around the
country you can see my written testimony
for evidence from Minneapolis Houston
Oregon and California that the policy
change under consideration is likely to
result in marginal rather than
revolutionary changes in residential
construction
um and I further my written testimony I
I laid out three categories of arguments
um for when
States should preempted when they
shouldn't
um those arguments are about property
rights Which towns should not limit
without a compelling reason uh fairness
between those who do and don't live and
have representation in a particular town
and solving Statewide problems that
cannot be addressed without using
traditional local policy levers in my
view single-family zoning is right for
reconsideration
um please refer to the written testimony
and thank you for your time I'm happy to
answer questions now or by email I
appreciate it thank you for your
testimonial our last uh uh individual to
testify is describes himself as a
lobbyist
from Portland Oregon uh Neil Heller Neil
you best for 10 minutes I can give you
one
that works one minute Works hi everybody
I'm Neil Heller of neighborhood Workshop
uh performa-based urban planning firm
here in Portland Oregon
I'm testifying today in support of House
Bill 341 because at fourplex is a house
it's important to understand that the
feds so the federal housing
Administration and your local banks
consider anything one to four units a
house and it can be financed in exactly
the same way that a oneplex is and is
owner occupied and a low down payment it
is our local zoning codes that create an
artificial limitation on the housing
Choice available for people and their
various life stages and family
Arrangements the nuclear family is a
thing of the past and more and more
households are one in two persons nearly
75 percent of American households are
singles living alone couples with no
kids or roommates so by by this
statistic 10 of the 13 reps that I can
see on my screen here fit this
description
I was the lead analyst modeling
Portland's single dwelling Zone update
that allowed up to four units on a
single dwelling parcel this effort
locally was underway prior to Oregon's
Landmark Statewide House Bill 2001 that
allows up to four units in
municipalities across the state
here locally even in a major American
city 84 percent of our residentially
zoned land was exclusively single family
this was pushing home prices ever higher
and Out Of Reach
Bill 341 does not mean that developers
can't build single-family homes but they
can now build other stuff too and this
will match changing Market needs and
important to understand that changing
codes does not cost you anything but it
is the equivalent of writing a 150 000
per unit affordability subsidy check
the modeling work that I performed here
locally demonstrated that amortizing
land and development costs across more
units reduces cost to the end user and
come in at Workforce income levels of
100 to 120 percent area median income
so now we anticipate Workforce housing
to be developed even in this time of
high Construction
so in addition we did not come up there
in order to achieve a regulated
affordable housing I propose an
amendment that was adopted to include up
to six units if some of them are
affordable at sixty percent Ami
providing new affordable home ownership
opportunities
so this bonus puts local affordable
housing developers on an even footing
and able to compete for Lots in
desirable High amenity neighborhoods
prior to this amendment affordable
housing developers were being pushed out
to the edges of the city in search of
less expensive land and so again
changing these policies cost the
community nothing but created a
framework where new housing options can
be delivered to our everyday residents
at rates within the standard income
levels these are your firefighters these
are your teachers and these are your
graphic designers
these zoning changes allowed us to
stretch our limited affordable housing
dollars further or allow us to push the
affordability deeper
if all they were allowed to do was
develop single-family houses the subsidy
required is around 550 000 per unit and
this is obviously an unsustainable
approach
Mr hello I'm gonna have to ask you to
wrap
yep I'm going to stop there thank you so
much I urge you to pass the house bill
341 for the working class residents of
New Hampshire and thank you for allowing
me to speak and thank you for your time
thank you uh with that I'm gonna close
the hearing
and uh that house bill and uh
341 and we're going to take a break a
half hour break for lunch and those of
you who are waiting patiently for
testimony on House Bill 266 and we will
begin that at one o'clock and uh thank
you for being patient
s
foreign
yes people
okay
right now okay we're back on over here
yeah okay Mike's alive
um
yeah
it's awesome
don't you agree with me I mean she's
really on the floor yes it's uh
she is
Mr chair
you're you're off
um uh
okay
Mr chair I just wanted to let you know
that I've made a request to Olf for an
amendment to 341 that uh sorts out the
whole question about what does it mean
about water and sewer it just says that
it has to be connected to water and
sewer and also uh fixed the question
about relevant building and fire codes
and also uh the lot coverage shall be no
more restrictive that was a typo that
somebody noticed anyway I have made a
request to get an amendment that will
correct all those things wait a second
I'm not the chairman
testing can you hear it now
come on now can you hear can you hear uh
Fair us now
are you muted
yes we can hear you now
yes
yeah the uh the whole room there is a
button on there
on the screen over here that says mute
the entire room and that's what we've
been trying to do with those lunch and
we'll take breaks because the mic stay
hot and
it can be embarrassing for people to
forget that
okay we're just waiting for a couple
people to come back from the restroom
and then we'll get started
Mr chair this is uh Jim majori just so
you know uh the prime sponsor
representative patuchik is
um is all queued up and ready to go when
you're ready okay good thank you
for you committing members who are
remote do you feel how hot it is
it's actually cooled off in here since
before lunch yeah
are you saying telling us that it's full
of hot air in that room
yeah a lot of hot air in this room
just
chair that's my tickle bone that
it's okay
representative majority if you want to
put me on video I am suitably attired
representative I have uh I I have made
you a panelist you are with us in sound
in sight
now why can't I see him on my screen
oh he looks like he's coming up and then
he's coming up there he is
we're gonna see you now John
thank you
I think we're uh we're ready to get
started yeah
welcome back everybody this is a
municipal and County government
committee
and uh we are reconvening after lunch
and uh our next action we're going to
take is to have a public hearing on
House Bill 266
and uh as we get started the
sponsor of the bill representative check
is here and I'd like to ask him if he
could introduce the bill
floor is yours
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
ladies and gentlemen of the municipal
and County government committee
uh for the record my name is John
petusic representative from Rockingham
six in Derry
I'm here to
I'm here to introduce House Bill 266 FN
local
it's relative to enforcement of
immigration laws and the prohibition of
sanctuary policies
the bill is actually relatively simple
it consists of three parts
part one which is on page one line six
starts the definitions of what the bill
is all about
part two is on page two line 10
immigration detainer request Sanctuary
policies prohibited
and finally uh part three the penalties
process is on page three line 24. the
complete process and penalties and we
put in a severability clause on page
four line eight
um a little history on this bill I froze
again
there I am okay A little history four
years ago I put in a very short
four-line bill
which did effectively
a small version of the same thing
it was heard when chairman Jim Belanger
was the chair
and it was voted itl because there were
at that time quote no Sanctuary cities
in New Hampshire
unquote
two years ago this bill was brought in
by another representative
and I was I had a chance to chat with
representative Belanger before he
retired
and at that time he told me John
we should have brought your bill in two
years ago
and that you can talk to representative
uh Belanger about because he will verify
that
now uh I have a legal advisor who will
testify uh after mate but I'm going to
point out a few of the Salient points
about reasons to ban Sanctuary cities
let me make one point clear this is not
a bill about immigration
this is a bill about Sanctuary cities
one first Point Sanctuary cities
threaten Public Safety
they do
number two Sanctuary cities conflict
with federal law
in 1996 law the illegal immigration
reform and immigration responsibility
Act
number three
Metro cities are expensive
Sanctuary cities in 2017 cost
New Hampshire
86.9 million dollars in costs associated
with illegal immigration
number four Sanctuary cities put
National Security at risk
um a case in point
um just before 9 11 two of the hijackers
were stopped on separate occasions by
police
if their backgrounds and immigration
status had been checked their plot might
have been uncovered
before
the tragedy happened
and number five Sanctuary cities are
unfair to Legal immigrants
and looking around at my peers on this
committee I know my great-grandparents
came in through Ellis Island legally and
quite a few of our
forebearers came in by either New York
or Boston or some other legal means to
become Americans
now with that I'm going to keep my
testimony very short because there will
be others who follow me who know more
about the technicalities and ins and
outs of this build than I do
so ladies and gentlemen I thank you for
your attention
and uh I will take any easy questions if
you have them for me
we have questions from the committee for
representative patuccio
we do Mr chair from representative
Gallagher
I see yes representative Gallagher go
right ahead
so
you so you said that this is not a bill
about immigration then why even bring up
immigration in your testimony and why
are there so many immigration related
groups signed up to testify
on this bill today
thank you for your question
representative as I said I went through
this four years ago
and the folks that tend to speak against
this bring up the immigration part of it
because that is what they do it is about
sanctuary
Sanctuary unfortunately involves illegal
people who are in our state
and that's about it and like I said a
legal representative who can talk more
about the ins and outs of this bill
after me
but I brought it up because some people
want to make it about
immigration
thank you thank you representative uh
Manchester
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative for taking my question uh
how do you define
um
immigrants
or
though a term you used was illegal
immigrants and Status less or
transitional immigrants so do you have
definition of the three different kinds
of immigration
uh thank you for your question
representative mangaputi uh I would
defer that to my legal representative
who will be speaking after me
and uh representative Gallard that I
hear you had a follow-up
yeah
um so
um
the representative
characterized the groups
um related to immigration uh mainly
being opposed to this legislation but at
least one of them is in support of that
is in support of the bill so
um if this isn't a bill about
immigration then why do you have
an
um immigration lobbyists testifying on
your side
think of your question representative I
do not know who is and who is not
testifying on this bill for or against
it
next we have representative stavis
representative for taking my question
cite the source for me for the 86
million dollars in costs of illegal
immigration that you cited in your
opening testimony
um
I do not have the data in front of me I
have a memo which was written to me by
one of the folks who uh is for this bill
and uh this person may be testifying
after me so could you hold that for my
legal representative
follow up Mr chair yes please
so representative you do not president
course of that data
I didn't get the whole question you
don't have the source for the data yes I
yes I do and this person will be tested
be testifying after me do you have the
memo that this person supplied to you uh
yes I do could you tell me the name of
the memo uh it's
it's a it's a personal memo between two
people
let's see thank you
a representative uh Gilman
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative
for taking my uh question
um you mentioned that this is not a bill
about immigration and yet that word is
used throughout the
um throughout the bill discussing
particularly in the um definitions with
the immigration detainer request of law
enforce immigration law
um quite you know it's quite a few
places so how is this not about
immigrants uh it is about thank you
representative for your question uh the
bill which as written is about
immigration laws and the prohibition of
sanctuary policies
you could not
um Define
who would get sanctuary
and what immigration laws were affected
without uh
having some information in here about uh
immigrants
the technicalities of this like I said
I'm not a I'm not a lawyer I'm not
versed in immigration law
I that's not my job
I would I want to defer the questions
about this to
um Miss Rendell who is my legal advisor
as she will be testifying
okay thank you thank you
thank you representative machiore
Mr chair and thank you representative
for taking my question
in comparing
House Bill 266 with House Bill 232 from
a couple of years ago
it seems to me that all of the language
that remains in 266 from 232 is is
verbatim
um the exceptions being a couple of
sections have been removed a definition
for inmate
and I think the cause of action has been
removed is that accurate
thank you representative it is accurate
thank you
representative mandapudi had a second
question yes thank you Mr chair thank
you for a representative I'm a little
confused
referring to an attorney is it a
personal attorney or an immigration
attorney that would be testifying on
this with the sources
uh
I only know of one person that will be
testifying and I do not know whether she
is an attorney uh
or not
um
I
know who she is but I do not know her
credentials but obviously
um based on my
knowledge
of her
she seems to have a good handle on what
she's doing
above and beyond that I really can't
comment Mr codification on my question I
am just asking I'm not asking about
who's testifying but you keep referring
to this immigration lawyer or when my
colleague asked about the source of the
memo it's your lawyer friend or attorney
or immigration expert whoever that
Turtle term you're using is it it's
comes across to me as it's your personal
attorney or personal uh
so I'm just trying to clarify in my mind
who is this who's going to be talking in
depth about immigration
uh
representative before you get the uh
and that I can tell the committee that
the person that representative is
referencing to a Sherry Rendell who is
next up to speak and offer testimony so
perhaps we can uh when she comes forward
we can ask her what her potentials are
yes representative Phil Evans
thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question
um after reading the bill a few times I
I noticed there were lots of forces of
the bill that we're going to be asking
local and state officials and entities
to participate
um and then I got a fiscal note and
there was no
money allocated or no money
uh issued to be allocated no money
reference to be allocated for these
services and my guess would be the
Attorney General would like to be paid
for whatever extra time he or she might
have to put in to deal with these issues
in your bill as would local officials
local law enforcement so what's the plan
to pay for this
I
unfortunately representative thank you
for taking my question but I do not have
an answer to that question
thank you sir
thank you
representative van you have a question
yes I do thank you very much Mr chairman
uh my question is similar to rep
ster 11's question which is
um
immigration requests for detainers are
not warrants
um they're not backed by judicial
anything so I guess my question is
if a local law enforcement officer
complies with a request for turning
somebody over to ice and it turns out
that it was a mistake
uh who pays for the damages because we
know that there have been a number of
cases one in Greenville that I remember
from a number of years ago and I think
also what in Exeter where that kind of
mistake was made and there was
considerable damage money awarded so how
are we going to pay for that
uh beg a few question representative uh
I'm going to defer legal questions to uh
Miss Randell
uh representative Davis do you have
additional questions
yes I do thank you Mr chair uh and thank
you representative for taking my
question I hope perhaps you do have an
answer to this one and I know that you
are a staunch supporter of the
Constitution
and my concern with this bill is that it
seems to violate at least in my view the
10th Amendment to the U.S Constitution
which bars the Federal
from interfering with the powers of
States reserved for or implied to them
under the 10th Amendment
so do you not see this as a slippery
slope
for example if the federal government
were to pass bills on gun control or
civil rights or what products could
legally be sold
might they not be able to interfere with
New Hampshire's rights under those laws
and would this law if passed become a
precedent that the Supreme Court could
point to
um thank you for your question
representative I knew I had that
information in here somewhere
but uh
I can't really find it and I would
appreciate it if you would ask uh Miss
Randell the same question I know she had
uh
she had uh give me the answer but I
can't find it in the document
documentation that I have thank you
representative did you have another
appointment you need to go to uh well I
I did I did have one at one o'clock but
I mentioned I had a chance to move it so
I will stay uh you can take my my video
off I'll stay on audio as long as I can
but I do have to make an appointment my
appointment later today
okay thank you uh any other questions
for representative for two checks before
he he has to uh depart for well before
we go to our next uh speaker
thank you representative uh if you could
stay on as long as you could we
appreciate it in case another question
came up okay at this point I'd like to
recognize
Sherry Rendell
if she's on the line
good afternoon chairman Dolan and other
distinguished members of the municipal
and County government committee thank
you for allowing me to testify today I'd
also like to thank the Bill's sponsor
representative John poticek
um there is a non-profit nonpartisan
organization of concerned individuals
who believe that our immigration laws
must be reformed to serve our nation's
interest fair was founded in 1979 we
have two million members and sporters
Nationwide including about 4 000 in New
Hampshire I am the director of state and
local engagement for fair
um
Fair strongly supports HB 266 if the
bill was enacted it would prohibit
jurisdictions from employing dangerous
policies that provide a safe haven or
sanctuary in which illegal aliens can
work and live without fear of
apprehension by federal immigration
authorities
many expect crimes committed by illegal
aliens to happen in big States like
California with huge illegal alien
populations however many would be
shocked to find out that these incidents
aren't limited to high immigration
States in southern border states alone
New Hampshire is sheltered its share of
criminal aliens
in a ice enforcement action
um in December 2018 a 44 year old
Brazilian native who was wanted in his
own country for embezzling smuggling and
Firearms was arrested in Windham for
assuming the identity of American
citizen
also in Windham in 2017 a passenger who
was in a van that was stopped for
erratic driving rodolgo raxton Garcia
was identified as a felon in New York
wanted for sexual conduct with a child
under the age of 14. in Manchester in
2015 Kailyn aldolfo Rivera was charged
with possession with the intent to
distribute after he was found with 100
Oxycontin pills at The Mall of New
Hampshire all of these individually were
illegally in the country
you ask about Sanctuary policies
Sanctuary policies come in all shapes
and sizes some of them are written some
of them are not some of them are enacted
through local laws While others
masquerade as welcoming resolutions some
even a Paris internal law enforcement
policies however they generally bar
state or local officials including law
enforcement from asking
detained individuals about their
immigration status and Reporting or
otherwise cooperating with Federal
immigration officials regardless of how
they're enacted or what form they take
the uniting factor is that Sanctuary
policies place a greater emphasis on the
welfare of illegal aliens than the
welfare and safety of citizens and legal
residents in their own communities
hundreds of cities and municipalities
Nationwide have just declare themselves
welcoming or Sanctuary these welcoming
or Sanctuary cities claim they do not
interfere without enforcement but simply
leave immigration enforcement to federal
agencies
however this is a matter of semantics as
welcoming or Sanctuary cities actively
impede the enforcement of federal
immigration laws and often attempt to
block or borrow free communication
between state and local officials and
federal immigration officials
clear and unambiguous violation of
federal law and is considered a
sanctuary policy regardless of what it
is called
since 2017 in New Hampshire there's been
a proliferation of counties and cities
some include chest Cheshire Deerfield
Dublin Harrisville Lyme and Manchester
but do not call themselves Sanctuary yet
their practices make them function as
sanctuary cities
enacting hb266 will ensure these
jurisdictions cannot prohibit or
restrict Communications with immigration
officials
unfortunately illegal aliens that reside
in sanctuary cities do not necessarily
remain within that locality
for example in the sanctuary City of
Lawrence Massachusetts which is only
four miles from the New Hampshire line
dozens were arrested in 2018 on federal
drugs firearms and immigration charges
in addition authorities seized 10 kilos
of fentanyl enough to kill half the
state of Massachusetts
according to the nus attorney Andrew
lelling Lawrence is a Clearinghouse for
illegal drugs pouring into New Hampshire
and Maine
just for your information New Hampshire
had the third highest rate of opioid
related overdose deaths in the court in
the country according to the National
Institute of drug abuse
most of those are related to fentanyl
the majority is manufactured in China
and Mexico and brought into the United
States across our Southern border
according to John Delena an associate
special agent in charge of the New
England field division of the Drug
Enforcement Administration cartels like
Mexico
are making decisions that are going to
affect what happens in New Hampshire he
says that these have much better
research and development than any
Fortune 500 company
furthermore shielding illegal aliens
needlessly endangers innocent lives
there are roughly 3 million criminal
aliens living in the United States that
is illegal aliens with criminal records
in addition to their unlawful presence
in this country
nearly 1 million of these have final
orders of removal these criminals should
not be able to continue to live in
communities and engage in further
illegal criminal activity
according to the office of Inspector
General in fiscal year 2019 immigration
officers Nationwide made 143 000 arrests
of aliens church with were convicted of
489 000 crimes
these crimes included approximately 45
000 assaults 6600 sex crimes nearly 2
000 killings opponents of sanctuary
policies justify shielding illegal
aliens from our immigration laws by
saying it's necessary for law
enforcement to build trust within the
community but by Community they mean the
people who violate our nation's
immigration laws not the community of
people whose laws were meant to protect
moreover state and local cooperation
with ice does not reduce the number of
non-citizens reporting or coming forward
with testimony about being criminalized
besides the fact that anonymous tips can
be given there are already a number of
programs that allow state and local
police to encourage victim and witness
cooperation by granting lawful status to
illegal aliens who Aid in the
prosecution of criminals if illegals
provide helpful information to police
they may qualify for a u t s or vawa
non-immigrant VISA which in turn allows
them to apply for permanent legal status
in the U.S
Sanctuary policies actually prevent
illegal alien victims a crime from
taking advantage of these programs
in addition many jurisdictions are
bullied into adopting Sanctuary policies
by Advocates claiming that honoring or
applying with detainers
would be unconstitutional in a violation
of the Fourth Amendment
the United States courts appeal for the
first circuit which governs New
Hampshire has never determined that
honoring or complying with detainers is
unconstitutional in morales Lee
Chadbourne the first circuit held that
for a federal government official to
issue a detainer they must have probable
cause to please that person is in the
country a lawfully
the only cop the only court that has
directly ruled on the question of
constitutionality of honoring detainers
is the fierce Circuit Court of Appeals
and ends meet simiso versus Texas in
that case the Court held that not only
honor not only is honoring detainee
detainers lawful under the Fourth
Amendment but that the state can require
its localities to do so
Additionally the court determined that
the state and local law enforcement are
not making independent decisions about
detaining someone but acting only where
there has been direction from an ice
agent who makes an underlying
removability determination therefore New
Hampshire law enforcement would be able
to comply with a properly made detainer
request as required by hb266
ice has just 20 000 employees only about
half were dedicated to the apprehension
and removal of illegal aliens the
cooperation of state and local law
enforcement whose number is about nine
hundred thousand strong is a force my
multiplier vital to Parenting out those
Among Us who wish us harm if ice is
forced to go into the communities rather
than secure our environment of local
jails many who wish us harm will not be
removed and others may be put at risk
hb266 ensures this cooperation
finally Sanctuary policies tell
individuals that despite violating
federal laws law enforcement and other
government officials will ignore that
just because the regulation of
immigration is a federal issue does it
mean that state and local law
enforcement agencies must Overlook
immigration violations that harm their
community
moreover state and local law enforcement
routinely operate in enforcing other
federal laws like gun control and others
immigration enforcement should be no
different
HB 266 is needed to clarify New
Hampshire's public policy of cooperation
with Federal immigration authorities and
for this reason we strongly support the
legislation
thank you so much other questions
for this testimony
yes representative Maggiore
oh thank you Mr chair and and thank you
for taking my question
um
this
um this bill pretends to amend RSA 103
am I correct
I believe that's correct
um you wouldn't know which section it
was amending yes Mr chair of follow-up
please go ahead section 103 RSA 103 is
the policeman's retirement system why is
it in that section and not 105 which is
the rights and responsibilities of
police sheriffs and
um and constables
this is a question for your legislative
Council in the New Hampshire State
Legislature we did not draft this bill
we have looked at the bill overall and
support the language of the itself
if you find another place that would be
better
than I would suggest putting it under
Section 105 instead of 103.
thank you representative
chair thank you for taking my question
I'm going to redirect my question about
the 86 million dollar number that was
cited by representative poticek at the
in his opening testimony he said that
you had information about that can you
please tell me exactly what those
numbers are
sure um thank you for the question uh
the 86.9 million he was referencing
comes from the fiscal cost study about
the Federation for American Immigration
Reform uh did in 2017 I'm happy to
provide a copy of the cost study to the
committee as needed follow-up Mr chair
yes please go ahead
uh and so the opening testimony that 86
I guess it's 86.9 million dollars now is
not a current figure that was cited
it was cited from the last report the
most current report that has been done
um
yes it is current
I was just giving you the date of the
actual study do you have your
methodology attached to the document
that contains this figure
um yes it is attached and I can tell you
right now
um that we have been asked that before
and I'm happy to share the methodology
as well
thank you
thank you next we have representative
Porter
thank you Mr chair this is related but
not directly as um an expert on
immigration law can you tell me how much
does it cost
um to go through the process to become a
U.S citizen now
representative um I cannot give you an
exact figure because that cost is going
to be different for other everybody who
goes through I can tell you it takes
thousands of dollars and many many years
including some people have have waited
to become as uh for 10 years or more
can I have a follow-up on that Mr chair
so I all of my um grandparents came to
the United States from Italy back in the
early 1900s
do you was it that expensive at that
time or I mean relatively speaking do
you know historically was it that
expensive for them to come over here and
become U.S citizens
I cannot answer that question directly
as I do not have those figures I am sure
that it was quite expensive but I don't
know for sure how much it would cost
um and at that point I know that the
immigration laws were different and
people were were you know numbers were
fluctuating and so it was probably
different at that point thank you
uh representative Gallagher
yes I am wondering why we should listen
to any testimony given by a group that
is classified as a hate Group by the
Southern Poverty Law Center
representative thank you for that
question
um
splc designates many people who disagree
with them politically as hate groups and
that has been evidenced by several
journalists in different Publications
thank you next uh representative
trelelevin
uh thank you Mr chair and thanks Ms
Rendell for taking my question
um I made a note during your testimony
that you uh you said that sanctuaries or
Sanctuary cities limit
or prohibit immigrants legal or illegal
in testifying or reporting to police
could you clarify that for me
um I don't what did you say I said that
it limits what
my note says that a sanctuary City or or
a city that offers Sanctuary or
welcoming
to an illegal or even illegal immigrant
might prohibit or Tamp down any
reporting that they might do to police
actually
um I believe what I'm I said is that
welcoming our Sanctuary cities actively
impede the enforcement of federal
immigration laws and attempt to block or
bar free communication so that was the
blocking or borrowing goes to the
communication between state and local
officials and federal immigration
officials I'm sorry Ms Rendell that's
not what I heard
um I heard you specifically say
um
limiting an immigrant from testifying or
reporting to police
um
possibly you've got written testimony I
could look at later
um representative I have submitted
written testimony already to everybody
in the committee but the only other
thing I can think of where you were
where I was talking about
um non-citizens reporting crime was that
where you were talking about
I said it doesn't reduce the number of
non-citizens reporting crimes are coming
forward about being criminalized because
anonymous tips can be given
um law enforcement officers are not
going to bite the hands that feed them
they are not going to
um go after someone's immigration status
who's reporting a crime or as a witness
to a crime
I respectfully disagree thank you Ms
Riddell representative Matt Yuri
thank you Mr chair and and thank you
again for taking my questions I asked
the prime sponsor on this if this bill
was largely if 266 was largely the same
as 232 except for the notable exceptions
which I hope I brought out and and he
agreed with that and at the time that we
heard
232 there were significant questions
about violations or conflicts that this
would pose to the fourth Fourteenth and
as we've heard 10th Amendment also if
these bills are exactly the same can you
please respond again I know you did I
know you did say something about the
fourth amendment in Texas can you please
respond to how there are no conflicts
with the Fourth Amendment 14th Amendment
and 10th Amendment to the United States
Constitution
um sure so with respect to the fourth
amendment I believe that I have
addressed that with respect to the 10th
Amendment the Tenth Amendment says that
any
um laws not done by the federal
government are reserved to the state
um this bill does is not a federal law
this is the state law that is um
deciding what what it wants its laws to
be
so in that for that reason the tenth
amendment is not implicated with respect
to the 14th Amendment this bill
um
specifically says it will not be
anything based on civil rights or racial
discrimination
and next we have a question from
representative
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um you kept using the word welcoming
communities and Sanctuary communities
into changeability
can you define where you got these two
definitions can you make
there are two distinct uh
definitions are two distinct communities
and to commingle
it is very harmful
and could you please give me the source
of where you're drawing the definition
of welcoming communities and Century
communities and thank you
thank you for the question
representative we are saying that
welcoming communities should be true of
every Community every Community should
welcome
people into their Community what we're
saying is communities that will turn a
blind eye to those who are coming into
their country illegally and
effectively restrict or bar or prohibit
communication that is what we consider
to be a sanctuary policy
follow-up Mr chair yes go ahead please
um thank you
I'm still not clear
where you're drawing the definition
between the two and this
is really
um
troublesome
my other question to you is also the
prime sponsors mentioned that you will
be addressing the different definitions
of immigration immigrants different
categories and you would have a better
handle better able to address my
question of different definitions would
you be kind enough to give me the
definition how you define immigrants
illegal legal
um sure sure thank you for the question
the immigration nationality act uh
actually is the one that defines what
the terms are and they have the term
alien meaning any person who is not a
citizen or a national of the United
States
they also just determine who may and who
may not enter the country
um based on the Ina
and I'm happy to provide you with a full
site of all of those definitions if you
want
yeah could you could you please send
them uh to the committee I appreciate it
representative van has a question
okay
thank you thank you represent thank you
chairman Dolan thank you uh Ms Lindell
my question is I had always understood
that immigration violations are not
criminal violations in the same way that
you know robbing somebody is can you
speak to that that violating uh so the
question is if I violate the immigration
laws have I committed a crime or have I
done something less than a criminal act
yeah representative most uh immigration
violations are civil and nature there
are some that are criminals such as
re-entry and so I hope that addresses
your question
now representative the Salas has a
question
yes
um thank you for taking my question I'm
a great believer in the rule of law
in this country we have uh 50 states and
literally thousands of cities and
municipalities
uh that all have their own sets of
ordinances and laws and so forth
what government entity is responsible
for
establishing the overall immigration
laws for this country
right now Congress
um is the one that establishes our
immigration law most of it
thank you a follow-up Mr chairman so
if Congress is responsible for
establishing the law
and we have established immigration law
that is on the books
then I think it behooves every law
enforcement officer No Matter What
entity that he is uh is involved with to
participate in in
enforcing those laws
would you agree with that
um yes
thank you
all right uh representative uh status do
you have an additional question or do
you want to wave off
representative Missouri
yes thank you again Mr chair and thank
you for taking my question I apologize
the the bill that I printed off did not
have the line number so I apologize for
not citing it by line number but in
proposed section 103 Dash a colon 3
Roman 1 sub a
fully comply with honor and fulfill any
instruction or requests made in the
detainer request and in any other legal
document provided by a federal agency
um there there and this question was
asked before I assume that there will be
costs for this and those costs will be
will be
um uh will will be born by the local
agency so it's a two-part question are
those costs reimbursable by the federal
government for that compliance
so representative I just want to clarify
there uh there are always costs
associated with with law enforcement
complying with things and I can tell you
that uh immigration officers are not the
only ones to issue detainers and yet
detainers are not an issue when the US
Marshals or other or other law
enforcement officers issue them the only
time they seem to be an issue is when it
is in the realm of immigration law with
respect to reimbursement of costs um
some of them can be possibly reimbursed
through the state Criminal Alien
assistance program
um there are some other alternatives for
that as well
thank you Mr chair quick follow-up to
that go ahead
um so then I'm curious if you feel that
there may be any issue with uh with
unfunded mandates as we have uh which
are which we have in RSA 28a if those
costs are not reimbursed
um I do not believe this was an unfunded
mandate this would be the same directing
its localities to follow a state law
um it's not a mandate by the federal
government
thank you
additional questions
yes Mr chair thank you
um
I'm trying to think of putting it
very as a matter of fact
how would you
describe how would the local authorities
find and prosecute
or bring people
to court
based on
immigration status
so are you suggesting that I as a
naturalized citizen should have to carry
a card so that I can protect myself from
any stop or unnecessary rust because I
look different
representative absolutely not we firmly
believe that in legal immigration what
is uh not the officer's job to go out
and round people up but if somebody is
in the jail system then if if the uh
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
finds that and individuals in jail they
will issue a detainer and at that point
we want the officers to be able to
comply with the detainer request
follow-up Mr chair yes go ahead
let me calm down
I'm sorry let me calm down okay I'll
come back to you all right um I'm ready
all right go ahead how how would you
characterize
legal immigrants illegal immigrants
without racial profiling or who are
detained
so
are you defining
anybody that's detained
as
illegal immigrants or criminals
and isn't the law says unless proven
guilty you're innocent
representative I'm not sure where you
got that from what I am saying is ice
has to determine whether someone is
removable or not they have to have
probable cause when they issue a
detainer there is a probable cause that
is attached to that detainer and once
that is presented to law enforcement
only at that point would the law
enforcement officer hold the individual
for up to 48 hours it's only up to 48
Hours
um for ice
the now I'm not quite sure what you are
asking with legal immigrant versus
someone here illegally I didn't quite
follow that and if you can clarify you
know how you define
how can visually our local officers
figure out we need to let the uh
those testify and answer the question if
you want to follow up you need to
request a follow-up I don't want to have
a uh I'm going to dialogue to chat I
will shut up
okay uh representative
thank you Mr chair and thanks Ms Rendell
for taking another question uh I'm a tad
confused
ice is a federal government entity is
that correct
yes ma'am thank you and the federal
government has control over the
immigration laws of the entire United
States of America is that correct
that immigration is a federal issue yes
thank you and immigration is a civil
matter not a criminal matter
um that is correct under our immigration
laws the ice enforcement has civil uh
Authority and under the Ina they have
the ability to arrest detain or remove
individuals who have
illegally entered this country and who
are removable
let me let me jump out I want I want to
ask the committee to please limit
yourself to one question at a time and
uh and then because we have so many
so many people wanting to testify what
if you need to follow-up to staff
um I'm sorry Mr chair may I have one
more follow-up yes please
I asked the questions in those ways to
clarify this is my last question and I
think Ms Rendell has answered it but it
will help to clarify so what I want to
understand is how ice involves our state
county and local law enforcement
officers in detaining quote unquote
potential illegal immigrants if they
have not committed a crime
representative they have ice has the
authority to issue a civil detainer
under the Ina that is a simple request
issued to law enforcement officers in
the same way that another law
enforcement agency would issue a
detainer to a local or state law
enforcement agency this is not a matter
of a criminal or civil violation what
we're saying is this is the issuance of
a detainer request
is that clarifying what you were asking
me yes thank you
thank you and uh question from
representative McDonald
we don't have police officers New
Hampshire going and kicking down doors
looking for illegal immigrants do we
to my knowledge you do not
default
isn't it true that
a large majority probably 90 plus
percent of people that
are detained by law enforcement is due
to them being stopped from committing a
previous crime and that's how their
contact has been has happened
the majority is either they were because
of a crime or in the jails where their
name or information was run through the
system and Ice has been able to
determine that they have an interest in
an individual
okay I'm going to take one more question
for this witness from uh the minority
leader and then I'm going to move on to
the next witness we have like I said
about 15 people who still want to
testify so representative Porter
thank you Mr chair I guess I'm just a
little confused and I'd like a
clarification
um Miss Rendell
in in answering um representative to
11's question you said that it was a it
was a civil detainer and it was a simple
request to law enforcement
so can they under the provisions of this
bill law enforcement would not be able
to
um
not not comply with the request they
wouldn't have the option you know they
come and say we want you to he has a
request for a detainer an irlr
enforcement officers could not say no is
that what this bill would do under this
bill the the state law would require
them to comply with uh detailing they
would be forced to comply to a request
they would be uh they would be required
to comply with a detainer request thank
you
okay uh
thank you Miss uh Miss Rendell uh if if
you could be so kind to stand by
um I'm not sure if there'll be more
questions for you but there might be but
I want to try to bring in some more
people who both oppose and support the
bill
um and you've uh so far you've you've
held up well with the we're approaching
30 questions already
so at this point I'd like to move on and
and invite
Vanessa Blaze from Manchester uh who
opposes the bill
I am looking Mr chair
I
don't see her chair I do not see and
since Vanessa Blaze is a member of the
public I do not have any other way other
than her first and last name to try to
find her if you wouldn't mind that I'll
keep looking and you move on to somebody
else okay the next
person would be Maggie
folk men's service committee who opposes
the bill
know that I have search capacity
it's okay we have a lot on the list so
I'm sure we can find someone that's
there uh we have a lobbyists
named Grace uh Kentucky
who for the American Foreign Service
committee
oh there we go okay oh there we go okay
um so I do see grace kandiki and should
be all set to go all right thank you and
please uh identify yourself
yes thank you hello and thank you to the
committee for taking my um giving me the
opportunity to speak my name is Grace
condecke and I am the program
coordinator with the American friend
service committee
um and I'm also from Manchester and have
lived the majority of my life in the
granite state after immigrating here as
a toddler in 1989. I know firsthand what
it's like to live is both an
undocumented immigrant and a documented
one in the granite state I'm here in
opposition to HB 266 and urged the
committee to Market in expedient to
legislate the foremost and direct impact
of this bill would be to undermine
relationships between residents and law
enforcement it would it would make
exponentially less safe for people to
rely on police because as an immigrant
every encounter with police can turn
into a very real possibility of being
detained and later deported prohibiting
local communities from taking actions to
prevent cooperation with Federal
immigration enforcement means that
formal and informal Cooperative
agreements will endanger the growing
Community immigrant community of the
granite state which totals over 83 000
immigrants these are people are our
loved ones our family members our
neighbors they are taxpayers workers and
business owners
when I was a very little girl I'll tell
you a story about living in Manchester
when I was a very little girl in early
Elementary School I got separated from
my aunts and found myself lost in a
department store in my child mind I
thought the best thing I could do was to
leave the store and go find my mama who
was working at the time I walked by
myself at night down Hanover Street in
Manchester until an older white couple
who were out for a stroll heard me
crying and stopped me they took me to a
nearby convenience store bought me a
snack and called the police who came and
picked me up a very kind officer took me
to the local police station on Pine
Street found my frantic aunt and helped
to reunite us I was undocumented at the
time although I didn't know it because I
was so young and if at any point in time
the officer had asked my family their
immigration status as I likely would
have because they would have taken
identifying information to ensure that
they're matching the right child in the
family and hunting down the parents then
they would have reported it to Federal
immigration enforcement because that's
what these detainers are because of a
Cooperative agreement that we would then
we would have been in danger of being
detained and deported because that
information would have been used against
us and Ice would have known where to
find us this bill the bill sponsor
claims that this bill would make New
Hampshire safer and that is not true
immigrant community members know very
clearly that even the most routine
traffic stops even the most innocuous
instances where you do need police help
puts you in that front line danger and
like acid this bill would erode the
trust between the community and local
fishes local officials and service
providers and if we want to retain a New
Hampshire that is truly not only
welcoming and inclusive but is actually
safe for all Granite Staters then I
strongly urge you to say no to this bill
thank you any any questions for
uh Miss Kentucky in decade decade sorry
thank you
uh representative ninja putty
thank you Mr chair
um Miss Kentucky
how would you describe
the safety in terms of the largest city
in the state
and Manchester second largest is Nashua
we have a lot of diversity how do you
feel currently without this bill our
relationship or the minority
relationships both communities are
welcoming communities how is it with our
police and City officials
I would say that between the Immigrant
and community and this and the police
um as was illustrated by the bill that
came up last week HB 328 in terms of
driver's licenses for immigrants in the
state that there is a lot of cooperation
in Goodwill between immigrants in law
enforcement for around issues that are
about community community and Community
safety because people want to work
together Manchester is the largest city
in New Hampshire but New Hampshire is
still a very small state and after
having lived in Boston
um and having experienced the community
there and experienced it here I know
that there's a lot of effort that
Community leaders community members as
well as law enforcement have done in
order to build community relationships
together as have been very well seen
between the relationship that um that is
between the Nashua police and BLM Nashua
that those those relationships have been
ongoing and being built over a long
period of time in a bill like this does
nothing except really and I excuse my
French it really takes a big dump on all
that work in that effort and now those
relationships that have been built up
through Blood Sweat and a lot of
conversation and a lot of love
thank you
but Mr chair sorry to interrupt you but
I did find with the help of Christina
Dyer Maggie Fogerty from the New
Hampshire peace Alliance if you would
like to go back to her okay thank you um
there's Fogerty uh please tell us who
you are where you're from and how you
feel about this bill and I I'm only
going to limit you to two minutes
uh thank you very much yes I'm showing
up as uh from the New Hampshire peace
action but I actually am uh Maggie
Fogerty from the American friend service
committee we share a zoom account so I
can't sometimes control how I enter into
the meetings but Mr chairman and members
of the committee thank you so much for
this opportunity to speak
um I am a Dover resident I work for an
immigrant rights organization and I am a
member of uh Dover Friends meeting at
Quaker Meeting which is a uh proud
Sanctuary congregation and in all of
those capacities I'm here in strong
opposition to HB 266 as has been said by
my colleague Grace kendeke this is a
proposal that would erode the safety and
the well-being of our communities and
rolls back all sorts of thoughtful work
that's been done locally the current
context of U.S immigration law is that
it is convoluted it is chaotic it is
cruel it is a collection of policy sees
built over many many decades on the
exploitation of Labor and the profit
motive of private prison companies and
because of this millions of people in
the United States and many thousands in
New Hampshire are in limbo they have
every desire to regularize their status
to raise their families here and to
remain together without fear of
expulsion it is a desire that people
have had as they came to New Hampshire
over hundreds of years it is the
majority story here in New Hampshire and
Congress has failed for decades to
establish Humane Common Sense
immigration policy and it is long past
time that they do so but in the midst of
this chaos New Hampshire communities are
suffering tremendously and it's
Insidious it's the grinding stress of
uncertainty of trying and failing to
sort things out of spending thousands of
dollars on attorneys who who can't even
find opportunities for Relief because
the laws are so inadequate and it's
waiting in agony for an application to
be approved and hoping that nothing
disrupts the process in the meantime I
have been visiting ice detainees at the
Stratford County jail since 2014 and I
have met mothers and fathers who were
arrested for the most minor of incidents
or non-incidents and they've been taken
from their families for what for rolling
through a stop sign for asking for
directions for having a flat tire in the
case of one Community for offering the
local police to help with interpretation
when they arrived to a crime scene Mrs
Fogerty I'm going to have to ask you to
wrap as soon as you can I will thank you
I'm from Dover our community has figured
out how to have a healthy balance of
policies that allow local policing to be
on the side of of local realities and to
keep this separation so I urge you to to
prevent this harm full proposal from
from becoming law in New Hampshire thank
you questions from this Fogerty
representative thank you Mr chair thank
you Miss Fargo your testimony and taking
my question I would like you to just
simply focus on the definition
of welcoming communities and Sanctuary
communities are they interchangeable are
they too different or are they
one and the same
uh well that's an interesting question I
mean I think that there is not really a
precise definition of a sanctuary
Community it is subject to
interpretation although I know what I
recognize as a sanctuary provision is a
provision that says Federal immigration
is just that and it would erode local
trust local safety local community
strength if we were to conflate that
with uh Municipal uh and local law
enforcement and welcoming communities
are just a matrix of ways that we say we
celebrate diversity we want all kinds of
folks to be able to make a home here and
Thrive and that we recognize our own
history as people who
almost always have come from somewhere
else
thank you for that uh
next I want to recognize
[Music]
um
Mr
oh I'm sorry to representative Tripp has
a question
thank you Mr chair
uh thank you for taking my question
uh you said that uh
part of your uh duties with the friends
is uh visiting people
uh who are incarcerated in jail or
whatever do you uh you know why they're
incarcerated
yes so Stratford County Jail in Dover
has a about a hundred bed contract with
Federal immigration enforcement uh it is
a significant stream of Revenue that
funds County operations and the jail
allows us to visit anyone there in ice
custody and overwhelmingly these are
folks with no criminal marks on their
records at all they are all uh they are
primarily immigration status violations
people whose request for Asylum have
been denied uh people who have because
of chance local encounters been found to
be out of status but uh it is they are
people there in civil detention
not criminal custody
thank you representative for Levin thank
you Mr chair thanks uh Ms Fogerty for
testifying today
um you just said it they're in civil
detention not criminal detention and a
few moments ago we were discussing
during a previous speaker's testimony
that 48 Hours was the longest that
uh person can be detained so I'm
confused can you clarify for me
yes people speaking after me can speak
more precisely to what a detainer
request is and what law enforcement can
do but I will say there are immigrants
in detention for years who are just
stuck in a process that offers them no
way out even to deportation it is it's
horrible and it's hidden so no detention
immigration detention can be very very
long
thank you uh next
um
about alternative representative power
as we're doing a little cross training
here I want to recognize
Mr Grays from the nhma and then after
him go to Maureen baloney
debris you've asked for one minute
and uh you and you guys speak in
opposition to the bill yes thank you Mr
chair my name is Nate Graves I'm with
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
in the interest of time I'll just say
that nhma opposes this bill my colleague
Cordell Johnston earlier submitted
written testimony outlining our position
if anyone has questions I can take those
but I would also add that I would defer
to the ACLU and others who are better
versed in this particular area of law to
answer technical questions I've heard a
number of technical questions here that
I just uh I'm not that familiar with the
answers to
you had a question
yeah thank you Mr Grace for taking my
question the opposition is you will
represent the municipal Association
correct that's correct a position is is
it due to the cost it adds to the local
municipalities or is it just uh
communities and the workforce what is
the point of what is the highlight of
the opposition
so we we identified a number of areas in
the bill that we had concerns with
one being that uh the bill
prohibits municipality for enforcing a
policy or taking another action in
violation of of federal law but of
course municipalities already have to
comply with federal law so there's no
need for state law to compel compliance
it also
um further prohibits municipalities from
adopting any policy that restricts or
discourages inquiring about the
immigration status of any individual
when we spoke with police Chiefs across
the state they emphasized that the
municipalities are safer when residents
are comfortable reporting crimes and
otherwise cooperating
and there was concern as as we've
already heard here today about how the
police and citizen interaction will
occur and local authorities are better
positioned to determine what's best for
their own cities and towns and that's
really kind of the emphasis that we want
to emphasize even though our letter
doesn't outline every concern that we
have it just seems that the decisions
the local level
make more sense because local officials
know who their citizens are and they're
able to talk with them more effectively
um
then and does we don't need this uh
legislation to to require that
a representative Gallagher you have
yes um one of the principles that the
municipal Association often
um cites
when
um choosing to support or oppose
legislation is that of local control
um could you go a bit more into depth
about how the principle of local control
comes into play here
sure so
um
a ice detainer request is a request it's
not a document with the force of law
federal law doesn't require the local
authorities hold anyone based on the
request alone
and I would certainly defer to the ACLU
for for a further explanation of that
but my understanding is that
um
when state law here would require local
police departments to fully comply with
ice detainer requests as well as any
other legal document provided by a
federal agency
it wouldn't be clear exactly what
municipality should be doing and there's
possibility as we've heard here that
municipalities would inadvertently
violate individuals constitutional
rights by attempting to interpret this
this phrase which
we're not entirely sure what it means
um so
it makes more sense that at the local
level
you know the the local police uh and the
local officials working with their local
communities make determinations about
what kind of local policies they have
and they want to have to determine what
they should do in these difficult cases
thank you and next we'd like to go to uh
Darren Nelson if he's available from
Hanover
uh do we have him on the line
the chair I did not see searched
okay uh how about representative Joseph
Shapiro
searching again I just searched him
earlier and I could not find out
another one that signed up to speak is
Bruno Soros
from Catholic Charities
okay Mr sores
from nashworth let me uh you've asked
for five minutes I only can give you two
can you wrap it in two
chair asked him
you need to unmute uh Mr swords
if you're on the uh
on the phone I think it's star six time
news and
star nine two of you star nine I'm sorry
star nine there you go
are you with us
I don't show you it muted anymore Mr
Source are you with us can you hear us
hello Mr Soares
all right
um
let's try uh
asthma al-huny
who's a lobbyist from Lebanon she would
like to speak
in opposition to the bill
yeah can you hear me
yes we can can you uh limit your
testimony two minutes
um I will try my name is asthma hunina
and the movement politics director for
rights and democracy New Hampshire a
Grassroots organization that promotes
human rights and I'm really not
understanding why a hate group gets all
these minutes and then you want to limit
us to two minutes you know uh I think we
should respect affected community and
listen to our voices we live in New
Hampshire
there's a point of order being made
uh we've asked her for her testimony
yes uh Mr uni uh please provide your
testimony
um and try to keep it to two minutes yes
I will give you my testimony after I I
share one and some of this I'm speaking
from my my heart I want to start off
yes is this testimony
yes this is testimony this is testimony
absolutely by a New Hampshire resident
and I'm also the movement politics
director for rights and democracy New
Hampshire I am a Lebanon resident of New
Hampshire
all right please continue thank you
I want to start off by saying I am a
proud Muslim woman who wears hijab and
I'm also an immigrant and I'm really
upset about this bill for several
reasons I'm very familiar with the way
immigrants are racially profiled and
police and discriminated against through
the use of policy
um representative
um patusic said if Muslims were racially
profiled then September 11th would not
have happened I want to start off by
saying shame on you rep for trying to
encourage racial profiling my community
has been surveillance we've been put on
Registries we've been deported and we've
been targeted the fact is the majority
of terrorists are done by white
supremacists in this country and if
you'd like data I can send you data on
that too
to impugn the the intentions of a of a
representative is not an order so I'd
ask you to move on please sure I also
just want to point out the fact that you
are a sponsor on the bill is quite
interesting as well in your chairing
this committee I also want to share
several things with you first immigrants
I'm sorry I'm sorry
continued personal attacks I'm not
personally attacking I'm stating a fact
is that an attack I'm just stating a
fact I want to share several things with
you first immigrants are not only
community members and family members
they're also fellow Granite seders they
contribute
we've had to mute you because uh you
you're not wanting to follow the decorum
of the committee uh we will not listen
to attacks or suggestions of impropriety
by by representatives of the State of
New Hampshire I'll give you one more
time I'm gonna unmute you and give you
one more chance to get your testimony on
the record we're asking you to speak to
the bill and not to impugn the
intentions of any of the personalities
that may be involved
you
[Music]
foreign
as I said the immigrants in our
community 15
000 undocumented community members New
Hampshire rights Granite Staters who
live in our community deserve the
benefit of the doubt they are our
laborers they're our friends they are
family members and we want to benefit
from their labor but we don't want to
offer them the basic human rights of
being treated like human beings and I
want to also state that most people that
are undocumented came here legally and
the only reason why they don't have
documentation is because of language
barriers and it's difficult for them to
renew their visas for most people right
according to the American economy
undocumented immigrants paid
77.1 million dollars in taxes that's
18.6 million dollars in state taxes and
that's 58.4 million dollars in federal
taxes I live in Lebanon and in Lebanon
and in Hanover we have something called
the welcoming ordinances that immigrants
are incredibly grateful for and they
tell me thank you so much for passing
this ordinance because we were worried
that police officers may stop us and
then call Immigration Customs
Enforcement and then have us deported so
this is a way to tell immigrants that
this is an inclusive in uh Community for
everyone and also I also want to stay
according to the Poverty Law Center
numerous quirks have found that cities
and counties that comply with ice
detainer requests in the absence of a
Judicial warrant
are violating a person's Fourth
Amendment right against unreasonable
search and seizures and have required
those governments to pay damages to
those people they held in jail as a
result of detainers I can also offer you
that information law enforcement should
not be in the business of enforcing
civil immigration that's really a waste
of tax dollars and for this sake we
should and for the humanity of these
people we should vote to itl this bill
immediately
yeah thank you uh representative to 11
you have a question
uh for uh Ms El uni no I'm sorry I do
not have a question for her my hands are
not by a mistake thank you okay thank
you all right next uh to testify we have
Persian
uh who would like to speak in opposition
to The Villages from the New Hampshire
Alliance for immigrants and refugees
good afternoon can you hear me yes go
right ahead you sound fine thank you for
taking my testimony my name is Eva
Castillo I'm a resident of Manchester
and uh I am the director of the New
Hampshire Alliance for immigrants and
refugees I advocate for the rights of
immigrants in New Hampshire for over 20
years I have had countless meetings with
different police departments all over
the state in fact I am a police
commissioner in Manchester uh I started
in 2011 and and I served for six years
and I just came back after my mandatory
retirement uh because I do believe in
building uh trust and in building good
relationships based on uh on respect
mutual respect and understanding and I
and I see that many immigrants mistrust
the police and I also spend a lot of
time talking to police departments all
over the a place about cultural
diversity and immigrant attitudes and
immigration inside so I am speaking
both as an advocate for immigrants but
also as a person that has strong ties to
different police departments this bill
is totally wrong I know for a fact that
so many police departments have spent
countless times and a money and effort
to build relationships because they
recognized that uh when everybody feels
safe and accepted our community as a
whole is safer for everybody so this
bill would undermine all those
relationships of trust that they have
spent so much time uh so much time
building and when when they become
entangled in Immigration enforcement
that's going to hamper all public safety
for all of us ultimately is the
responsibility of federal immigration
authorities to enforce federal law
police departments are here to enforce
criminal law
uh the lady that spoke from Fair did not
get the memo that DHS got forbidden the
use of alien uh now they're supposed to
be called
non-citizens uh thanks to the Biden
Administration so people are to be
called from now on non-citizens
um
so please you know I get a stomachache
every time I I hear the I the I word
uh you know so this is this build really
makes no sense whatsoever no Sanctuary
City policy has ever impeded or stopped
uh emit ice from doing their job
they they
um the the detainers ice detainers are
not mandatory and they they There's No
Business of police enforcing immigration
law let the feds take care of the feds
we should not spend our limited
resources doing the job of the federal
authorities so for all these reasons I
oppose this bill and I urge you to keep
New Hampshire safe and let each Police
Department know what's best for the
communities that they serve yes
representative Rudy has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you Miss Eva
Costello for uh taking my question have
you been involved with the race and
Justice uh project both in Manchester
and Nashua where the communities have
worked diligently with the police
department with the municipalities and
the communities immigrant Community to
build the trust increase the public
safety and celebrate the diversity and
harness the human potential yes I have
been involved with both the cities and
also with the Statewide effort uh
sponsor for for the equity and race and
Equity Group and I work in the law
enforcement for the group for the past
three years it's a Statewide effort to
build relationships of trust and respect
and understanding thank you
representative lasalles do you have a
question yes
um Miss Castillo turgeon um
thank you for taking my question
during the Obama Administration the
Department of Homeland Security
said that anything over 1 000
unaccompanied minors per day on the
southern border would be a crisis
today there are over 4 000 unaccompanied
minors per day crossing the border would
you say that's a crisis
uh you know what I heard before to
instruct not to talk about immigration
we're talking about police and immigrant
relations we're talking about an issue
that doesn't have anything to do with
the border with people immigrating here
so respectfully I really don't see the
relevance of this question
representative Tripp your question thank
you Mr chairman uh
I believe I heard you say that uh
the federal uh
uh enforces should enforce federal laws
and uh the state should have nothing to
do with enforcing federal laws is that
correct that's right it's not their job
so you have a follow-up I have a
follow-up so uh uh you you would uh say
that uh
people that are and not necessarily
non-citizens uh that are uh
breaking Federal narcotic laws it's not
that the the
state's issue to enforce those laws no
that's not what I'm saying when you
commit a crime I have no problem
whatsoever with people being
incarcerated and these bills that that
people the police departments have or
these policies that they have about not
honoring ice detainers have absolutely
nothing to do with with criminals
they have to do with people like
somebody else refers before that are
driving without a license that are here
uh just presence was unlawfully present
but they have committed no crime I have
no problem whatsoever with people that
have committed crimes being incarcerated
this is my community too I don't want
criminals uh here of any kind
so uh
civil breaking committing a civil crime
it's not a crime
immigration being here unlawful
represent is not is not agreement it's
not a crime per se it is a civil
violation
okay next uh do we have uh Mr Nelson
uh into
the uh Darren Nelson from Hanover
did you not see
me
cheese
about the representative Shapiro
um Mr chair I'm noticing that
representative Gallagher has his hand up
I'm not sure why
yeah I'll come back to him
thank you I do not see Mr
uh representative Gallagher you got a
question
yeah I wanted to follow up
representative lasalles's question about
the southern border
um which was he was directing it to Ms
Castillo so I guess that would be who
I'd be directing it to as well unless I
can I direct it directly to him no we're
not here to ask questions from other
committee members just from those that
are testified so can I ask is Miss
Casino still here
I'm sorry as Miss Castillo still here
then
you have to Castillo virgin is that who
you're looking to speak with yeah
I'm not sure if she's still here are you
still here
I think that she may have uh
live I'm seeing her hand I think she's
still here
well she's not responding so uh maybe
she dropped off
no she's she has to be unmuted uh Mr
chair
she's uh she's not muted
I am am I can you hear me now oh yes I'm
just back now uh representative
Gallagher had a question for you yes yes
um so
um
regarding
regarding the southern border so
does New Hampshire's Southern border
um is it shared with the Border along
Mexico
no I share with the border of
Massachusetts but although sometimes we
don't like Massachusetts people too much
but I don't think we have a crisis of
people massively migrating from Mass
okay thank you that's all thank you
all right um
we have uh gills Bissonnet uh incube
uh he is uh from the New Hampshire ACLU
the lobbyist and he would like to speak
in opposition to the bill right are you
with us thank you I I think so can you
hear me we can't hear you and I like to
ask you to limit your testimony to two
minutes understood understood can I be
seen as well or is it just audio it's
hard for me to tell uh you you can be
seen uh uh at times but right now we're
just getting audio got it got it I
understood thank you Mr chairman very
much uh for hearing my testimony my name
is yield Bissonnet I'm the legal
director for the ACLU of New Hampshire
we're here in opposition to HB 266. I
know I have limited time and I know the
committee's gone on for a while today so
I just want to make uh three points and
the first is uh out the outset just
having heard earlier testimony today
particularly from one advocacy group
supporting the bill I fear that this
bill really may be premised on the in
generalization that undocumented
individuals are criminals and it's not
true and I really would caution against
this type of generalization having
represented many immigrants and their
families in my work I can tell you that
they're like us flaws and all like all
of us a small number of committed crimes
the vast majority have it like all of us
they're doing you know the best they can
do to to live and survive in these
uncertain times they're just as
complicated and unique as we are and
there's just more difference we have
status they don't but they're part of
our communities nonetheless I do want to
make two additional points and the first
is that uh and this has been mentioned a
little bit before is that this bill
would uh Force municipalities to violate
the fourth and 14th amendments and would
subject uh local law enforcement to
liability for those violations uh what
do I mean by that what I mean is that
this bill would create serious
constitutional concerns in practice by
requiring state and local police to
honor immigration detainers and and so
doing hold uh civil immigration
detainees for ice and that's really
problem dramatic because immigration
detainers aren't arrest warrants and
there's some testimony earlier about
this unlike criminal warrants which are
supported by a determination of probable
cause ice detainers are just issued by
Ice enforcement agents themselves
without any type of judicial oversight
and that's really critical and why this
creates a Fourth Amendment violation
because if a person is held pursuant to
that detainer they haven't been held
pursuant to a warrant where a judge has
found probable cause and premise within
that of course is the fact that was
mentioned before that being undocumented
uh by itself is not a crime and so
because it's not a crime any type of
civil detainer doesn't provide a
predicate for local law enforcement to
hold someone so if local police does
hold someone pursuant to a detainer as
they would essentially be required to do
under this bill that municipality is
really going to be subject to
significant uh exposure potential
litigations
the second point I want to make and also
it was one that was made before but I
think it's really important from my
perspective is that I think this bill
would undermine Community Trust in law
enforcement if enacted when local police
departments detain individuals simply
due to their undocumented status I fear
that they're going to create an
environment where you know victims these
individuals uh you know are going to be
afraid to call the police for help and
you know this isn't hypothetical it's
real we had an example of this out of
Exeter where undocumented person
provided translation services
um a department was uh police that
Police Department was interviewing a
potential suspect and following that
interview the department turned their
attention to that undocumented
individual who was providing translation
services and held him uh for ice and
that is exactly the problem with this
type of Bill that if you are
undocumented you are not going to go to
your local police department
um
to ask you to rap yep that was thank you
Mr chairman that was actually the last
point I was going to make I was just
finishing up uh but that that's the fear
of undermining uh Community Trust in law
enforcement and with that I'd be happy
to take questions I'm sorry for running
over Mr chairman that's all right uh
representative Gilman you had a question
yes thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
Bissonnet for taking my question uh for
full disclosure I am a select woman uh
in the town of Exeter and I once when
this incident occurred uh so I'm pretty
familiar with it but my question is
actually
um on what's cited in this bill is eight
USC section
11357 g
and under that
it reads
that in performing the function under
this subsection an officer or employee
of the state or political subdivision
may use federal no wrong one
is subject to the direction and
supervision of the Attorney General
so does that mean the patrol officers in
my town or any town have two bosses but
only one pays them
well I think I'm pulling up that
language now I think under this bill
that's really the concern right is that
essentially local police could be
commandeered uh by ice now whenever I
submits a detainer now that department
has to use its Authority and resources
to uh to ultimately detain that person
um you know that provision that you're
referencing of that Federal code I think
it's called 287g if I'm not mistaken it
has to do with formal agreements that
some municipalities will make with ice
where those local municipalities can
effectively act as ice agents the
concern I have with this bill is that it
almost requires that and how right if
you're a local police uh if this bill's
enacted
thank you
representative Amanda Putin thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr assessment for uh
taking my question
um did I hear you say that you in your
legal work or you work with the
immigrants
would you be able to define or send some
definitions of legal illegal status list
undocumented what is the definition of
all these categories that are mentioned
so freely in this bill yeah I mean there
there is uh
legal definitions and then they're kind
of colloquial terms that we're kind of
using in this discussion today uh and
I'm just trying to be clear when I when
I use the term undocumented or without
status really what I'm just referring to
is an individual who doesn't have lawful
authority to be in the United States
that doesn't mean again that they've
committed a crime that is a
fundamentally different thing being in
the United States without status is
merely a civil violation by itself I'm
happy to provide kind of a glossary of
terms that would be more technical in
nature but I'm trying to frankly avoid
legalese as much as I possibly can at
risk of confusing and muddying things up
yeah Mr chair just a quick follow-up
please go ahead so uh what you're saying
is is it undocumented or illegal is this
a static situation or are these
instances where uh some status could be
fluid and changes for example if I am
um a student and I'm transitioning I
could be undocumented
or a status list for a period of time
does that make a criminal offense it
doesn't and I I see your point now I'm
sorry I understand the question you're
right status can change for example
um you know a Visa overstay right you
know you have a set period of time in
which an individual is allowed to be in
the country lawfully and at a certain
date if that person remains that person
is now here unlawfully and that is a
civil violation not a criminal violation
um so so you're right obviously status
is fluid and can change based on dates
whether a predicate criminal offense has
been committed that type of thing yes
Representatives Davis
Mr chair and thank you Mr
question
um
I'd like to to ask your legal opinion
about the perhaps unintended
consequences of the talk about welcoming
ordinances and confusing those with
Sanctuary cities and alleging that they
hide under the guise of welcoming
ordinances etc etc
do you see any First Amendment issues
arising this bill become law where a
city or a town let's say decides to pass
an ordinance's welcoming
people from Moldova to their
municipality
yeah I don't know if it's a First
Amendment issue but I can tell you that
the government of course can engage in
any type of speech it wants to just like
individual citizens can so I don't think
there's anything appropriate about
proclamations that just as a value
statement right a city or town is saying
that they're welcoming a particular
group of people I know that some cities
and towns have been concerned about
requirements concerning detainers or
complying with detainers for the same
reason that you for Testimony today is
that they worry about liability given
the fact that being undocumented uh is
by itself not a crime so I mean I think
there to some extent
two different concepts Sanctuary versus
welcoming I don't even really know what
the term Sanctuary means to be honest
it's kind of this term that's thrown out
there uh you know what I'm principally
focused on in my advocacy is work around
detainers and just trying to educate the
public that uh detainers are just not
warrants they're not like arrest
warrants they are fundamentally
different and as a result really just
can't form a basis for a detention
by a local official
thank you
thank you and for those on the committee
if you just uh
indulge me for a minute we are
quickly running out of time to get our
business done today which needs to get
done and we are approaching three
o'clock I like the target three o'clock
to finish this here and so if you keep
that in mind with your number of
questions that you have and for those
that still want to testify with the
amount of time you need to keep that in
mind uh
representative Maggiore you had another
question yes thank you Mr chair and
thank you Mr Beason for taking my
question in your ex in your opinion if
this bill becomes law
are we going to have our local law
enforcement officials going to have an
issue with the power granted to them
under RSA 105 which is police Authority
well I think my position is if this
becomes law
they're going they they potentially
could be forced to hold people for ice
without
inadequate finding a probable cause that
a crime has been committed and I can
tell you though you know though I'm
sometimes on the opposite sides of
municipalities here I'm very sympathetic
to the concern they have because
I think they're likely to get sued you
know
um you know as a result
thank you representative lasalles had a
question yes uh Mr Bissonnet thank you
for taking my question very simple
question and I'm I am too am confused
about the legalities of this
a person who is undocumented
who enters the United States illegally
have they broken the law
so uh it really depends on the situation
so if an individual has crossed the
border and say they're then detained at
the border they may have committed a
crime but there are other categories of
undocumented individuals for example
like Visa overstays like I was
referencing oh and I understand it yeah
I understand the legal entry is uh a
legal entry or a legal re-entry is a
federal criminal offense yes okay thank
you very much
uh and next I'd like to uh
go to representative McDonald question
thank you Mr chairman
and thank you um enough for taking my uh
my question thank you
I'm a I'm a police officer at a local
town and I go to a domestic violence and
I find that's going to solve it a
serious part of the injury the person
that I've assaulted I arrest him and as
I'm taking the jail I run a motor
vehicle record check or whatever record
check that you uh want to call it and it
comes up that there's a dictator for him
under these under these circumstances
there are some towns that if I work for
them they're going to tell me you can't
contact ice to let them know that you
have the constant
but eventually I take him to the court
and I bring him before a judge and I
tell the judge that yes there is a
detainer the judge would tell me fine I
just got three hours to whatever time he
gets his bail done with criminal charge
what problems do you see by
I'm aware of a crime or a several crime
being committed and being told not to
contact the authority you know they're
helping the apprehension the other of
this particular individual concerning
the federal law
yeah so there's a couple things embedded
with that so one of the concerns that we
have with detainers is prolonging a
person's detention as a result of a
detainer that is one of the fundamental
concerns I have now I don't think
there's really anything prohibiting now
frankly local law enforcement from
contacting ice but when we talk about
honoring a detainer which is what this
bill talks about it invites a situation
where a local police department is
detaining a person because of the
detainer when there's no other lawful
reason at that point to detain an
individual so you know in a situation
that you're talking about where hey hold
the person for three hours for ice
um you know when the person otherwise
would be eligible for release that in my
view is a problem now if ice were to
show up at the time where that person is
released and that person wasn't detained
for ice pursuant to the detainer then
you don't have a fourth amendment
problem there
thank you
okay next uh
we have Amanda toll on the line
can you hear me yes uh Ms told uh
could I ask you to limit your testimony
to two minutes
I will try my best and it's
Representatives told thank you oh thank
you thank you I I didn't realize I'm
sorry it's it's okay honorable members
of the committee my name is Amanda
Elizabeth toll I represent Cheshire 16
which encompasses the city of Keene at
large I'm here today in opposition to HB
266 by allowing New Hampshire law
enforcement to initiate investigations
of immigration status this bill will
essentially turn New Hampshire Law
Enforcement Officers into Federal
immigration officers this will have
xenophobic and racist implications as it
will open the door to profiling
immigrants and racial and ethnic
minorities I feel confident that the
vast majority of my constituents would
oppose this bill and I know that our
elected Sheriff
opposes it Keen citizens appreciate the
cultural economic humanitarian and
educational contributions of our
immigrant friends and neighbors we do
not want to increase profiling in our
community rather we want immigrants to
feel welcome and safe here this city is
where project home an organization that
seeks to help Asylum Seekers was founded
it is a city where people crowded into
the library on Thanksgiving 2017 to post
family separations and stand in
solidarity with our immigrant
communities it is a city that had
significant turnout to BLM rallies in
the wake of George Floyd's murder I am
proud to represent my constituents today
by taking a stance against
discrimination I urge you to do the same
and oppose HB 266 I will not be taking
questions thank you for hearing my
testimony
thank you representative Soul next we
have
Christine Wellington is she on the line
for us
hello can you hear me yes we hear you
fine I'll ask you to try to get to your
points within two minutes
thank you representative Dolan and uh
thank you members of the committee my
name is Christine Wellington
I uh work with the immigrants rights
Network and I did submit written
testimony on behalf of the network to
you that will go over most of the points
I want to make most people have made
um all the points that I I would uh have
gone on at length I'll be very brief
um I do want to say we can't over
emphasize the fact that the federal
government has decided that Federal
immigration law violations are in in
most of the ways not criminal acts and
even crossing of the Border without
going through immigration has only been
deemed a federal misdemeanor not a
felony
um
there is also it's uh uh attorney V
sinat pointed it out there is a federal
program the 287 G program that does
allow state and local law enforcement
entities to work with immigration and be
sort of deputized to do immigration law
work and that's really the only way that
a local entity could enforce Federal
immigration law and according to the ice
website there were no law enforcement
entities in New Hampshire that have
opted to do that a 2009 police
foundation study about this very issue
felt that having police focused in on
um enforcement of federal civil law was
not a good decision for most departments
and that most police chief students feel
that it would be good for their
departments
um I did want to answer a question that
one one of the representatives asked
earlier about the 48-hour issue with
detention that specifically relates to
the
um civil immigration detainer where um
um enforcement agent is asking the local
law enforcement folks to hold for 48
hours up to 48 hours and I agree with
Zeal that three hours or five minutes
after that person should have been set
free is triggers a violation of the our
state or federal Constitution there is a
Massachusetts case where a court officer
held
um a a defendant after he was would have
been released from Court Lund versus
Commonwealth and the Supreme Judicial
Court of Massachusetts entertained that
and found that that was a violation of
federal law as constitutional law
violation I will also say in working
with police departments to make fair and
impartial policing policies
um that we worked with the New Hampshire
State Police the ACLU did as well and
the state police brought in our State
Attorney General's office to look at our
position that civil immigration
detainers were legally problematic for
law enforcement and I believe that they
agreed because the state police issued
what's been now considered a model
policy it's at police standards training
Council as an exhibit to a model
policing policy and it explicitly does
not permit detention on civil
immigration detainers I think that's all
I wanted to say thank you very much for
the opportunity
thank you uh our next
comments will come from Mr Bruno Soares
and Catholic Charities who wants to
speak
Mr chair yes
can I ask a question or are you limiting
all the questions no you can ask a
question please be brief though
okay
thank you this is to Mr
Chris Wellington
sorry Wellington
when you talk about
would you believe that
detainee and detaining
people for more than
or less than what they should
if there is no crime committed
that is
a crime by
the authorities
uh
thank you representative Amanda pootie I
I wouldn't say and by the way I'm
Christine Wellington you can't see me
I apologize
um
yes if it it's there's so many
um cases that it it's not a crime it's a
civil rights violation it's a
constitutional law violation
um when an office a law enforcement
officer or a state actor violates
somebody's rights it's not a crime to do
that but it's a it's a civil rights
violation and deal the an expert on
civil rights violations could probably
answer those questions
um much better than me thank you
thank you
um next we have
Bruno sores
from Catholic Charities uh
are you in uh are you in queue
yes can you hear me yes we hear you fine
please go ahead all right so good
afternoon uh Mr chair and members of the
the committee uh I'm going to try to be
uh very brief my name is Bruno Souris I
am an advocate and I try to
representative uh from with the
Department of Justice secretary
Charities New Hampshire and I have
worked with immigration law for several
years now uh instead of giving my
testimony I would like uh to answer some
of the the previous questions that that
were asked previously so I'm going to
try to be very brief although I mean not
Eminem and can say 4.28 Awards per
second I'm gonna try to do my best
um so the the first point that I would
like to clarify uh there was a comment
about Alice Island
uh that the uh that the parents and
great uh grandparents great grandparents
came through Ellis Island uh legally uh
so technically if we compare to to that
uh to to current immigration policy that
would also be considered uh you know the
terms that have uh that have been used
illegally uh and the reason being is
because uh those individuals you know
like would come to the United States
without a Visa uh the equivalent uh
immigration uh benefit to today's loss
is called Asylum so pretty much all
those individuals would be considered a
side lease upon coming in another point
that I would like to to make is that
we've been working tightly tirelessly
with uh the chiefs of police across New
Hampshire to implement a fair policy
where actually the chiefs of police and
local law enforcement they do in fact uh
enforce
um either detainers when they encounter
someone that has committed a crime other
than that they encourage the community
to actually report crimes because
undocumented folks they are victims of
crimes as well in the State uh in
regards to the uh 86 million uh there
was uh mentioned I think my colleague
asthma huni has mentioned that you know
undocumented immigrants uh you know have
paid you know 77 million dollars
producing New Hampshire Alone
um so and actually if you count all of
the the immigrants in the state the
amount to 1.1 billion dollars uh that
these folks have paid
um so and I also heard that this bill is
not about immigration and this bill is
definitely about immigration uh because
it does try to control
um uh officers uh State agents uh to
enforce immigration laws
um so representative uh if Davis
um mentioned that this is a 10th
Amendment uh violation which that's what
my testimonial is going to be about
um and she she's 100 correct
um so and the case on point on that is
us the Arizona
2012 where pretty much the Supreme Court
ruled that local law enforcement must
not enforce immigration laws which
that's what this bill is a 10 thing to
do
um and it is also
um a 10th Amendment violation because uh
he he confronts the supremacy clause
because immigration law is a field that
the federal government intends to occupy
does it constitutes a violation
um and I want to answer a question uh to
uh representative Porter the cost of
becoming U.S citizen uh so you can
become a U.S citizen uh after three
years if you're married to a U.S citizen
for over two years uh so you can apply
for his citizenship and other than that
you have to wait five years uh and the
cost of citizenship percent the filing
fee to the government is 725
and the Leo that's not counting the
legal fees if you go to a private
attorney it can vary from one thousand
dollars to five thousand dollars
depending on the attorney
um
yeah and I would like to also ask the
question to
um if possible to they sponsor the bill
and the person that I spoke right after
uh about uh immigrants being criminals
um so she cited a few
um a few individuals but I wonder how
many uh undocumented immigrants are
actually uh charged with crimes all the
time for driving related offenses in the
state and are incarcerated Mr sores I'm
sorry this is not an opportunity to
debate with other uh folks here because
in testimony we're just here to hear
your testimony
okay fair enough
um and that actually concludes my
testimony thank you so much all right
representative van had a question Mr
chair I just want to acknowledge that my
husband has just come back from work and
he is in the other part of that thank
you for that notice representative van
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question Mr Soares uh my
question has to do with something you
mentioned about the economic uh impact
of undocumented workers in New Hampshire
uh
undocumented workers pay income tax yes
correct that is correct
follow-up Mr chairman
it's all up go right ahead yes thank you
uh so they pay income tax but if I
understand correctly they are not
eligible for any uh federal or state
subsidies like uh snap or housing
assistance or anything like that is that
true
that is correct they're not eligible to
any uh state or federal uh funded uh
programs
including the stimulus checks so none of
them documented folks receive the other
stimulus checks
representative Gallagher
all right um yeah I was wondering if
since you were um with Catholic
Charities of New Hampshire
um
so
uh
or well does that imply that you're
Catholic yourself
I think that that's an inappropriate
question or well all right
um let me rephrase what does your
position with how how does your position
as a worker with
Catholic Charities of New Hampshire
um informed how does your faith inform
um your
uh the points you've raised on this
issue so far
thank you Fuller for your question so
pretty much uh you know like it's based
on uh values and
um you know like more crack character
and based on uh you know those values uh
this bill is uh clearly
um you know something that I you know
that I approve
okay the the last speaker that we have
today is uh I have my hand up can I ask
a question
so I didn't see your hand up but yes go
right ahead
I don't know what happened I had it up
and it's not it's down anyway uh thank
you for letting me ask for that and it's
it's no means it's been easy for me I am
trying to stay calm trying to stay
focused
please in doubt
uh mrsaurus
is you said you're an immigrant
immigration lawyer
for a legal immigrant or for somebody to
legally immigrate from uh outside today
uh
how long
is to get a green card what is the time
frame that is uh I can tell you when I
came I landed with the green card I
walked out of the airport when I landed
in 85 with the green card in my hand and
today I hear
that it's more than 50 years is that
true
um so it depends uh representative
manjapuri uh there are various uh
categories so we have uh immediate
relative which you know like a pretty
much uh you know the spouse uh minor
children which under immigration is
someone under the age of 21 uh that is
not married uh and parents of U.S
citizens that they can uh you know like
apply and you know the Visa becomes not
available immediately they're not in a
preference category uh but then there
are you know like everybody else they
are put in a list which is called a
preference uh category which they'll
wait list can go from four years uh to
30 years over 30 years uh wait uh you
know for revisa uh and most people uh
they fall under a bracket of you know
like um you know the average of uh 15 20
years so most of the clients that that I
deal with uh they are you know they have
to wait 15 20 years
[Music]
a follow-up Mr chair yes one follow-up
please
um
if I am a professional I come as a
student
and I don't have any relatives I'm not
married to Citizen I'm I don't have
children who are citizens what would my
time frame be
so pretty much at the end uh because in
that case it would be considered you
know immigrant Visa so upon the end of
your uh immigrant Visa you have
um you know like 10 days
thank you
and after those 10 days you start
growing on lots of presence
you have another question from the
president
yes thank you Mr Soros for taking my
question now it's just gone right out of
my head oh my gosh
oh
um I think what uh representative
Gauthier might be or Gallagher might
have been looking for is a brief
information about the mission of the
Catholic Charities of New Hampshire
could you give us a thumbnail of what
your organization does
I mean exactly
um you know like uh mission statement I
don't have in front of me but uh pretty
much uh hold on please uh hold on point
of order thank you Mr chairman no is
your main question let's move it
perspectively uh that that question is
the point of order is it's a
non-germaine question
um
representative Gallagher did you have
some clarity you want to add Mr chair
point of order
uh point of water go ahead
aware of the fact that this was a trial
it's not a trial
there to a non-germaine question
objection
I was just trying to keep the uh uh the
questioning Jermaine to uh the uh the
topic at at hand and uh and uh Eric uh
rather representative Gallagher is
perfectly capable of asking his own
questions
excuse me Mr chair I'm sure do you have
a point do you have a point of order I
do I have a point of order
I was not asking for representative
Gallagher I simply referred to him
because it made me think of this we know
what the aclu's mission is we know what
the American friend service committee
mission is I don't know what Catholic
Charities of New Hampshire's mission is
I was simply asking that question all
right uh let's do this
um
Mr Soros can you uh can you briefly uh
uh give us
a summary of what your mission statement
is
yep uh absolutely absolutely
um so we'd like me to to read or to to
tell you what we do all right
just just tell us what you do I think
that will satisfy that question
okay so pretty much we uh we assist uh
you know like uh vulnerable people I
might protect them support them uh and
family life values marriage uh you know
that they are preserved and strengthened
um in order to appear and uh respect uh
our neighbor with compassion uh we also
try to to provide person-centered
services uh through strengthen our
communities uh despite their their faith
beliefs or their immigration status okay
thank you
representative Phil Evan was there any
other follow-up you'd like to have
no thank you Mr chair that really did
what I needed I appreciate it all right
thank you uh didn't mean to cut you off
earlier all right the uh the last
speaker we have is uh Miss Maureen
Maloney that's she I think she's on the
line uh could we uh bring a
representative power
hi
yeah you're on you're on uh
you run with us and you have the floor
thank you thank you to the committee for
giving me the opportunity to speak today
my name is Maureen Maloney I am vice
president of advocates for victims of
illegal alien crime an organization
comprised of parents and family of loved
ones who have been killed or negatively
impacted by illegal alien crime and I'm
the mother of Matthew Denise who was
killed by a new legal alien I am here
today to State my support for HB 266.
my son is dead because of lacks
immigration laws and the fact that
legislators and judges have put illegal
aliens ahead of Americans
Matthew was 23 years old when he was
tragically killed by a criminal illegal
alien Matthew's life and future were
taken from him at a blink of an eye
my family as we knew it was destroyed
and we are now permanently separated all
I have left of my son are memories
photos and his grave
Advocates of sanctuary policies often
use the term immigrant for illegal alien
they will state that Sanctuary policies
protect hard-working immigrants who just
want to improve their lives that
immigrants avoid calling 9-1-1 going to
the hospital and seeking police in court
protection out of fear that they will be
reported to ice the reality is just the
opposite Sanctuary policies protect
illegal aliens who have committed
additional crimes once coming here
there is not one recorded incident of an
illegal alien reporting a crime being
deported there is no reason for them to
fear making that call particularly since
most of them are victims and would be
eligible for a u Visa that would allow
them to remain in the United States
Sanctuary policies protect criminal
aliens
each year thousands of people are killed
by illegal aliens even more are raped
forced into sex trafficking maimed
assaulted and have their identity stolen
yet these are the exact people
that the sanctuary policies Protect by
preventing local law enforcement from
cooperating with ice if properly
screened as our immigration system is
required to do these criminal illegal
aliens would never be allowed to enter
the U.S and no one would object to that
why wouldn't we hold those who have
illegally entered the United States to
the same standard as those who legally
apply to come to the U.S
it is vital for Public Safety that laws
being forced and that includes
immigration laws permitting the creation
of loopholes like Sanctuary policies
leads to local law enforcement agencies
aiding and abetting criminal illegal
aliens illegal aliens know this and
that's why they flank they flock to
sanctuary's jurisdictions
not one citizen immigrant or another
illegal alien should be a victim of
another crime committed by an illegal
alien and the odds are very strong that
they will
do you actually want to prevent law
enforcement from cooperating with ice to
enforce immigration laws and have these
criminal illegal aliens
who have no civil rights to be here and
certainly no civil right to be protected
by law enforcement agencies be the
direct beneficiaries of reprehensible
Sanctuary legislation do you want to put
the safety and protection of New
Hampshire's citizens immigrants and
victimized illegal aliens at risk to
protect criminal illegal aliens
illegal immigration is not a victimless
crime nothing can be done to bring my
son back but I'm here today testifying
to protect your loved ones therefore I
urge you to vote Yes for the
anti-sanctuary bill
thank you other questions
from Miss Maloney
seeing none
thank you very much I had
targeted three o'clock to finish this
we're at 3 20 so I I have failed in my
mission to get this done by three but
it's okay we hit we've heard some
valuable testimony and some very
compelling testimonies uh so with that
I am the hearing on uh yeah who's that
who's speaking
um representative Manji Puri yes and
having some people texting me that have
had the right hand raised uh to speak uh
in attendees can somebody who is in
charge take a look
yes uh I have uh yes there are a few
reps in a few
um audiences attendees yes uh I
understand I I have uh
they have been here since morning so I'm
just asking we had we had uh
15 people signed up to testify and we
have I have given opportunities to all
15 to testify uh if there are additional
uh people beyond that then well there
was one person Darren Nelson that uh in
Joe Shapiro that uh
I didn't give up after you testify
because they weren't here uh
Representatives Mr chair I'm sorry you
of the representatives that are have
their hands up and also too that have
been listening to the testimony since 11
A.M or till since 12 30.
yes um
I'm sorry we're we're out of time uh
this is uh uh this could go on all night
I would imagine there uh it's a very uh
emotional topic for a lot of people
we've had
uh folks from our committee who have
tested who have asked questions as many
as
questions
for an individual
and so I think we've had ample
opportunity it's this is not a it's not
an unlimited time period we have to uh
do the best we can and try to hear from
as many as we can and I think I think
we've succeeded in that uh we'll never
satisfy everybody but there are some
people that probably haven't had a
chance to testify I guess my word of
advice would be in the future to to uh
to sign in
indicate hold on please the sign in
indicate to the committee that they want
to testify uh on the bill and how long
they want to testify for which is part
of the process and then we can queue
them up and we can allocate time for
them but if they if they don't do that
then it's it's very difficult to try to
just have an open-ended unlimited time
period no no Mr chair this is with all
due respect people who have calling are
also signed and requested to testify and
have been told to wait and I am just
asking for a process and I understand
it's been a long uh this is my fifth
term I have sat through in criminal
justice uh and Public Safety Committee
where we heard testimonies for two days
in a row for eight hours each I
understand and I understand this is an
important bill and it may not seem but
it's important and we need to have the
voices heard and I truly object for
rushing through uh bill that is that
makes an important point and changes the
lives of many of my constituents
including my family so I would like to
make sure that everybody has had or
Affair I'm not asking for an unjust uh
time it is a protocol I'm just asking
for a courtesy did you have to I'm sorry
do you have the name of anybody that uh
signed up to testify that wasn't given
that opportunity
um Mr chair representative Perez says
that she signed up to testify she has
been waiting a long time
I don't know why she's not on the list
but she has signed up
um yeah so I see these attendees that
have their hands raised and they are not
on the printed out list of the um house
remote testimonies
so these people that are being referred
to at this point in time are in fact not
on the list that we have but we're given
a a list
uh in fact it should be shared with all
of you a list prior right before the the
hearings begin as to who has signed up
uh whether they oppose or support the
bill uh where they're from and how much
time they're requesting from the chair
to speak and and actually when they
signed up date time stamp when they
signed up so I had that list in front of
me and it totals a a 15 people who sign
up to testify beyond that if they can't
if they did not sign up to testify and
we weren't we're not alerted then I
wouldn't have had that information I
don't know if you've got a list that's
longer than mine but mine came from the
uh yes Mr chair and that list cannot be
updated after eight o'clock in the
morning is what I've been told so
anybody who signed in to testify today
for a bill that's coming up at 11
o'clock if they didn't get that test
that signature in before eight it's not
going to show up on our list and these
people
have perhaps they missed the deadline
but that doesn't mean they didn't do
what they were supposed to do
thank you
uh representative you had a comment yes
I I object very strongly to limiting
debate in any way paper form and
and especially limiting testimony from
people who are here ready to testify
some of whom are members of the public
and some of whom are Representatives I
think we should take the time to hear
them that's what we're here for
thank you for that input any other
comments on that
representative Wallace thank you Mr
chairman as elected representatives we
are expected to be aware of the rules
and proceedings and the procedure
requirements are quite clear if you have
not signed up to speak on the bill crime
for eight o'clock
Mr chair I would uh in the old days hold
on hold on uh one of the things that the
folks can do who have who wish to offer
commentary but didn't get an opportunity
they can always and I always encouraged
to submit their uh their testimony in
writing in which we would include in the
file in a copy to all all
representatives in the committee
well I do because in the good old days
before we had to do this remotely
someone could walk into our room and
fill out a pink card and pass it on down
to the chair regardless of the point in
the hearing where we were
um and I and
that was their right and we always
honored it and now we're saying I'm
sorry but if you don't do it by eight
o'clock on the day of the thing you
can't speak and I I'm just concerned
about that that's all
yeah thank you Mr chair uh I would just
like to point out that this has been
inconsistently applied that other bills
have uh we have allowed people that
weren't signed up by eight o'clock and I
I just want to point that out
thank you representative uh stavis
thank you Mr chair I would just like to
be on record as strong as opposed to
limiting any testimony on a bill that
touches on the Civil Rights and the
Constitutional obligations of our police
and of our citizens I think it is
unconscionable to limit debate or
testimony on such an important bill in
the interest of moving a process along
representative magic booty
so if I have the written testimony that
was emailed but can I read that as a
representative do I have uh right to
read a testimony that were blocked
because of the
constraints put arbitrary constraint I
feel like can I read that
uh representative Powell how many people
are still here that want to testify
see six individuals with their hands
raised since
well I'm going to ask the committee do
you do you want to extend your time
because I think we're going to go uh
well past dinner tonight if you uh you
want to keep this going uh
um representative van you have you run
away in
uh I was just going to say yes I am
willing to say
Mr chairman yes I happen to be a
selectman in my town and I do have a
meeting tonight it's very important
non-public meeting if we stay much
longer I will not be able to make the
meeting
representative clay
oh yes I I am an alderman here in Nashua
and I also have a very important meeting
but um this will take precedence and I'm
willing to stay
representative Davis
we have a meeting
stop meeting
representative treeleven
yes Mr chair thank you I think that uh
what representative stavis said earlier
regarding the Constitution and the
law enforcement community and the
citizens of the United States of America
and the state of New Hampshire requires
that we stay and listen I'll be here
representative
thank you Mr chair I'm the chair of the
select board here in my town and
um I I will be torn but I will I will
serve at the I will do whatever it takes
to get through this meeting although the
the matter is pressing before us on the
select board side will require my
attention
okay it's kind of a mixed review I'll
tell you what I'm going to do I'm going
to uh
reopen the hearing and I'm going to tell
those people who want to speak that they
have very limited time to try to uh try
to support both
emotions on the uh committee now of
wanting to hear additional testimony but
also understanding that people will
start peeling off uh and not be able to
participate in our executive sessions
this afternoon our work needs to be done
by tomorrow morning and uh or else the
bills that that are pending uh I'm not
I'm not going to finish by the end of
the calendar well we'll have a bigger
problem on our hands
for all those bills we have nine nine
bills to affect uh still before the end
of uh end of today and we have some
additional
committee reports that are still pending
that need to be written by the end of
today
so Mr chair yeah this chair would it be
possible the executive bills and then
return to the uh hearing
um no we have to in order to exec this
bill we have to complete the hearing um
well I I think I think
I think what I'm going to do is uh
continue to continue to take testimony
but I'm going to encourage those that
are in queue to move quickly through it
and uh they're just going to have to
live with live with those time
constraints and I'm going to ask the
committee to be very uh careful uh
given the schedule and the in the clock
that we're working with not to prolong
the meeting unnecessarily if if uh if
someone else is already given the type
of information you have some of you are
I keep track of questions some of you
today
on this bill alone are up over 12
questions uh and some of you haven't
asked any so I'd ask you to be fair to
your fellow committee members in terms
of not only asking questions but also
given the calendar I mean many of us
will be attending
Municipal elections tomorrow from early
morning to late night so that's the that
also plays into uh the schedule that
we're going to have to be dealing with
okay uh representative to eleven one
last comment I just wanted to say thank
you Mr chair and I will listen and
remember not to ask any questions
okay thank you all right so uh I'm gonna
reopen the hearing on HB 266.
uh
uh it can sense I'm I'm sensing a
consensus among the committee instead we
extend the hearing time
and uh
representative Powell could you tell us
who's in queue next
uh why don't we uh go back and forth so
why don't we start with a representative
first we have representative Perez
representative Perez
representative Perez are you with us yes
can you hear me I am I'm going to ask
you to try to be brief as you can yes I
will thank you for the opportunity to
speak up first of all I wanted I want to
educate a little bit like the public
that the terminology illegal illegal
aliens that's not the correct way to
talk about uh people who is in document
uh we have to talk to the people is the
human beings they hear they pay taxes
they are part of our communities and
that terminology is like the human fight
like we're not talking about humans
we're talking about
animals and that's not a way which we
should be treating our community members
and um the other thing that I want to
say is I was born in El Salvador I
immigrated to the United States to
protect my family for terrorists
um I started doing my volunteer work
with the New Hampshire family service I
help women from the a woman's prison who
didn't speak Spanish like they didn't
know how to read or write in English or
Spanish and I teach them how to do that
as an immigrant that was my first
community service
um hear people saying that immigrants
here they're like uh criminals we're not
criminals we hear we heal to help our
communities we pay taxes
we we we do a lot of them I've been
working with them you know with within
family service without breadcrumbs I've
been working with the hospitals local
hospitals when at the beginning of the
pandemic I started doing face masks for
hospitals and all a lot of different
communities uh identities that they need
face masks so I will ask you please
please vote no to this bill we don't
need any any more discrimination within
our communities since 2016 people have
enough impression they treat us like
we're not humans even myself I was
discriminated last year I was told that
I didn't belong in this community
because I was an immigrant that's
something that that didn't happen before
2016 we have to recognize that because a
lot of filtrations are not there anymore
people feel like they can treat us like
we're not human beings we are human
beings and we need to be treating
immigrants with respect thank you so
much for the opportunity to speak up
thank you thank you representative
uh next next uh Mr Lynn Lynn
yes and it's representative Lynn thank
you just I just I wanna I wanna I wanna
thank the uh the members of the
community that uh the members of the
committee that that uh that advocated
for continuing the hearing I because I
have to say uh Mr chair I I believe that
I signed up to testify in this hearing
uh last Friday or maybe last maybe last
Saturday but I um I think I signed up
pretty early
um to testify so I don't I don't know
what what happened I'm not blaming
anybody but I just think there may be
may have been some uh some uh mistake
and anyway I'm going to keep my remarks
very very uh very quickly because I know
you've got a lot of other work to do
what I wanted to say is this I don't I
am a strong supporter of this bill I
don't and I don't think despite what
you've heard from other people I don't
think that there it can be any serious
question about the the constant
institutionality of this bill
um and and I would direct any if anyone
has any wants to do any further uh
Research into that I would suggest that
you read a case of relatively recent
case from the fifth Circuit Court of
Appeals
it's called Uh city of El cenizo versus
Texas eight nine it's reported at 890
Federal uh reporter Third Edition
164 it's a fifth circuit case from 2018.
it was written by judge Edith Jones
she's one of the most respected federal
judges in the country I was mentioned as
a possible Supreme Court nominee on more
more than one occasion
and basically it dealt with a Texas
State Statute that was very similar to
the statute that the legislation that's
proposed here and there were a lot of
municipalities that opposed it and the
fifth circuit uh for many of the reasons
that are sort of advocated here by the
opponents of this bill and the fifth
circuit rejected all of those challenges
um uh with the exception of one minor
thing that's really not not at issue and
because the language of our bill is
different
um but basically
um I think one of the things that about
which there's been some confusion
is yes it is true
that uh um
entering the country illegal being in
the country illegally is not a crime
it's a civil violation but the
immigration and naturalization service
has the authority to issue a detainer
which is an administrative arrest
warrant it's it's it's issued
administratively it's not issued by a
judge but it's an administrative arrest
warrant which empowers the ins to take a
person into custody and what that fifth
circuit case explains very very you know
uh carefully is that that
um although that's a although that is a
a civil as opposed to a criminal
violation the warrant is issued based
upon probable cause the probable cause
being probable cause to believe the
person in question is in the country
illegally and that that is sufficient
probable cause the fact that it's not a
crime doesn't matter and in fact if you
think about it
um under New Hampshire law the police
are not only entitled to take a person
into custody for crimes although that is
obviously most of the most of the the
occasions when they do so but they can
take people into custody for example if
someone is if someone is inebriated or
if someone appears to be con you know
appears to be
um engaging it appears to be mentally
unstable or is likely to hurt themselves
or hurt someone else even though they
haven't committed a crime the police can
take that person into custody and detain
them in effect and so what this fifth
circuit case says is that
um the same thing applies here the
immigration and natural uh the
immigration detainer is something that
the police can enforce it doesn't
violate any constitutional provision and
the last thing I'll say is as far as
this 10th Amendment issue which I
believe represents my jury had had
raised there's no 10th Amendment issue
in question here because the Tenth
Amendment would come into play only if
it was the Federal Government
trying to enact a statute requiring the
states
to do something this is a state statute
there's no there's no 10th Amendment
issue whatsoever because this is a state
statute saying we the state have a DOT
will adopt as our policy that we will uh
cooperate with uh the federal government
that doesn't raise a 10th Amendment
issue at all
um so for for those reasons I think
there isn't any serious constitutional
issue here this statute is
constitutional I think it's important uh
um that that we not uh that we allow
State authorities to cooperate with the
with the ins in enforcing the federal
immigration laws because there is a real
problem with immigration I don't think
anybody can deny that there simply is
and we shouldn't be turning our no uh
thumbing our nose at it so with that I'm
happy to take any questions but thank
you for giving me the time
any questions for a representative Lynn
Mr chair in love I'm sorry in lieu of
time respect I will not ask any
questions
um
next we have to speak it's uh
representative Abramson
all right are you able to hear me yeah
you sound fine go right ahead all right
I'm just going to talk really fast and
not take questions because I was on this
committee last year and I uh organized
the floor debate in favor of House Bill
um
uh which every Republican on the floor
voted for except for one and I think we
also picked up about a dozen Democrats
um I I can't remember exactly
um this does create RSA 103-a which
would not be part of RSA 103.
um politicians should not be allowed to
micromanage um
emergency responders many peace officers
contacted us last session in support of
this bill because of their growing
concerns for Public Safety most of them
were in New Hampshire but we did get uh
one Sheriff from Massachusetts who was
talking about uh the effects of
sanctuary City policies in Southern New
England
we already enforced federal laws like
welfare fraud kidnapping terrorism Etc
uh the cost of the taxpayer was
estimated last session at 1200 per year
in additional federal state and local
taxes that's mostly state and local
um illegal immigrants do have anchor
babies here which is the way that
they're able to
um qualify for various welfare benefits
some of the countries involved have 10
to 5 10 to 15 times higher homicide
rates in other countries El Salvador has
a 16 times higher homicide rate which is
why we need why criminal background
checks are so important uh Tucson
reported 3 000 kidnappings in one year
became the kidnapping capital of North
America many of those Americans have
never been seen or heard from again
many Latin American gangs get
established
down there by murdering dozens of people
and leave their bodies on the ground in
town centers to or to terrorize the
locals and get their reputation Mr chair
I object there are
I'm sorry point of order
I find these comments
this is not excellent please please uh
representative Porter
I find that these comments
unsubstantiated with fact
are disparaging and and not
insulting to the people
representative and I just asked you to
uh to consider the comments and uh
continue
all right we'll do uh I'm just trying to
go through the statistics as quickly as
I can what we're trying to do
hold on hold on hold on representative
Raymond so what is your point of order
earlier when a young woman was
testifying she was near dead and she was
told to not talk bad and not be
disparaging and this is okay I am seeing
such double standard Mr chair it is very
difficult for me to serve
it is making me so emotional and very
stressful to see this double standard
I understand representative to 11. well
thank you Mr chair I I believe that um
representative Abramson should limit his
comments to what happens here in the
state of New Hampshire not what happens
in El Salvador or anywhere else in the
world thank you
representative go ahead and continue
um I I will take questions by email but
I'm not I just want to for interest of
time I just want to go through these
statistics what we're trying to do is
prevent dangerous criminals from coming
into the country and I'm saying that we
have to have secure borders in order to
make sure that everyone coming into the
country has been through proper criminal
background check
um there are 450 000 homicides around
the world including 150 000 in Latin
America alone it would has been
estimated that between 630 and 650
million people would come to America if
they could according to Gallup and
various immigration policy studies
bringing their families with them so the
total number theoretically eventually
could be a three to five times increase
in population if we don't enforce
immigration laws uh multinational
corporations of course would send
Millions more career criminals use our
poorest poor Canadian border and the
only enforcement for that for the most
part is by our own police five towns and
cities including Manchester uh and
Cheshire county were turned into
Sanctuary cities without voters being
consulted and people were very angry to
find out that this has been had been
done to their towns and cities
Massachusetts Rhode Island Connecticut
have been made Sanctuary cities by their
legislatures the California legislature
actually prevents police from responding
to emails from Ice Mr chair
uh representative Center if you could
just stop for a minute what's your point
or whatever representative Davis
Mr chair
what represent
s talking about
absolutely nothing to do with this bill
and I object to his line of testimony
okay I I think uh I hear what you're
saying uh point of order would be uh
when we're not following our process
We are following our process
representative Manchester you have a
comment a question for representative
I have a would you know question uh just
to to clarify something made in the
beginning it would be uh representative
Abramson for whom I have a great deal of
respect and as a neighbor would you
believe that the vote on the floor was
211 to 132 in favor of the Ito with
eight members of the Republican party uh
it wasn't one and uh I just had that in
front of me and I thought it would be
useful for the committee thank you
thank you
okay uh representative can you rap
yeah I'll just go as quickly as I can
um those with false documents who are
not working are not quote undocumented
workers they are here illegally
uh would we prevent Park Rangers from
removing someone who's illegally
trespassing on a state or national park
why have elections process to create
laws of act activists and criminals are
going to just ignore them we did have a
Citizens petition here on the Seacoast
uh and 60 to 70 percent of Voters in
each Town voted against Sanctuary cities
um the Communist Party put up I'm not
going to read the quote but they said
um that it was aiding and abetting
Immigration and Customs Enforcement uh
aiding and abetting refers to helping
criminals ice employees are hard-working
public servants not criminals and should
not be treated as such violent criminal
gangs Russian Ukrainian Mafia and Latin
American drug cartels are criminals
representative I'm going to have to ask
you to uh to wrap in the next few
seconds that's that was my final comment
very good are there any questions for
representative he didn't take questions
Mr chair Mr chairman who is this
Chevrolet I can't figure out how to
raise my hand I apologize my wife is
home and she's in the family room I just
want to let you know thank you for that
notice that the next speaker will be uh
let's see
representative Oregon
okay okay so I'm representative Timothy
Horgan the towns of Durham and Madbury
and Durham is a home of unh so we do
have a number of uh we do have a number
of uh International students so they're
immigrants too um this uh
first of all uh first of all I myself
the child of immigrants although they
came over at various times between the
uh
16th and 19th century none of them asked
for permission I don't think anything
even went through Ellis Island we just
showed up
um and that's that's how it's been for
most of American History so the whole
idea of standing in line is uh
something's not really the concept that
we'd fire into like
my just about all of my ancestors um
it's very broadly written seems to me
even I
recovered by because I I have uh in one
of uh State reps and other officials
just been keeping an eye on the
immigration Detention Center to
Stratford County jail so it seems like
even I could have my funding taken away
so I don't know how that worked for you
don't pay me my hundred bucks it's
written very it's written very very
broadly uh
two concerns I'll just mention uh one is
uh sometimes immigration Homeland
Security deal with people who are
Crossing Borders to our citizens I know
there's a domestic terrorism case that's
going on right now on federal court it's
a person maybe related to the U.S
Capitol terrorist attack and um he he
was caught by immigration coming back
from Brazil from Boston and he was he
was a U.S citizen of New Hampshire
resident in fact not even as far as I
know what Brazilian ancestry I think he
was just of a white answer I say like me
so this does uh limit another this just
limit a large uh large number so the ice
and the uh and the other Homeland
Security do do a lot of immigration
works it's not just uh you know
undocumented aliens and also I know
I'm not supposed to say speculating
people's motives but I noticed a number
of what we call pro-gun activists
there's a lot of people from the worst
thing possible would be
having their guns taken away I'm just
summarizing what they've said and
response to other bills and there's
nothing there's no special protection in
here for uh guns that may be seized
because even um
there's even immigrants or foreign
citizens are allowed to own guns there's
nothing there to protect a Firearms of
ABC's in there that's uh not really my
issue I'm more of a gun safety guy but I
just thought I'd mentioned it in case uh
if the Republicans if any Republicans um
have doubts about this and looking for
some reasons and they could cite to a
vote against this bill which is I think
a very bad Bill would have Myriad of
undocumented uh well undocumented but
unintended consequences one of the
phrases we like to use here and it's uh
just funneling running fundamentally
unfair and also takes away funding from
local agencies so that's uh
representative Horrigan I didn't get uh
your early comments whether you're in
support or against opposition because
I'm against it and also as I said this
is a bad bill so I guess sometimes we
vote for bad bills but I'm against it
and I don't know
also just a side comment I made the
issue of the executive session you're
hoping to hold after this uh came up um
I'm not sure exactly what deadlines
self-imposed or imposed by the
legislature came in but you all you have
here is the boilerplate about executive
session on pending legislation maybe
held throughout the day so I think
probably some members of community infer
that if this ran over you would not be
executing any bills so like the idea
that
if some of them have expression
willingness to skip other meetings to
accept bills but that was probably uh
that's something they'll probably still
enjoy not anticipating having to make
when they're like the Challenger so uh
thank you thank you for your testimony
uh
thank you we have uh comments uh coming
from Marshall jesperson
um good unmute Marshall and uh and
please go ahead and speak to the bill
thank you very much uh representative
Dolan my name is Marshall jesperson uh
I'm a business owner in New Hampshire
from Conway
um and uh I opposed this bill for two
reasons first uh and most selfish is we
in New Hampshire are the second oldest
population in the United States and we
need young people to balance our state
and be members of our Workforce here
immigrants tend to be on the younger
side and uh and throughout our history
have tended to be and we have seen this
some of the brightest most energetic and
most uh productive of our citizens in
fact the contributions made by our our
first generation immigrants some of whom
are are four bearers are just two
numerous to list now I'm a business
owner we employ about 200 people many of
those are first general generation
immigrants and I can tell you from my
own experience some of them are the best
brightest hardest working people we have
in our company
anything to make New Hampshire less
welcoming to immigrants is definitely
bad for business and bad for the issue
we have of his of an aging state
in my estimation this bill falls into
the category of cutting off one's nose
to spite one's face there are many more
pressing issues I think for the
legislature to tackle it's hard enough
getting quality workers in our state
without making our immigrant environment
hostile and pushing potentially good
workers and solid citizens to other
competing states
as a case in point within the last month
one of our employees proudly became a
new U.S citizen
we need as a state to be more welcoming
not less
now secondly and equally important
immigration policy
I believe is properly the purview of the
federal government
the passage of laws at the state level
is encroaching on that prerogative while
giving them a pass on enacting universal
sensible
enforceable Federal legislation to deal
with the issues that immigration
I urge our legislature to enjoin our
Representatives at the federal level to
enact comprehensive legislation to deal
with the subject of immigration at an
appropriate level
so I hope you'll take a look at this
bill and find as I believe it is that
it's not in the best interest of New
Hampshire or the nation and please vote
no for its Passage
and I'm done in under two minutes
are there any questions for uh
Mr jesperson I have my hand up yes
representative mangafuti
um thank you Mr chair thank you Mr
jessen for taking my question uh you
mentioned about the workforce
can you kind of give us uh approximate
dollar amount in terms of human
potential that will not be harnessed if
we become very punitive and unwelcoming
to the immigrants
thank you for your question I'll do the
best I can but to give it a dollar
figure I think would be impossible but I
can tell you I've got I've got people
from uh El Salvador
Albania
Russia uh Mexico
[Music]
uh just a host of other countries and
these are people who won at a great deal
of diversity to our Workforce a great
deal of energy and
um
you know I think we are probably
one third of first and second generation
immigrants
at an average
uh annual salary we average out at about
forty thousand forty seven thousand
dollars a person so you can do the
calculations on that
thank you for your testimony we have
about I believe one more individual
that's been in queue Tristan McLean
please
absolutely thanks for the click so my
name is Tristan McLean I'm currently
reciting in Plymouth New Hampshire and
I'm a member of the public I speak in
the strong opposition of this bill
strictly on ethical balance
um despite whatever legal founding could
be fine to be able to retain this bill
if it happens to pass I think that is
evidenced by earlier testimonies filled
with racially charged language and
Prejudice that this bill is definitely
founded in a discriminatory fashion I
really urge the committee and strongly
can tell you
as well
[Music]
I mean
You're just showing your constituents
your behavior honestly it's been
kangaroo crew for the last couple
hearings bye
um
and I just really can't understand how
you can support these biased testimonies
around a woman to go on for over an hour
then say two minutes and then finally
recant your statements and finally go
back to ethical Behavior
I just think it's a real sham I will not
take any questions
okay uh thank you for your testimony
uh
I think that's the balance of those
people who uh request testified
Mr chair I do not see anybody else okay
does anybody on the committee have any
knowledge of someone who wants to
testify that didn't have an opportunity
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing
for 266. let's take a 10 minute break
uh for those people that need an
adjustment get a snack or go to the
restroom and then we're going to
reconvene at 410 and begin our executive
session uh let me also say that uh I
just got a note from our Administrative
Assistant that we still need
um
which reports committee reports on 243
284 332 560 and 616. uh 243 was uh from
representative Porter 284 representative
van 332 representative Maggiore by 60
representative trip
and 616 representative Porter now that's
not to say they weren't submitted
but she doesn't have them so they might
be somewhere in route to her or uh or
somewhere else but we're going to have
to resolve that before we go home today
as well so
um I may need those of you who wrote
These for our writing them I may need to
get a second copy if I hadn't got one
already so uh take a break we'll see you
at uh in 10 minutes
all right
foreign
Dolan
it's Ivy van
chairman Dolan
Christina can you hear me
window uh yes it appears that the room
is not unmuted but you are
so someone will just need to unmute the
computer
representative Dolan chairman Dolan
nope not
not here you uh chairman
Mr chair we can't hear you
nope
now
no we don't want to do that
but we could hear it
not yet
can't hear you representative piamonte
how about now can you you hear me now
you can that's yes
representative van do you have something
you wanted to say
yes thank you chairman Dolan uh I just
can't hear you
I don't know why I'm I'm
can you hear me now yeah I'm not muted
on my end
we can hear you
who can hear me I can hear you I can
hear you we can we can hear you virtual
people can hear you representative
Porter can you hear me
I can hear you Mr chair can you hear me
but I can't hear you
okay
I'll wait
to audio in the room
see the rooms
gotcha Ivy the room isn't connected
right okay
why don't you go on history
can you reboot it's a computer audio
how do you do it
who's gave you that message Christina
can you reboot it's the
forget a message from Christina it's the
computer audio
can you reboot
she said she's asking if you can reboot
it's a computer audio
that's a solution to everything right
yeah well it feels plug it in I can hear
the chairman and Mrs Vince
if we reboot the computer do we lose the
connection to the meeting
yes no not the connection to the meeting
you starting to hear me now
well we can hear you representative
Dolan but um I worry that when as we're
going into executive session the other
folks in the room will not be heard
because it's through your audio that
we're hearing you
the room is saying connecting to audio
so we're definitely don't have audio so
if we turn it back on and turn it um
turn it off and turn it back on I should
be able to promote the room again the
same way we did this morning
Christina can you hear us you can hear
it yes I can hear you
question
we heard that
good sound check
you're muted
I think of my mother every time I sneeze
because my sneezes would sound just like
hers did
have you read cookie Roberts we are a
mother's daughters
foreign
are you talking
you're muted
I'm talking myself in the mirror okay
and not to my wife who may or may not
have entered into the foyer of our house
and is close by
Mel say hi to everybody you talk like I
do with your hands
hi everybody
oh it's always with the hands the hands
always have to be going
my husband heard me screaming and he
locked himself in the room upstairs
shouldn't he have come to your rescue
instead of running away
and it was a like this little baby like
a two one and a half two-year-old
Italian baby talking to her Italian Nana
and the hands are gone and it's perfect
it's perfect right
all of us who have loved talk with our
hands it's just an expression and with
food
total it's called the total
communication body language emotion and
everything together tie my hand behind
my back I can't speak
I can't hear you I need new glasses that
kind of thing
that's actually a thing we all lip read
and if when you can't see people it's
harder to understand what they're saying
foreign
I keep thinking I'm recognizing people
in parking lots and I actually went to
the store yesterday and because of the
mass I'm like nope that's not who I
think it is nope oh I won't say hi to
that person oh whatever so
I'm just peering at them wildly
I didn't realize how much I smiled at
people when I'm in the grocery store
even people I don't know
until I realized the other day that they
can't see it anymore but I was doing it
okay here comes somebody who wants to be
recognized
oh what's her name what's his name and
then his name is Ernie
Bernie
Bernie yeah
God I have an Ernie story for you later
not right now where's Bert
one of my constituents is joining me for
his afternoon meal wave to the people
that's my husband yeah one of your
constituents I love that
we used to always refer to my son's
girlfriend and my now my daughter's
boyfriend as their associate because you
know it's not really any of our business
this is our son Charlie and his
associate Sarah associated
and sometimes it's complicated as Hugh
says yeah so what did they break the lob
what happened
we're trying I can see representative
power is trying and she's probably got
um Christina with her
Liz Eric
yeah where is Eric I'm worried about
Eric we need his vote when we get to him
I just turned off the camera because I
went to the bathroom and then forgot to
turn it back on again
representative air
yeah
he's on the zoom
well his representative power we see
we're trying to fix it oh there she yeah
I think my constituent here has to go
okay
come here
hey
if we're doing that here's here's here's
another one oh
I love how when you pick up a puppy I
need that puppy he's pretty great I have
to say I never thought I'd be a handbag
dog person but you know they're
concentrated they're all dog just small
yes I had two of them I lost them in
2019 and attached to my hip on either
side right
my daughter used to my kids used to call
you have you becoming are you becoming a
dog lady or a dog lady because I would
talk to them I would carry them
elasa I have a question for you yes
ma'am I have a consistent who is
um a homeschooler she's also a Unitarian
Universalist you can tell your husband
um she and her two teenage children are
studying India
I mentioned that I knew you and they're
wondering if they might be able to
interview you next month absolutely and
if they need material from any about
culture art I have lots of books and
stuff I can give it to them oh great so
shall I give them your legislative
address no give my personal
you can give them my phone number
whatever you want I'll do whichever you
want they she gave me her email okay so
do it my Comcast email okay what is that
it's my first name and DM yeah just a
reminder that you are being recorded
folks
we'll get it
so they they got all that laughter on
tape
dogs cats
more dogs
that's not a bad thing
shows where humans
thank goodness Marjorie
I just sent the committee report over
for 332 to and Heather said she'll wait
for the approval and I said I wrote it
so long ago I might have just sent you
the recipe for my secret uh my secret
recipe for eggplant parmesan
so now she's holding me to sending her a
now these they're all talking on the
screen
we're start we're here
can you hear us can you hear US
Representative piamonte
you can't hear it no he can't hear us
yes I just sent Marjorie
and uh
uh chairman Dolan the committee report
on 284 which was 19-0 and it merely says
that we eliminated the sunset Clause
because we didn't see any reason why
these Lots shouldn't be unmerged in
perpetuity
foreign
I just emailed representative pimonte to
let him know that we can hear him
I just saw that email
did so you could hear us
I can't but we're not recording I don't
think we are yeah it says we're
recording all right so I'm uh it's John
do you have that's only on my computer
this is working you can't see him right
it's only on my computer
I'm talking to them now they can hear us
representation can you hear me
yeah I can hear you but I can't hear it
on Tom's computer no
[Music]
problem
yeah go ahead I'm sorry go ahead one up
Mount Washington
yes I've run it 38 years in a row I got
the third longest streak in the history
of the mountain
I'm a runner obviously okay thank you
that's pretty impressive yeah
hey he's coming up now
do you run for Time Records
representative McBride or do you run
just to finish no I run the time I'm I'm
66 and I'm probably in the top three
good for you top three at least the top
ten in the state in New England anyway
and how long does it take to run up
um
back in the day when I was an elite
Runner I was about an hour and 22
minutes last year was an hour and 52
minutes wow
up the auto Road straight up
good for you yeah it's uh yeah I'm a
fitness nut good for you
you then run back down
well one year we had to because it was
uh it was icy and they wouldn't let the
cars back up but normally no I get a
ride down oh okay the elite run is run
down though but that's too crazy it
would be pretty tough to run down that
mountain it's been more difficult coming
down yeah it is
so you worked at Raytheon
no
I was I was in business with myself I
was in business
all right so
much
oh I forgot I was in Saudi Arabia too
and I was never there I was in Vietnam
Vietnam yeah been there
all right he's running nieces
not not Ryan the technician but Scott I
mean Everett said he's running
so this will apparently this one's
working
air
or it was working
not anymore we can hear you oh you can
you can hear us can you hear me too no
yes we can hear you
yeah because he can hear you through my
computer
maybe can you go over to where
representative Powers chair is
yeah how about now is it oh
[Music]
because that's what I did I turned on
the
speaker
again
no wait
can you hear representative power
hello
I think we're only hearing you
representative power through the ambient
Ambience is that a word
can hear you fine Mr chair
that's a kind of uh sleep aid I think
representative
ambiently
it's getting late can you hear him now
we got an I.T guy coming
okay here
can you hear him now can you hear me now
it's not like a Verizon commercial
s yeah
Okay so
we don't want that but I think that we
want to make sure the public in here
foreign
I was able to promote the computer I
think
um if someone wants to try and unmute
and turn on the video
all right
can you hear us
yes
okay well we can't hear them
no
we could hear you say can you hear us
right well I'm online with you but I was
hoping that the chair would be able to
hear us
um but we can't hear you chairman
I have an idea go ahead Christina can
you hear me now
we can hear you yes uh
my concern is are we broadcasting out to
the public yes we are okay so can we can
we continue the uh the briefing rather
the uh the meeting and this
at this stage without having the screen
at the end of the room on we don't
really need that
so long as the other Representatives can
be seen and heard
that's that's they can't do that and we
can see all of them
the other people in the room everybody I
can see you all of you right
I think we can
okay can you hear all of us
some of us yeah
um
I can
here he is it's a big guy now
we are frozen over there or something
okay
let's learn how to fix it yeah
we have it
uh
so we lost the room now again
I imagine he's rebooting at the moment
okay
I wasn't sure if it was me because every
now and then I lose everybody and I have
to come back in I was thinking I might
have lost my headset yeah I was thinking
the same thing that's what happened
that's what happens to me every now and
then I lose the headset and then I lose
everything there's nothing that'll bring
it back and uh
well now you're stressing me out I'm
stressing myself out I'm gonna plug my
headset in
I know I have the airpods I keep putting
one in each ear switching them off and
that's when I tend to lose people so
I'm grateful we have this opportunity to
do it
remotely
your majori yes
still
multi-colored markers
and they mean something no blue means
I'm in favor of what's on there so I
have to highlight that pink means I have
no idea what's going on I'm I'm kind of
in the middle green is usually a go oh
yellow is I got questions an orange I
don't know I just have
caution date
Christina can the uh the public here so
they just can't hear the room is that
what it is
uh they can hear
um but they can't hear what's going on
in the room because because
um I was on YouTube and I was seeing
them on YouTube
so it's just we just can't hear them I'm
not sure I turned it off because it's
very distracting to hear both at the
same time
so you can hear us in the room outside
I can double check I'm not sure
Christina are you saying I'm distracting
because I'm not offended by that
all right guys hold up for a second I
just want to make a public announcement
this is uh representative here Marty
we're having uh technical difficulties
right now with our Zoom uh hopefully
we're gonna get it done within the next
few minutes uh just be patient and uh
we'll be right back with you okay thank
you
thank you
also scheduling anytime
um let me find out hey just asking that
question
um you need to schedule a day to finish
if you want to resist now that's an
option
so how do we
together
foreign
is Ivy there my two boys
[Music]
um
thank you
[Music]
foreign
are we recording yep you're on okay
thank you
okay
thumbs up can you guys hear me
doing okay
we're back
so we're going to begin our executive
session
we have nine bills to exec so
I'm gonna try to do it as as quickly as
we can
first I'm going to start with uh HB 484.
um
I think we're looking for a a motion
from representative McBride Kevin and I
would move that on to pass
is there a second from representative
Tripp
yes there is
a motion's been made in second is there
any discussion
on 484.
you can ask the clerk to take the role
I'm sorry Mr chair I had my hand up oh
I'm sorry I didn't see it quite all
right I'll go very very quickly uh thank
you
um
I I really don't have a huge problem
with this bill except for the word only
and and that word gives me grief enough
that I unfortunately can't support the
ought to pass
um I I think that the budget committee
should have the opportunity it should be
somehow in there that you know you you
you you should be doing this only on
Appropriations but you know where
appropriate
um have that flexibility and without
that flexibility it gives me cause for
concern so I might I'd even like if
there was an amendment or if we could
retain it but unfortunately I apologize
I can't support the OTP
I agree with representative Maggiore I
feel that the budget committee needs to
have the opportunity to weigh in on a
bill that might not exactly have money
in it that day
but we'll have some sort of fiscal
repercussions uh in the future so I'm
sorry I can't support the OTP
okay
um that being our last gonna ask you
know the clerk to call the roll
yes
representative trip yes
representative uh Wallace yes thank you
representative lasalles yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative here yes
yes
Representative no
representative
he said no
representative Gilman no
representative majority
Representatives Davis no
Representative no
represented a fan
representative plea
no
representative Gallagher
chairman Dolan yes
cash is 10 to 9.
okay next bill to consider is
oh yes um
can I ask uh representative McBride to
write the uh
the majority report
and you know who would want to volunteer
for The Minority Report
I'll do it Mr chair if there's no
objection from the minority leader
love it
okay now uh by the way these reports
have to be to me ASAP and I have to
submit them by tomorrow morning into uh
into the clerk so uh
please send them to me so that I can
approve them when she or she won't
accept them without my approvals I'll do
my best
all right next uh Bill to exec is
House Bill 411 which is a study
committee on the equalization rates Mr
chair yes I move
ought to pass on Bill 411 yes
and representative power seconds is
there any discussion on the equalization
ratio
seeing none I asked the clerk to call a
roll on OTP
just a minute sir please
okay House Bill 411
ought to pass
representative yes
representative Wallace yes
yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative Porter yes
representative yes
representative Gilman yes
all right yes
thank you uh representative Davis yeah
representative yes
representative fan
representative clay
yes
representative Gallagher
and Shannon yes
19-0
all right without objection I'll put
this on the uh on the consent calendar
and I'll ask representative lasalles to
write them the command report
challenge
so I have I've found a meeting tomorrow
morning
yeah but we all do okay yeah all right
do what you can
uh I'll be I'll have my laptop in the
school gymnasium okay
uh the next bill we're going to consider
is House Bill 374
which is how we adopt uh sb2
official balance uh uh town meeting
yes we did uh representative PMI do you
have a motion on 374 I like to make the
motion on House Bill 374 octopass
and representative sellers I'll second
that motion
okay uh is there any discussion
representative Porter
um I this the current
um statute has only been in effect a
very brief period of time we haven't had
a chance to see how well it works
um I have not heard complaints from
anybody about it prior to
um today and I think it's a little soon
to be reverting back to a system that
was flawed and was changed because there
was a flaw so I I can't support ought to
pass on this
thank you
I've seen no further comment uh it's
supposed to take the role
second was uh representative lasalles
okay representative yes yes
representative yes
representative Wallace yes
representative lasalles yes
from Leonard McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative yes
representative power yes
representative Porter no
I saw her saying no but I didn't hear it
we got it
no no she's a no
representative Gilman
no
or davidory no
Representatives Davis
Representatives Davis oh
uh Representative no
representative van
no
representative clay
Gallagher no
She haven't gone yes
or keep passes 10 to 9. I asked
representative piamonte to write the
majority report they haven't volunteered
for The Minority Report I'll write The
Minority Report Mr chair
the next bill we're going to take up is
house bill 266.
uh is there a motion from representative
Wallace uh Mr chairman I move lots of
fast
is there a second from representative
here
yes
representative air are you with with us
okay Mr chair yes I hate to be
doing this but I don't believe a
substitute can make a emotion and write
the majority committee report when they
are serving as a substitute on a
committee at least that's the rule that
I was told last year when I wrote a
committee report as a substitute on a
committee and they wouldn't allow me to
do it the clerk kicked it back I don't
know that to be true but I'll take your
word for it so uh can we have somebody
else make the motion to
OTP
animal votp on 266. it's a
representative trip and representative
Wallace is a second okay
it's Janet is there is there any further
discussion uh yes representative uh Mr
Wallace can't be the second I think it
would be Mr air yeah really my comment
you're right
my comment was I'm not used to having
the chair of the committee say a
specific person's name in regards to is
there emotion is there a second so and
so and so and so marjorie's waving her
head so I I don't know if I'm right or
wrong my thought is the process is is
there emotion and then whoever is going
to make the motion types up and says
here's the Motion versus you calling out
a name of someone already chosen
it's been done both ways representative
211 depending on the committee that you
serve on so okay I know that we did it
sometimes last year but uh your Point's
taken so clear point of order can I ask
is there a way that I could make a
motion or that's not going to be
recognized
uh we're in voting mode now so uh I
understand but you know I've been trying
to wait or say but you know it doesn't
look like I
I can be there you know I can make a
motion is that process
yes
[Music]
can I ask
Ed was representative manager putty
trying to be recognized before the
motion was made or she's trying to be
recognized now I'm not sure I didn't see
any hands up
I was trying to find out if I can make a
motion at all because we have done three
votes and I you know even before I could
raise my hand you were asked already to
somebody to make a motion and somebody
to love unless my name is called I
cannot make a motion is that correct no
you can make a motion anytime
thank you for clarifying I will be quick
right so we have a motion from uh
representative Tripp and a second by
representative air on 266 is there any
additional commentary before we uh go
into voting mode
I would strongly oppose it I would have
liked to make the itl motion but I was
not recognized or I didn't have the
opportunity so I am just going to
well if the uh okay to proceed is uh
voted down and there'll be an
opportunity to make an alternative
motion
I know the reality Mr chair
okay uh say no further conversation when
I take the role yes Mr chair I ought to
pass an HB 266.
representative Piemonte yes
collect folks yes
representative yes
representative walls yes
representative lasalles yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative here yes
yes
representative Porter no
representative
sorry it's been a long day no worries Mr
clerk no
uh representative Gilman no
representative majority yeah
Representatives Davis
thumbs down
absolutely no
representative fans
no
representative clay
and representative Gallagher no
um yes
and ask representative piamonte to write
the majority report and who would
volunteer to write some minority reports
for that
I'm up for that
thank you
we're supposed to cast them in a
professional
yeah I I that's not a bad idea I just
ask everybody to uh try to
with all due respect I have been very
restrained and the kind of Jabs that
have been thrown is not easy to take I
would like all of you to be in my skin
for a second and understand what's
happening thank you Mr chair
all right
okay
the next uh next bill we're going to
take up
is
bill 341.
this is uh
representative man's bill that she uh
she sponsored
hi Mozart
chairman yes I have an amendment
so if we've got a lot to pass with
Amendment just to see how our prior to
you mentioned I just received a motion
to itl from representative Richard this
is what I was talking about it was we
were trying to get your attention but
you make them up you don't look at it
and this is not right Mr chair I protest
this we were trying to make get your
attention
I guess you were trying to make a point
of order uh it is it is
uh within the process of the committee
for the chair to recognize uh someone
that made that makes a motion and it's
up to the chair to recognize who the
chair decides to recognize
Mr chair uh yes
a point of order I know maybe this
doesn't matter to you or to the other
members of the committee but it
certainly matters to me I know that
representative van has spent
months working on this piece of
legislation and she has an amendment to
fix issues that were brought forward
I think it would be fair to allow her to
make a motion to at least
deal with the amendment and then take a
vote of ought to pass as amended and if
it fails then you can do your itl but as
courtesy to someone who has spent months
writing this bill it I just think it
would be a courtesy that would be
appreciated by the members of the
minority
yeah representative yeah
last year I mean I tried to do the same
thing and uh representative I mean the
chair Crossing
took uh the way he wanted to make these
decisions to uh correct the or do the
vote
um and I lost out I mean you know I felt
badly last year
that's the way that cheer decides to do
things you have to put up with that you
know
point of order Mr chair yes what's your
point of water
I unders I understand about last year
but here we are now in this year with a
very different environment going on I'm
a little square box rectangular box in
front of you right now and however many
of you are in the lob you're all people
who can see one another and chat with
one another and be off the camera we
only have this little
hand you know the one that we can raise
or we could shout out which I understand
is inappropriate to get the chair's
attention so I think there needs to be
some awareness and latitude in this and
I think that especially the chair since
he's the person with the power to
supervise all of us that he made sure
we're all included
thank you
uh
uh in in
deference to the ranking member who who
I have worked with now for two sessions
and uh
out of sensitivity to what
representative van has been doing I I
will allow her
to present her Amendment and make a
motion
thank you very much Mr chairman I truly
appreciate that and thank all of you who
spoke up so uh there was confusion about
the whole question of being attached to
Water and Sewer you have to be attached
to Water and Sewer so I have an
amendment uh chairman Dolan you should
have received it from
Olsen wait a minute wait a minute wait
wait wait wait wait wait we have we have
a process and uh oh okay so do you want
me to make uh after pass with an
amendment I want to review the processor
also I'm going to get another point of
order from the other side of the aisle
and that's it you need to say something
like Mr chair I'd like to move OTP
on House Bill x3 yeah for Amendment y
EP okay
Mr chair
p with um Amendment hang on and I will
tell you
um
oh crud uh we have an amendment I sent
it to you
it is
uh
oh God
I am trying to locate
I'm trying to locate the number of the
amendment that OLS sent me I'm sorry I
did not write it down
let me the the amendment is
I got it I'd like to move ought to pass
with Amendment zero six nine two h
okay so first we're going to take out
the amendment uh is there a motion to
adopt the Amendments as presented
is there a second
okay the motion has been made and
seconded uh as the clerk to call a roll
on the amendment
you want to know what the amendment says
we just need to know who said that this
person I'm sorry the the motion was made
by representative van and seconded by
representative status
and the motion is zero six nine two h
and I'll thank you thank you in advance
for the work you've spent on the
amendment
yes
do you want to know what the amendment
says
I mean you have it but I'm not sure the
rest of the committee does
I think I think everybody has uh
received a copy of it through
distribution okay perfect that's fine
you don't have a copy no I do not no I
think the amendment had to do with water
and sewer uh issues is that correct
uh it has to do with water and sewer
issues we struck the words or which can
be connected to Water and Sewer by any
means so that came out it says uh in a
residential zoning District served by
water and sewer
um and then there's an additional
sentence in line 10 which reads all
relevant building and fire codes shall
apply
and in line nine it shall be lot
coverage shall be no more restrictive
there was an extra R in that sentence
which uh representative Tripp pointed
out
okay well let's uh
since we now know what the amendment
says let's uh let's go ahead and take a
vote on the amendment okay
zero six nine
2H
representative yes
yes
representative Tripp yes
representative Wallace no
[Music]
representative yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin no
representative here yes
representative power yes
representative Porter yes
representative yes
representative Gilman yes
that are majority yes
Representatives Davis yes
representative yes
representative van
yes
representative please
representative Gallagher
yes
and Shannon Dolan yes
17 to 2.
okay now the amendment passes
so uh now I'll need a motion to OTC as
amended
uh Mr chair
the on House Bill 341. second
who gave the second representative
Gilman gave a second so van and dealman
okay and uh is there any discussion
before we call a roll
so the motion is to OTP as amended
ask the clerk please call the roller
uh representative Piemonte no
Workforce Now representative chip now
representative Wallace no
representative assames so
Kevin McBride
no
representative Melvin no
Representative no
representative power no
representative Porter yes
representative
yes
representative gentleman yes
representative majority
yes
yes representative yes
representative yes
representative van yes
representative Klee
yes
representative Gallagher
and Shannon no
10 to 9.
motion fails motion feel so now I've
been looking for an uh emotion uh
to move forward with uh
with this bill I move uh House Bill 341
itl is there a second second
Piemonte
is there any discussion before we call a
roll
saying none uh please call the roll on
341. oh Ito
representative Piemonte yes
coach folks yes
representative trip yes
representative Wallace yes
representative lasalles yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative yes
yes
representative Porter no
it's representative
no
representative Gilman no
representative majority no
representative Davis no
Representative no
representative fan
no
representatively
ah
I'm sorry I I was trying to find the
meat but unmute button um I vote no on
uh motion Thai tea out
okay thank you and Shannon yes
uh ten tonight okay I'd ask a
representative trip to write the uh
majority report and who would volunteer
to write The Minority Report
representative van thank you yes
all right next uh we're going to tackle
House Bill 573
which is a change in use uh without uh
variances and for large retail
businesses
uh
I make a motion to itl
Rebecca
so who who was the second
I have uhuri and stavis
for itl
is there any discussion
seeing none uh
I'm sorry is it oh yes representative
Porter
thank you Mr chair
um I think that the this bill is well
intentioned but it really is the purview
of the local uh zoning board and
planning board to make these changes not
the state and I believe we heard
testimony that said if if this is a
slippery slope kind of bill
um once we start changing on the state
level we're going to end up dealing with
a lot of appeals and issues at the
legislature that really need and belong
to the uh to the local governments so I
will be supporting the itl on on this
bill
I'll ask the clerk that takes the role
on
house bill 573.
503 ATL
representative Piemonte yes
representative Tripp yes
[Music]
representative Wallace yes
representative yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes representative
yes
representative power yes
exceptionally reporter yes
yes
representative killman yes
representative majority yes
representative Davis yeah
yeah a couple that are making foodie yes
representative again
yes
representative Klee
representative Gallagher
yes
Mr chairman yes do you have a point of
order uh well a question who is the
second on that motion that was
representative stavis
and uh my wife's girlfriend has arrived
and they're in the great room sewing and
stitching and doing all those things
that they do so without objection I'll
put this on the consent calendar I'll
ask representative man japoodi to write
the committee report
okay I will try thank you uh next we're
going to take up
House Bill 574 which was a similar or a
companion bill to 573 about changing
categories of use without uh obtaining a
half the obtaining a variance
Mr chair I would like to make a motion
again IPL
I'll second that
motion's been made by representative
manager Puti and seconded by
representative Tripp is there any
further discussion
seeing none Alaska clerk to call a roll
on 574.
okay
yes
representative yes
representative Wallace yes
representative Brian yes
representative Melvin yes
representative yes
representative power yes
representative Porter yes
representative yes
representative gentleman yes
representative majority
yes
Davis
[Music]
yes
representative fan
representative please
yes
19 to zero
I without objection I'll put that in the
consent calendar and
representative just volunteered to write
the committee report for 5783 would you
like some help with 574 uh yes uh Mr
chair and I will send it
do I have to do it in the next half hour
or can I do it
yeah I just I need it by tomorrow
morning okay then I can do it no okay
then you're gonna do both 573 and 74.
okay thank you
uh next we're going to take up uh House
Bill
588. Jay I'd like to make a motion with
the itl 588
uh is there a second
I'll second that
uh piamonte and Air
um
is there any discussion before we uh do
the Roll Call
yes Mr chair yes
um
well I guess just not fast enough I I
would have liked to have gone in there
and had a discussion about the amendment
and the merits of the bill which we've
heard a lot about for a a tool in the
toolbox to help the affordable housing
in New Hampshire but unfortunately I
wasn't quick enough and uh you know
doesn't hurt me I have a house I guess
this hurts the people of New Hampshire
and I'll be voting against the itl maybe
you need to get some coaching from
representative Manchester booty she's
developed a quick draw off the off the
market she's getting pretty quick
that was that was a bad attempt do I
take that as a compliment or a uh
that is a problem
representative you have a question
I have a comment I don't have a question
yes
Paul that we would yell this bill
so many people spoke in favor of it and
it allows City student towns to know
exactly what they're doing and to again
meet the needs of the citizens in the
state of New Hampshire uh I don't know
what the problem is with it I don't know
why we would itl it and if someone wants
to explain that to me I might listen for
30 seconds
but I I won't I won't vote to itl just
sorry
I understand is there any is there any
other discussion or comment yeah yes
representative Gilman
um I I agree with um uh first
representative majority who introduced
the bill but also it's enabling
legislation so a town doesn't have to uh
take this on it's not mandated by the
state so if you don't want tiny houses
in your in your town then don't adopt it
had a comment
yes I do I guess my question is what's
our plan for housing in New Hampshire
because I don't see that we're making
any project any process progress at all
on any of these housing bills
I I just don't understand what we're
going to do I mean I'm beginning to
believe that the answer is we're going
to build a giant parking lot and let
people Park their cars there and live in
their cars
I understand how you feel I was a little
very disappointed in how things turned
out with the affordable housing bill as
well but uh
that's what happens uh representative
yes my uh sentiment I
Echo the sentiment every effort that we
have tried to improve housing situation
it's a crisis and for most vulnerable
and not so vulnerable we are in the
middle of pandemic and this just tells
me that we are not listening to our
constituency I got a lot of calls for
this
representative air
yeah I get a lot of calls from it too
and what my town wants to do is be left
alone the zoning board the planning
board want to make the decisions on what
we're going to do for housing where
we're going to put it what size it's
going to be they don't feel that the
state belongs in our local government
that's all I can tell you and uh
representative Maggiore did you have a
comment
good yeah
um I guess I'll be prophesizing but I'll
do it a little bit quickly I serve on
the governor's Council for inclusion and
diversity and one of the days we were a
bit frustrated and so uh a few of us had
a conversation and somebody said Jim it
doesn't matter if you fail
and I didn't know what that meant
um and it suddenly it after a long
conversation I'm a middle class guy with
a house and three kids and and plenty of
money and all that good stuff if I fail
doesn't matter one bit I go on with my
day my refrigerator is full my heat is
on
but when I fail here in in when we're
trying to pass legislation when I fail
at the select board I'm failing all of
those people who are looking to us for
leadership I don't know how to go back
to them with with the points that we
have heard from representative Manju
Puti and and and and Van and everybody
else to say we're doing our darndest but
I just don't have the the the reason why
I have failed you and and that's that's
frustrating to me so thank you for
indulging me
thank you for your comments so
representative Phil Evan you have
additional comment thank you Mr chair I
do
um in this air I understand exactly
where you're coming from and your town
can say no we don't want any tiny houses
yet this is the tool that other towns
who might want tiny houses can use to
have a framework of what a tiny house is
what kind of codes and regulations it
needs to meet and that town can adopt it
but if your town doesn't want it they
don't have to have it this is not a
mandate this is an enabling Bill and it
gives people a framework where they
don't have to reinvent the wheel they
can look at this and say oh we can have
a tiny house Park let's do it
representative reporter can I answer
that oh I
representative 800 I'd rather not have a
dialogue back and forth between
committee members but you can make
additional comment if you'd like
uh representative Porter
thank you Mr chair
for the past eight years I have been
attending
seminars put on by the state at St
anselms and other places discussing the
housing crisis that we have in New
Hampshire
it is a crisis the business and industry
Association has recognized it as a
crisis the governor has recognized it as
a crisis
people who want young people to come and
stay here within New Hampshire recognize
it as a crisis the homeless Advocates
recognize it as a crisis and over and
over again we hear how dire the
circumstances are
and we are people in our state in our
towns and cities are crying out for ways
to help bring in affordable housing or
housing of any kind so that people have
an affordable place to live and every
time this year that we've brought forth
a viable bill that is not that is not
mandating it's enabling it offers an
option for towns and cities to do what
they need to do for their folks that the
governor is crying for that the business
and industry and Association is crying
for we get to this point in the
committee and the bill is killed and I
don't understand how we can be partisan
about an issue like this I'm not
understanding why it's a democratic
issue or and not a republican issue and
that's how these votes are coming down I
really need someone to explain it to me
because it is a state issue and our job
is to take care of the people of the
state regardless of their party and and
this just doesn't make sense to me and I
really would like someone to explain
I'm sorry to get upset but this is so
important this is so important people
need places to live I I our occupancy
rate we don't don't have any openings we
have not even one percent
vacancy rate in our state that's
ridiculous
thank you representative Cleve
thank you Mr chair
um
[Music]
I I have to agree with everything that
my colleagues have said about the the
necessary housing I live here in Nashua
and our um our availability is no it it
it's a crime and we keep talking over
and over again all the things we want to
do to get young people to come into the
state we talk about all the things that
we want to do
um to keep those who are older you know
staying within the state and not having
to go into another type of home we have
systematically killed every Bill and
like you um Mr chair
um
my heart was broken when we lost the
affordable housing bill it it truly it
killed me because it I thought for sure
that there were enough people on both
sides of the aisle that would want
something like this
um I I feel like right now I'm almost
wasting my breath because the the
everybody has made their mind and I mean
no disrespect for anybody no matter how
they vote but it's a very very
frustrating thing when I hear people
from both sides of the aisle say we need
to increase our housing I I am an
alderman here in Nashua and we are
working desperately hard to to get
affordable housing to get housing mixed
within all communities
um small large Adu style type of things
and so on
um I have seen this literally
systematically in this committee alone
just kill every one of those with the
exception of the affordable housing we
did that one on the floor so
um I've said my piece and thank you for
letting me have this time
thank you
okay thank you uh representative air
now I just have a cona I keep hearing
over and over and over again that well
if your town wants it they can have it
your town wants it they can have it why
don't you guys have it you can have it
just go to your commanderboard tell them
you want it put it in okay
point of order
please uh indicate that you want to read
if you want to raise your hand and make
a comment uh
I see your hand up on the screen thank
you
thank you for those of us who have
served in
more we understand that that is not the
case that the state must Grant
permission to the towns to do what they
want to do and that's the purpose of
enabling legislation in a Dylan's rule
state so it's not the case that a town
can just go out and do what it wants to
do the town requires permission from us
the legislators to allow it to adopt
these measures it's not forcing them to
do that it's simply allowing them to do
it or leaving them alone as as your
constituents would like to have happen
either way it can go either way but if
you vote to kill this bill they can only
go one way and that's the no way
foreign
I'd like to
like to allow local jurisdictions to
decide what to do about toxic waste we
don't let local jurisdictions decide
what to do about safety issues we need
to treat housing the same way there is
no incentive on Earth for any single
jurisdiction to ask for even a modest
Improvement in density because the
nimbies will kill you every time
we have to do these kinds of things at a
larger level because otherwise they
won't get done and we've seen this over
and over and over again in New Hampshire
and across the United States
it's not really a local issue anymore
thank you additional comments
okay
um
we have a motion and a second uh that's
the clerk to call the roll
okay motion is to uh itl
hb588
yes
representative yes representative
Wallace yes
representative yes
representative McBride yes
representative Melvin yes representative
yes
representative power yes
representative Porter no
representry 11. no
representative Gilman
no
representative majority
Representatives Davis no
Representative no
representative Vance no
representative please no
representative Gallagher no
chairman Dolan yes
10 to 9.
Mr chair can I reconsider
do you like to make a motion to
reconsider
uh I guess that that motion is in order
to be on the Prevail unnecessary to be
on the prevailing side you're right
that's all that does apply however when
you're on the house floor but in the
community I'm I'm very aware of that
okay so uh do you like to make a motion
to reconsider it I would like to make a
motion to reconsider and I would urge my
colleagues to rethink and make a
last-ditch effort to help the most
vulnerable so please vote Yes so we can
make a reasonable
motion
okay so the motion on the floor of the
committee here is to reconsider
the itl on 588 Mr chair
S Davis thank thank you Mr chair thank
you very much
I know it's late I know we're tired but
I would like to say that this is not
just the legislation that is going to
help the neediest among us this is
legislation that will have those who as
uh representative van has turned the
vanishing middle you know we
New Hampshire is going to become a state
of rich people and Indigent people
how can we possibly want that Democrat
Republican independent I don't care how
can you possibly want that for your
state it seems like it seems like
suicide to me
in motion is to reconsider
uh did we have a second on that
second
the motion was made by representative
majikudi second and seconded by
Representatives Davis thank you
thank you
okay representative Gilman if you have a
comment to make on the on the motion yes
go ahead
yes thank you Mr chair
um I would just like to say I would wish
the
um our committee to reconsider this bill
because uh similar to other statements
uh one that has been we've missed in
this conversation is the idea of Aging
in place and again being a state that is
getting older and older
um uh older folks are not going to be
able to keep their big houses and they
will not have a way you know they want
to be in their own house and there will
be nowhere for them to go
plus our our nursing homes are have
waiting lists that are years long
thank you
on the motion to reconsider
okay what should we consider HP 588
I mean no
[Music]
uh representative Tripp no
representative Wallace No
representative lasalles bill
representative McBride no
representative Melvin no
representative
no
representative power no
representative Porter
you're on me yes my vote is yes thank
you man uh
[Music]
chapter 11 thumbs up or thumbs down
I said yes
got it
representative Gilman yes
representative majority yes
Representatives Davis yes
representative
yes representative fan
yes representatively
yes
representative Gallagher yes
and Shannon no
so the motion to reconsider fails
and so the the
boat to itl is a
still in in effect and I'd ask
representative fiamonte to write the
majority report and do I have a a
volunteer for The Minority Report
you do I will write it to majority
thank you representative
if you remember that's the one that uh
about uh
uh members of boards uh ex officio and
voting status and so forth
I move Ito on House Bill 392. is there a
second
oh second devotion oh representative
LaSalle seconds
uh is there any discussion
seeing that I'll call the roll
392.
as far as we'll sell us
trip in lasalles
four percent motion again motion was to
ITF
thank you
okay itl 392 representative pmrt yes
look folks yes representative Tripp yes
representative Guthrie uh Wallace I'm
sorry yes
representative Salas yes
representative Pride yes
representative Melvin yes
representative yes
representative power yes representative
Porter yes
oh
no why you can hear me no respect you
representative
yes
representative majority
no
Representatives Davis yes
representative
no
representative van
representative plea no yes
representative Gallagher yes
chairman Dolan yes
50 to four passes okay the bonus 15 to 4
ask representative Tripp if you'd write
the majority report and do I have a
volunteer for The Minority Report do we
need a Minority Report uh Mr chair it's
only four yes because this won't go on
consent there's too many uh no votes
so we do need a Minority Report
representative reporter could you uh
identify a member of your caucus for The
Minority Report
one of the people that voted no be
willing to write this representative we
have representative
and representative
how about representative true 11 you
have nothing so far could you do it
[Music]
yeah
is the minority writer and please
remember to get these
11 is trying to talk we can't hear her
she's not it doesn't look like she's
mutant I'm not muted um I don't know
what's going on
I have everything representative Porter
and I'm happy to do it thank you very
much representative well I would ask
that you anybody writing these reports
please put them in my email inbox ASAP
uh but no later than uh late tomorrow
morning
to ask a member of her caucus to write
The Minority Report when many of them
had not voted with the Democrats on this
bill and I would just like to point out
that we do not all vote as a Bloc and
the assumption that we do is offensive
my apology I was looking just to spread
the workload a little bit so
um
she's our minority leader so I uh I
turned to her for those types of things
I will I will be more cautious going
forward just my comment I just want to
make sure you're a chair of the
committee we are all part of this
committee members correct so you are
here to Chiller and I would look to the
chair to say you know who's making the
of who's making that uh motion who's
seconding it and not a sign ahead it's
very it's been appalling or it's very
frustrating watching it and that's why I
had to jump like that and that's
it I'm I'm just like I'm just fifth term
and this is my first time on this
committee and I'm just shaking my head
is there a 40 year to comment
yes Mr chair I'm wondering wondering if
members are being muted um
a couple of my members have reported to
me that they TR we're trying to speak
they hadn't muted themselves
and they were not they were muted and
they hadn't done it themselves and I'm
wondering is muting being done
by people in the room there with you
uh any uh any co-host or uh
yeah our Tech advisors also have the
ability to mute uh and if someone is
speaking out of turn uh then that's when
uh they might be muted when they're not
properly recognized by the chair Mr
chair um and again I brought this
forward to the clerk and I'm waiting his
answer
I'm not sure that someone who's running
the computer has the authority to mute
someone because they think that person
is speaking out of turn I believe that
that is the responsibility of the chair
and unless the clerk has gotten back to
you with an answer to my question he has
not gotten back to me with the answer to
my question so I I'm real I'm I'm just
asking that we not be muted by anybody
unless you
please say please mute representative
treeleven please mute representative
Porter because
I don't think another member of the
committee has the right to decide that
I'm speaking out of turn
that's right uh is there
yeah yeah
nice chair and
I I was not going to bring this up I
wanted to talk about it really but
um people just blur it out
and debate with the people in the
hearing so I I have mentioned that you
after you asked your question
that's it you want to follow up
as you raise your hand whatever we have
a system here that works
and and you raise your hand you'll be
recognized uh but there'll be no more
blurting out answers or anything like
that I was appalled at some of the
things that I had seen so far in this
committee
um and I will tell you this it would
never have happened last year when uh
chair constant was here
he would not tolerate that you had to
raise your hand and it and if he decided
to recognize you then you spoke if he
didn't decide to not recognize you you
didn't speak that's exactly it
representative Piemonte and that is the
chair's prerogative it is not another
member of the committee's prerogative to
say that that is the chair's
responsibility so if the chair does not
want us to speak out then the chair
needs to say that but I don't think it's
right for another member of the
committee to mute me or you or anybody
else because they are making the
Judgment that is up to the chair to make
okay I don't want to get into an
argument here about this uh I I will say
that uh I will ask people to uh please
wait to be recognized if you have a
point of order or if you have or more
importantly if you have a follow-up
question
I really need to direct that indication
to the chair throughout this so far here
we are getting to the middle of March I
have never denied anybody a follow-up if
you've asked for a follow-up you've got
one even in some cases
and today for example we had a long
discussion one of our bills I I have one
uh one individual that I believe asked
like 16 or 17 questions and uh but
that's okay
and as long as it's done appropriately
and respectfully I I will uh will allow
it so
please don't take advantage I'll ask you
not to take advantage of I could
normally good nature but let's just try
to please be respectful and and uh and I
think everything should go fine
representative
thank you Mr chair I think this speaks
to what I was trying to say earlier in
regards to recognition of those of us
who are remote versus recognition of
those folks who are together in the lob
and I got to tell you I'm 100 jealous
I'd love to be there with all y'all the
point is it's difficult to run with this
technology and I have seen more than
once
in the entire time that we've been
meeting somebody's sitting there with
their hand up and you don't see it
you're just one person if I was in the
room you know I could have my hand in
front of you but I don't
so there's got to be a balance a measure
and some help from
all of us
to help recognize one another and I
think that's a big part of where the
frustration comes from yes I I uh I
understand that in fact there's been
some complaints of those who are in the
LLB that I'm not recognizing them when
they have the hand up in fact you you uh
you actually uh it was uh kind of a joke
but one of our members brought a little
bell a little pow balance so that I
would we put his hand up I would hear
him uh and because I wasn't recognizing
everybody that had their hand up so this
I will tell you it's extremely difficult
to manage a zoom meeting that's that's
Blended like this half in half in person
and half on the computer for uh 20
people it's it's very challenging and so
uh please bear with me I'm doing the
best I can and I'm trying to be
even-handed
and uh uh and like I said like I told
one of one of you I'm trying to call
balls and Strikes here without being
partial one way or the other
representative van
yes Mr chairman thank you very much uh I
have to go be chairman of the planning
board
um do we have any further work to do I
will tell them to start without me if we
do otherwise I should probably go yeah
but one quickie
okay what is it uh it's House Bill 132
which I thought we were done with but
I'm told that that we didn't finish it
uh it's uh it's the one about acreage
for single-family housing that
representative uh sponsored and I
thought we gained it our itl to uh you
IPL it because I that was a bill that I
supported and was one of the sponsors of
and you certainly did itla
okay so I have an indication from our
clerk that it was it's still an open
Action so uh if if you're all confident
that we already itl did it then we don't
have to revisit again I was just going
to call another vote on it but uh
if you you'll probably have a better
memory than I do so I'll take I'll take
that as a uh that you're confirming that
we did it
and uh
thank you chairman
I I don't know
the report on that though the majority
majority report Mr chairman I have that
we retained it in 18 to one am I wrong
I had retain or itl and I I didn't
indicate in my notes which one we did
maybe that's
I have retained 18 to one
me too Mr chair
okay
anyone else confirm that representative
power also yes
yeah I had I had I have a spreadsheet
that I keep track of the bills and I
have a note in there that we retained it
but I didn't write down the vote 18 to 1
is what I'm hearing from
more than one person so
[Music]
do we know who
let me say because representative Porter
that voted not to retain is that right
if we have
um a retention and it was I think
representative Gallagher who voted
against retaining it I I voted against
you saying it because I thought we
should ought to pass it okay back to you
representative band it looks like we're
done
yes thank you for recognizing me um I
would like to respond to representative
Porter's um comments that you made
before you before you do that uh we're
going to have some a little addition
additional discussion about uh muting
and and so forth but I can tell you that
our looks like our business is done
and except for those committee reports
that need to be written I would just ask
you to move as quickly as you can I
understand
open the polls at 5am tomorrow and I'm
going to be there probably the midnight
so I'm going to be a very busy uh time
going forward so uh if you can write
those reports and put them in my inbox
as fast as possible I really appreciate
it and uh uh and so those of you have to
go to other meetings
I have to go we're not going to take any
other votes but we are going to have
some discussions about process though
if you want to if you want to fail at
this time feel free to do that
thank you Mr chairman I have 130 1932 is
retained as well
okay thank you
all right the representative
so what I wanted to say was um
be clear
during this executive session this
afternoon
in the interest of the time into
um you know process through I know that
it takes time for people to unmute
themselves
you to a single person so just to be
clear and additionally representative
managoodi
um you know she was expressing that she
was unable to unmute herself I you know
recognize that you know impediment there
in trying to click to unmute oneself in
order to make a motion and
again I did not mute anybody for those
reasons so it's not clear to me
um
representative Porter was referring to
but I would like every Committee Member
to know and to understand that I did not
mute anybody uh I I also have thank you
representative power I just know that
several several people were trying to
talk and they weren't being heard and
they don't know how they were muted and
maybe it was a glitch today with the
technology we seem to have a lot of them
but I just wanted to make that I also as
a co-host I have the ability to mute
people as well and to take their hands
and put they're up to put them down I
can tell you I didn't mute anybody today
but I just hands down uh you sometimes
have that situation where someone asks a
question and their hand is up and it
stays up and I end up going back to that
person and say you have a question and
say no no my hand is up from a previous
question so when when I call on somebody
like if representative Gilman has a
question and her hand is up electronic
hand the little yellow and sticks up I
can click on her face and I can put her
hand down once I recognize her so that
her hand doesn't stay up so that that's
what I do I haven't muted anybody uh yet
this year okay thank you
you did have
uh some disturbance by a person giving
testimony today it was very aggressive
and I did ask to have that person
that's awesome
thank you Mr chair and I do too also
have to leave I apologize to everybody
thank you for listening today
well thank you for for all your help and
guidance you've been you've been a help
to me uh so far this year with your
experience and I appreciate that
uh
thank you uh Mr chair the
um I just wanted to make comment that um
my ability to raise hand
keeps disappearing like it's not there
right now the only thing I have the
ability to do is mute and rename myself
those are the only things that I I can
do at this moment earlier I had the
ability to raise hand and then it was
gone again so again I think it's a
glitch with the system I don't know why
um but I think it at times these are
some of the things that are happening to
us yes it was one of the reasons why
those of us who are trying to manage our
way through this this period of time are
very frustrated with the technology
because it's not smooth it's a very
bumpy and uh it's very difficult to
manage and and try to be fair to
everybody because it it can it can give
the appearance sometimes of unfairness
or at least uneven application of our
process so we're trying and we have we
have staff here to help us and we had we
had a half hour delay today when we
tried to reboot the computer and it uh
and I think we may have done more damage
they had to bring a new computer in to
get us back up live for this exact
session so uh we're we're working on it
I think I think we're doing okay I mean
given given the the Blended technology
uh uh it would it's uh it is a challenge
representative Powell he had something
else they I um suggest to representative
plea that you might want to try
um
re-installing or downloading Zoom that
might alleviate the problem
perhaps I I could possibly
um re-download it but I just upgraded it
last week I don't think there's a new
upgrade to it
um but I'm happy to to to do that
um I don't know voice because I asked
Christine to change my name
um friends call me Trish but my actual
name is Patricia and I would prefer that
to be on the screen and that suddenly
she had changed it and then suddenly it
disappeared so I don't know if this is
part of the
um the glitch that I was
um that that kind of um
messed things up so to speak but um I I
will ask at the beginning of each
meeting to have my name check changed to
Patricia because that is my name so it
could have been something as simple as
that well we've lost about half the
committee but I'm happy to say that I
believe that uh with the exception of
some of these committee reports that
need to be finalized I think we're going
to be done uh for about three weeks or
so uh I'm hearing a rumor that we may
have a General Session sometime around
the first week of April uh but the
details aren't known yet and I think the
venue is going to be the same as the
last one and that the indoor arena so
thank you so you can take some time off
and uh and please help me get those
committee reports done or else the the
legislation won't go through uh properly
so go Mr chairman I'll let you go
okay
thank you all and uh we'll see you next
time watch the calendar and also send
you messages when I when I hear
something about what next time